Jetzt ist es hier so ruhig auf einmal.
Ja, auf einmal macht es gleich den Eindruck, als hätte diese Sendung angefangen.
Ach, die stinkt noch nicht an.
Nee, hat noch nicht angefangen, weil wir haben den Vorhang noch nicht zugemacht.
Ja, aber ist doch egal.
Ohne den Vorhang. Wie sollen wir denn hier Vorhang aufmachen, wenn der Vorhang schon auf ist?
Hat sich hier irgendwas an der Mikrofontechnik mitgemacht?
Ich muss mir noch Taschensücher holen.
Hab ich noch nie an diesem Kabel hier gestört. Plötzlich, heute stört mich das.
Das ist neu, Max.
Das ist neu?
Ja, dann müssen wir dich jetzt leider ausschließen, wenn das jetzt alles nicht mehr passt.
Das reibt mir langsam die Schulter hier auf.
Ja, also ich finde, die Sendung hat jetzt schon offiziell angefangen und wir könnten uns ein bisschen bemühen, den Hörer auch zu erreichen. Ja, ich meine so mental.
Den Hörer.
Die Hörerinnen. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie das bei Mobamix ist, aber bei Not Safe For Work hören uns ja nur Mädchen zu. Und hier, glaube ich, sind auch ein paar Jungs dabei. Also wir grüßen die Jungs da draußen. Und die Mädchen. Ja, die Mädchen eh halt.
Not Safe For Work ist halt von Mädchen für Mädchen.
Jaja, das ist alles aufgezeigt. Dafür kriegen wir jetzt bestimmt wieder so einen Award. So ein Not Safe For Work? Nee, nee, nee, wir haben ja schon...
Wir haben ja nie darüber gesprochen, ne?
Nee, wir haben nie darüber gesprochen, wir waren so geschockt. Was war das nochmal für ein Award? Das war der Macho Award oder so was?
Showvinisten Award.
Showviz Monats oder sowas.
Ist mir total latte.
Den hast du gekriegt, gar nicht wir. Probier das hier nicht reinzuziehen.
Ich? Ja, kannst mal sehen.
Ja, du warst das.
Die Rampensau.
Naja, das war eigentlich gar kein richtiger Award. Ich hab noch überhaupt noch nie einen Award gekriegt. Das find ich sowieso scheiße.
Grimme, wer ist denn mal mit Grimme? Ich hab, als ich bei der Republika... Hör ich mich schon? Auf der Republika hat mich einer von Grimme online im Award unterhalten und hat gesagt, hey, podcast, mach mal den Tim. Gib dir mal Grimme.
Und?
Ja, klingt auf jeden Fall spannend.
Ach so, na gut. Ich wüsste, dass ihr auch noch mal auf einer nominierten Liste landet.
Ach, die sind schon wieder raus? Aber das ist echt peinlich.
Max ist ja Grimme gesegnet.
Genau. Bei Spritblick damals.
Spritblick hat doch mal den Topf geholt, der war so grimme wie ein Online-Topf. Was grabs denn da eigentlich?
Kode? Nee, gibt's glaub ich nicht. Nee, nee, du kriegst so ein Glas-Pokal.
Und die Erlaubnis, dich mit dem Logo auf deiner Webseite schmücken zu können.
Ah ja.
Wahrscheinlich, ne?
Vermutlich so was in der Richtung. Und du darfst halt, du kriegst ein, alles was gesponsert ist, ist gut, alles was nicht gesponsert ist, ist schlecht. Also Hotel war total scheiße, Chefs & Servers war super, Buffet war so mittel. Und es war halt so ne Party dann. Kann man machen.
Na gut, naja, mal schauen. Vielleicht schaffen wir es ja hier mit Mobile Macs auch noch. Da müssen wir wahrscheinlich erstmal den Namen ändern.
Ja, das hatten wir auch schon mal.
Also, wir begrüßen alle nochmal ganz herzlich. Das hier ist Ausgabe Nummer 55. Und jetzt sind wir so ein bisschen warm. Ich hab auch den Flash Samplizer gemacht. Haben so viele zurecht beschwert. Ich soll ja mal keine behaupten, wir würden hier auch kontinuierlich innovative Verbesserungen mit ein.
Nach drei Sendungen.
Man darf ja jetzt auch nicht auf den erstbesten Kommentar hören. Das kann ja auch einfach zu viel für einen Troll sein.
Wo kommst du denn so?
Bloß weil du deine Kopfhörer zu laut eingestellt hast. Weil du deinen Jailbreak gemacht hast und deine von Apple, DIA auferlegte Lautstärkenbegrenzung ausgeschaltet hast. Müssen sie. Ja, worum war das? Müssen sie das in den USA? Hier müssen sie das machen. EU, FU, genau, weil die Ohren müssen geschützt werden. Das ist auch so ein Jugend... Jugend-Schutz-Teil.
Ich war nie, auch nur ansatzweise dran, an der maximalen Lautstärke, egal ob EU oder ohne EU.
Das ist halt ein sehr feines Gehör. Tim ist laut und leise gleichzeitig.
Sagen sie ja.
Laut und leise gleichzeitig.
Das halte ich ja für ein Gerücht.
Dann ist deine Kompression falsch.
Meine Kompression ist...
Mit deiner Kompression stimmt was nicht.
Ja, ich hab eigentlich hier...
Ich wollte jetzt nur mal das Demonstrieren.
Ich bin hier gar nicht so komprimiert. Ich kann mich noch ein bisschen lauter machen.
Dennis hat noch gar nichts gesagt. Deswegen ist Dennis leise.
Dennis, sag doch mal, was Dennis kommt. Du bist voll da. Wir sollten vielleicht über unsere Kernthemen reden. Wobei dieser Metakram ist ja auch ganz gut.
Genau, unser Name. Was ist denn jetzt hier mit MacHackers?
Du willst, dass wir uns MacHackers nennen?
Naja, das war zumindest so ein Name, der mir umhergeistert hat.
Stimmt eigentlich. MacHackers Mailing List, MacHackers Podcast.
Obwohl er das eine mit dem anderen so direkt nicht zu tun hat, außer, dass wir das mal losgetreten haben.
Und?
Was ist denn MacHackers Mailing List?
Das ist ja voll den Aufstand. MacHackers Mailing List hat mir ja schon mal erwähnt.
Keine Ahnung.
Die MacHackers Mailing List, die gibt's seit sehr langer Zeit mittlerweile. Ich weiß nicht, wann?
Stimmt 10 Jahre mindestens.
Aber die ist gut. Das ist eine gute Mailing List, eine freundliche Mailing List. Das findet man nicht überall im Internet.
Wobei letztens wurde, glaube ich, einer angeranzt, weil er sich erdreistet hat, auf der Liste nach einer One-Password-Lizenz zu fragen. Und dann hat einer gesagt, Alter, das geht ja gar nicht. Und dann der nächste hat ihm gleich eine geschickt oder so.
Ja, es gibt immer mal da so Aufreger.
Das ist halt Mailing List, oder?
Ja, aber damals haben wir da auch echt gutes Housekeeping gemacht. Einmal gab es einen, der war unfreundlich. Den haben wir ja gleich rausgeschmissen. Nach dem Motto hier nicht. Mac Hacker, ich weiß nicht, mal gucken, wie das so resoniert hier in den Kommentaren. Bitte?
Mac Hacker, Mailing List ist auch so.
Was?
20. Jahrhundert, oder?
Du, Mailing List ist immer noch eine geile Technologie, deren Wert, auch von Apple übrigens, nicht ausreichend gewürdigt wird. Ich weiß nicht seit wie vielen Versionen ich schon so Feature Request in Richtung Cupertino schicke, dass sie doch bitte mal Mailing-Listen-Support in diesen Client einbauen sollen. Also ich begreife nicht, warum das nicht geht.
Das kann so einfach sein. Aber was ist denn der Support genau?
Ich stell mir so was vor, wie das erst mal das Mail-Programm in der Lage ist, selber zu erkennen, dass eine Mail von einer Mailing-Liste kommt und dann einem gleich zum Beispiel anbietet, einen Folder dafür zu machen oder es irgendwie so einen anderen View zu machen. Und dass ich dann eben für diese Mailing-Liste auch gleich Einstellungen machen kann. Zum Beispiel, mit welcher E-Mail-Adresse ich auf dieser Mailing-Liste posten möchte, weil man eben nicht selten... Ich weiß, das ist alles nicht so dieser Bare-Bones-Konsumer-Teil und das wird sie wahrscheinlich am Ende auch von solchen Sperenzchen immer wieder abhalten, aber es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt auch keine Advanced-User auf dieser Plattform wären.
Also ich benutze ja...
Ich meine, wie oft passiert euch das, dass ihr auf eine Mailing-Liste eine Mail schreibt und die bounce, weil ihr wieder die falsche Bekomponente habt?
Da und bei Mobile Max alleine schon. Aber ich benutze ja Postbox als Mail-Client, was ja so jetzt der advancedeste vielleicht GUI-Client gerade ist.
Postbox? Ist das nicht so ein Gmail-Teil?
Nee, der basiert halt auf Mozilla-Technologie, aber hat eine relativ nativ dreinschauende GUI. Die gibt es halt für Mac und Windows. Die ersten Versionen waren alle relativ unbrauchbar, aber jetzt die aktuellen Versionen, die haben halt schon ein paar Features, die Apple Mail halt nicht hat. Und sie geben sich irgendwie Mühe, das Mozilla-Interface zu verstecken. Also immer mehr native GUIs und nicht mehr diesen Thunderbird-Account-View und so. Sondern es wird.
Ach, das ist hier wie Thunderbird mit demselben, wie heißt das noch gleich, dieses API, das sie da benutzen? Ist das eine Zool-Anwendung?
Oder ist das native?
Glaubt das nur auf dem Mac oder ist das?
Mac und Windows sogar, glaube ich.
Wirklich?
Also ich glaube, es gibt keinen Linux-Client, aber da... Ja, die haben ja eh alle andere Clients, Konsole und so. Nee, aber...
Ist das irgendwie gut? Also ich meine, kann ich damit irgendwas nicht tun, was ich mit Mail abtun kann?
Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Also es ist eher andersrum, würde ich mal behaupten.
Und was fehlt dann? Also Spotlight Search und so weiter hat da?
Spotlight Search hat da auch, ja. Ja, was fehlt denn? Eigentlich... Eigentlich fehlt nichts. Also Mailing ist ein Support, wenn du das jetzt als Feature, also was ich durchaus nachvollziehen kann, weil das Problem höre ich auch häufig, weil ich doch auch auf ein paar Mailing-Listen subscibed bin.
Ja, das ist auch gar nicht so schwierig. Ich meine, es gibt normierte Header. Es gibt dieses List-ID als Header, das ist irgendwie ein akzeptiertes FC und meines Wissens unterstützen das mehr oder weniger alle. Manche machen auch Mailing-Listen noch so einen Header rein.
Aber das ist ja alles mein...
Genau, die machen das einfach. Und das heißt, wenn eine Mail von einer Mailing-Liste kommt, dann ist das als solche sofort erkennbar und du hast ja auch die ganzen Meta-Laten drin. Wie ansubscribe ich mich von dieser Liste? Wie subscribe ich mir von dieser Liste? Und auch dafür könnte man einfach einen User-Interface anbieten und sie tun es nicht. Dann kommt diese Mail und dann weiß er ja auch an welchen Account es geht. Dann kann er das auch gleich entsprechend konfigurieren und sagen, ah, hier hast du eine Mail bekommen von einer Mailing. Du bist wahrscheinlich auf einer Mailing. Soll ich dir das einrichten? Ja, nein. Zack. Und dann fragt er dich, mit welchem Account möchtest du hier posten by default und das anklicken?
Naja, also genau, also diese Sachen gibt's halt nicht, aber es gibt halt so ein paar andere coole Features, was ich zum Beispiel bei Mail-App immer ein bisschen nervig finde. Zum Beispiel, wenn du halt irgendwie eine Mail kriegst von jemandem, von dem du jetzt länger nichts mehr gehört hast und so, aber du weißt irgendwas war da zuletzt, gibt's halt gleich so ein Button in der Sidebar, zeig mir mal alle Messages von dem und dann hast du halt so ein Instant-View auf alle Messages von diesem einen Typen. Oh ja, das find ich auch cool. Oder wenn's Attachments gibt, dann sind die halt so schön sauber an der Seite aufgelistet und die Links sind gleich, also es gibt halt so Attachments, Links, Messages und so weiter. Kannst alles so direkt in so einer Sidebar von der E-Mail anklicken und kommst dann direkt in den View. Oder kannst eben direkt auf die Links nochmal gesonnen. Also hast du die Meta-Information nochmal an der Seite.
Hast du da auch einen Gmail-Account drin?
Äh, nee, hab ich nicht. Ich habe, aber, doch, ich habe Gmail, aber benutze ich nur für so Spam-Sachen und so.
Was ja total sackt, ist so Gmail über IMAP benutzen. Also ich benutze Gmail eigentlich nicht über das Web-Interface, sondern halt über IMAP, wie alle anderen auch. Und die Art und Weise, wie Google IMAP und Folder verkackt hat, das ist wirklich kaum zu schlagen. Also dieses Label-Modell, also ich finde diese Label-Idee an sich, finde ich ganz gut. Weißt du, wovon ich Rede mag?
Ja, ja, ich nutze sogar das Web-Interface von Gmail.
Ja, also, ja, wobei ich habe halt so Schwierigkeiten. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich eine Nachricht lösche. Also mir gelingt es nicht, meine Nachrichten zu löschen. Über IMAP, über IMAP. Im Web-Interface klar, da kann ich das irgendwie markieren und löschen und da löscht er das dann auch. Aber wenn ich irgendwie lösche, dann wird das irgendwie mehr als gelöscht markiert, aber geht irgendwie alles nicht weg.
Ja, die haben doch...
Was mein Problem, mein Kernproblem ist, und das habe ich mit ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Mail-Providen, ist so dieses, wie diese Default-Folder benannt sind. Also wo geht die... heißt der Ordner Spam oder heißt der Junk? Und ist das jetzt deleted messages oder ist es was weiß ich so? Und dann habe ich verschiedene Setups auf verschiedenen Rechnern, die alle auf denselben Account zugreifen und dann lösche ich irgendwelche Mails oder denke, dass ich sie lösche und dann tauchen sie in anderen Ordnern auf und der Spam ist auf dem Rechner da.
Aber ich glaube, dafür gibt es keinen Standard. Du kannst aber in Mail auswählen, in welcher Ordner wofür du zuständig bist.
Ja na klar, aber ich weiß nicht, welchen ich da einstellen soll. Also ich weiß immer nicht, welchen der jeweilige... Also was zum Beispiel sind die Default-Folder bei Gmail?
Das hängt immer von der Sprache an, in der du es eingestellt hast.
Ja, aber mal ehrlich, weißt du es, was sie machen sollen? Na ja, sie sollen es ja irgendwie sagen. Also wie heißt der Ordner auf IMAP, wo Spam drin ist? Heißt der Spam oder heißt der Junk? Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, das ist das Bettentafels einfach.
Also das ist halt bei Postbox, darum benutze ich den eigentlich auch. Weil was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich hatte halt vorher ganz viele unterschiedliche IMAP-Accounts auf vielen unterschiedlichen Servern. Und das hat mich immer genervt bei auf dem iPhone, wenn du dann die ganzen Accounts hast und du hast halt nicht Server-Filter-Rules für den Spam und den ganzen Kram, ist halt unmöglich zu lesen. Deswegen habe ich alle meine Accounts quasi auf einen konsolidiert. Das heißt, alle meine anderen Mail-Accounts forwarden jetzt auf einen IMAP-Account. Und auf dem Server habe ich so einen Stapel Filter-Rules, die das in IMAP-Folder einsortiert. Das heißt, ich habe eine Inbox und in meiner Inbox habe ich dann Huckel, add so und so, Huckel, add sowieso, Huckel, add weiß ich nicht, .com. Also noch mal unter Folder und da kommen dann die von den alten Accounts geforwardeten Mails reinsortiert. Und da kannst du halt in Postbox total flexibel konfigurieren, wo jetzt was genau passieren soll und welcher Ordner der Junk für alle ist zum Beispiel. Oder willst du für jeden Einzel-, also willst du für jeden geforwardeten Account einen einzelnen Junk-Folder haben und so ne Sachen. Also das kannst du da halt echt cool einstellen. Und deswegen habe ich den auch benutzt, weil bei Mail gab es diese Flexibilität der Ordner, Zuweisung nicht und also mit einem Web kommt der halt viel besser klar als Apple Mail.
Hat der richtige Threading, so Multiple Levels Threading. Das ist auch noch so ein Feature, was ich extrem vermisse.
Ja, das haben immer die Konsolen-Klines vor allen Dingen.
Vor allem hatten früher die Usenet-Klines. Wie hieß noch dieser congeniale Usenet-Kline unter Mac OS? Also dieser richtig geile...
Warte mal kurz.
Ich hab Usenet nie genutzt.
Kann ich dir mal kurz zeigen? Weiß ich nicht.
Dennis, weißt du das noch?
Es gab einen, aber den meinst du garantiert nicht unison?
Nee, der ist ja so ein Mac OS 10. Ich rede nur von Mac OS. Da gab's... Es hat ein deutscher programmiert. Nee, ich seh den nicht.
Aber hier, guck mal, ganz kurz. Ich zeig dir nur mal kurz. Also da klappst du halt hier auf wie bei Apple Mail und dann hast du aber hier unten in dem View sozusagen die ganzen Messages so gleich als Konversation angezeigt.
Ah, wenn man sozusagen mehrere Andings, dann packt er die untereinander.
Oder wenn du oben den ersten anklickst, dann zeigt da unten halt die Konversation an. Und du hast halt überall hier so einen Quick-Reply-Button und kannst dann direkt aus dieser Konversation dir auf die gewünschte Mail responden und so.
Sieht das aus wie eine OS-10-App oder sieht das so ein bisschen aus wie ich würde lieber unterliegen und kaufen?
Sie benutzen halt nicht so Standard-Mac-Icons in der Toolbar, würde ich mal sagen. Aber abgesehen davon...
Die Controls meine ich so.
Tubbing, nicht alles irgendwie. Ja, ne, doch, da geben sich schon Mühe. Also...
Hört das mal testen.
Genau, teste mal. Also es ist halt Payware, du kannst es 30 Tage so testen.
Ach echt, das ist geil. Und ich liebe es, wenn es Software Geld kostet. Ja, da kann man hinschreiben und sagen, ich wäre noch glücklicher, wenn ich das mache.
Die sind sehr häufig.
Weil wenn du an Tv schreibst, dann kriegst du immer so eine, programmierst du doch selbst.
Ja, und die wollen halt auch viel Feedback, also die freuen sich auch immer, wenn die voll piped.
Pa, das sind die Besten. Gibt's da nicht so viele Puhamira bei dir?
Ich hab schon früher auch wieder das alte Twitter-Phänomen auf Twitter über Postbox gerandet, weil da gab's halt so Versionen, die waren auch ein bisschen Arschlamm. Und Arschlamm, naja. Auf jeden Fall haben sie da auch gleich auf Twitter reagiert und meinten, ja, wieso, erzähl mal, was machst du denn? Ja, ich hab halt viel Mail. Und also, mittlerweile kommt da auch mit viel Mail doch recht gut klar.
Also ich hab mit Mail ab. Grundsätzlich muss ich sagen, bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Ja, bis auf das IMAP.
Was heißt denn grundsätzlich sehr zufrieden? Grundsätzlich bin ich zufrieden. Ich bin nicht sehr zufrieden. Sehr zufrieden wäre ich, wenn es keine Probleme gäbe.
Also das, was Apple mir am meisten sagt, ist einfach das mit dem IMAP, dass sie das nicht richtig können.
Wieso, was machen sie denn da falsch?
Na, sie benutzen, also es gibt ja viele Interpretationen von IMAP, ja, und wie man das so richtig sprechen würde, aber es gibt ja schon so einen RFC. Und dann gibt es halt einen, es gibt einen einzigen IMAP-D, der den Standard berücksichtigt, und das ist ja dieser DAF-Cut. Alle anderen machen immer so mit Custom Extensions und so ein bisschen eigenen Zeug. Und wenn du das so richtig standardkonform fährst und so, dann kannst du trotzdem nicht in Apple Mail deine Folder verwalten und neue anlegen und umsortieren. Weißt du, da gibt es halt dieses Apple-E auf deinem Account, und dann kommen ja die Folder und die Subscriptions auf Folder. Und du kannst halt nicht im Client auf Folder subscriben. Und das habe ich jetzt schon, also das funktioniert vielleicht mit 1% aller Mails, die ich jemals gesehen habe, out of the box.
Ach so, dass wenn sich in einem Folder was ändert, dass er das dann auch sofort anzeigt.
Ja, oder dass du einfach, also bei IMAP kannst du ja Folder subscriben. Das heißt, du kannst dann sozusagen ein Folder in so einem Firmenfolder hast für irgendein Projekt, legst halt Projekt XY als IMAP-Folder an, und dann können sich die Leute alle darauf subscriben. Und dann kriegen alle die Mail, die in diesem Folder liegt, sozusagen in ihren Client delivered. Und das kann Apple Mail nicht, und deswegen benutzt das auch keiner, darum wissen auch die meisten nicht von diesem Feature.
Aber sie haben ja eine Subscription-List und einen Subscribed-Button.
Genau, aber das funktioniert halt, wie gesagt, mit gefühlten 1% aller Mail-Servern da draußen.
Welchen denn? me.com?
Ja, wahrscheinlich, genau. Oder es gibt auch... Was hat denn Apple auf OS X Server benutzt? Cyrus oder Thief? Cyrus. Genau, mit dem OS X. Cyrus ging das auch, aber die Settings da hinzukriegen, damit das spielt, ist echt ein Pain und wenn du halt...
Aber Cyrus war natürlich lange, lange Zeit eigentlich die Referenz, was so IMAP betrifft.
Ja, aber Daft Cat ist jetzt... Ist jetzt die Referenz? Der neue König. Also, ja.
Taubenkot.
Genau. Ich hab mir irgendwie in der Uni hab ich ja so einen Mail-Server mal von From Scratch aufgesetzt und hab dementsprechend in echt viele Ecken geschnuppert und ja, also IMAP und Apple Mail, das ist so eine... Da sind andere Clients schon echt besser in der Hinsicht. Also einfach von Features, was sie so einfach supporten und wo sie mal ein Auge zudrücken, wenn der Server nicht so akkuliert ist.
Was mich total verwirrt sind so Bugs, was ich zum Beispiel häufig habe, so gefühlt alle 14 Tage für so ein paar Stunden kommt der mir so hoch und zeigt mir jede Nachricht doppelt an. Das find ich auch richtig cool. Das verschwindet dann wieder von alleine aus. Das macht einen total irre. Weil, weißte noch nicht, kann ich jetzt ein Doppel auch löschen oder ist dann, wenn er sich wieder befangen hat, die Mail dann auch weg? Ich hab auch so das Gefühl, mir geht Mail verloren. Das kann ich nicht belegen. Vielleicht hab ich auch nicht Recht, aber ich finde manchmal Sachen nicht wieder. Und was mich generell stört und was jetzt nicht Apples Schuld ist in dem Sinne, aber guck mal, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel ein iPad kaufst, wir haben ja schon immer mal darüber gemutmaßt, so iPad ist ja eine neue Generation Computer und es gibt Leute, die wollen nur ein iPad haben, dann frag ich mich immer, wie machen die denn das eigentlich mit Mail und Spam und so Filter rollt's. Ja, ich meine das geht da gar nicht und bei mir ist es immer so, damit ich Mail auf meinem iPhone benutzen kann, muss einer meiner Macs laufen und die ganze Zeit die Mail filtern, damit da irgendwie der Spam ordentlich rauskommt.
Aber da gibt's halt ein cooles Setup eigentlich. Also ich filter jetzt ja alle meine Mail möglichst auf dem Server, damit ich auf dem iPhone nicht den ganzen Schrott krieg, das heißt alles, was irgendwie...
Und wer kann das?
Naja, kannst du halt bei vielen Server, kannst du Filter rollt's machen, natürlich.
Wer kann was nicht?
Server-Site. Server-Site filter rollt's. Na überall, wo du so ein hässliches Squirrel-Mail hast und die Atmos das eingeschaltet haben.
Eigentlich doch wirklich jeder. Gmail, GMX hat einen Spam, web.de hat Spam, Hotmail, die haben alle Spam.
Der Spam-Filter ist ja das eine. Das heißt ja, der tagt es dir im Zweifel und so. Aber dann ist ja dein Client da, der das wegsortiert.
Du musst ja auch deine eigenen Rules haben. Es geht ja nicht nur um Spam. Also bei mir ist es so, die Spam-Situation auf meinen Accounts derzeit ist einfach so, wenn ich nicht noch ein Mail ablaufen habe mit seinem lokalen Junk-Filter, hab ich auf dem iPhone 80% Spam. Das ist ja in Ordnung, aber ich könnte Gmail, ich hab das schon mehrfach probiert und erwogen auch auf Gmail zu gehen, aber da kommen so Sachen wie, wenn zu viele Clients laufen, dann hört der einfach auf. Ja, too many Requests und so'n Kack. Dann hab ich Message-Größenbeschränkungen. Oder ist das nur bei den Google Groups? Das ist wahrscheinlich nur bei den Google Groups. Also, ich würde halt, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall möchtest du bestimmte Sachen, was weiß ich, deine Nachrichten von Twitter oder Facebook, ja, wer dir jetzt wieder folgt oder keine Ahnung, eine Nachricht geschrieben hat und angenommen du willst diesen Scheiß auch haben und bestellst ihn nicht ab, dann willst du den unter Umständen in so'n Folder reinpacken, damit dir das nicht die Inbox zuhagelt. Ja, da liest du eine Regel an, aber du musst diese Regel ja auf dem Server anlegen. Und dafür gibt es keinerlei, naja.
Kein Standard?
Standard?
Ach so, ja, das gibt's nicht.
Doch, gibt's schon.
Iris hat sowas, aber das hat sie nicht.
Nee, ich kann dich für dich durchgesetzt. Also ich kann ja mal noch von meinem Setup hier kurz einfach weiterberichten, ja. Also ich hab ja, da gibt's ja dieses, bei DaafCut, also früher hat man ja mit Proc-Mail oder was auch immer da auf dem Server Mails gefiltert. Und heutzutage ist der Standardweg halt CIF. Genau, und DaafCut hat jetzt auch seine eigene CIF-Implementation und dann gibt's noch eine Erweiterung davon, Managed CIF. Und das erlaubt sozusagen auch Clients, also wenn du in deinem Mail-Programm, zum Beispiel, wenn du Postbox benutzt, kannst du dir eine Managed CIF-Extension installieren und kannst in deinem Client die Rules auf dem Server editieren.
Nein.
Doch.
In Postbox?
Ja. Nein. Doch. Und dann geht aber noch weiter.
Gibt es das auch für Mail-Up?
Ja, Plugins und Mail-Up halt. Gibt's vielleicht, weiß ich aber nicht.
Managed CIF.
Managed CIF ist der heiße Scheiß. Und zwar, dann hab ich mir noch ein Web-Mail-Interface in der Uni installiert.
Steve, wir brauchen Managed Steve.
In der Uni hab ich mir dann halt noch ein Web-Mail-Interface installiert und da gibt's ja eigentlich nur Squirrel-Mail und noch so zwei, drei andere, aber die sind fast noch schlimmer, auch wenn sie nicht ganz so hässlich sind. Und dann hab ich halt Roundcube gefunden und Roundcube ist halt auch open source und ist so mit Ajax und Clickybunti und Schicko.
Roundcube ist ein Web-Interface.
Roundcube ist ein Web-Mailer. Ist gar nicht schlecht. Und ist ziemlich cool für deinen eigenen Server. Und da kannst du halt eben auch diese Filterregeln total komfortabel mit Drag & Drop und hast du nicht gesehen installieren.
Der macht auch Sieve. Das heißt du, der macht dann sozusagen dasselbe Protokoll. Das heißt du kannst sowohl im Web-Interface deine Sieve-Filterregeln machen, als auch mit deinem Client.
Ja, bei mir ist ja eigentlich auch alles total easy. Ähnlich wie bei HTTP ist ja alles so text-based. Und diese Sieve-Rules, die liegen halt auch in deinem IMAP-Folder als ein Text-File. Und das wird halt von diesem Managed Sieve ganz einfach interpretiert. Und jetzt hab ich es halt so, dass ich halt meine Twitter-Nachrichten, den ganzen Scheiß halt auf den Server wegfilter, damit ich auf dem iPhone nicht damit gestresst werde. Mein Spam, ab einer bestimmten Spam-Score schicke ich auch gleich in den Junk-Folder. Und dann gibt es halt noch, das will ich jetzt demnächst machen, dass ich noch ein IMAP-Folder habe, Spam und Ham. Und wenn du da nämlich dann deine Mail reinsortierst, kann man eigentlich auf dem iPhone-Mails moveen in einer Folder. Dann wär das schon mal gut. Weil dann kannst du deinen Spam-Filter halt auch on the fly trainieren.
Das ist cool, das haben wir ja irgendwie bei dieser Wissen-Schon-Installation. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr cooles Konzept, finde ich.
Genau, das bau ich mir da jetzt auch demnächst.
Das ersetzt dann auch so die Runde Angry Birds. Also wenn man beim Arzt wartet, dann kann man auch so ein bisschen Hemm- und Spam-Filter. Also die guten ins Köpfchen, schlechten ins Töpfchen oder was.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin jetzt auch echt total zufrieden damit. So meine fünf Mail-Accounts auf einen redirected Server-Rules kann ich überall konfigurieren und klicken. Mit Postbox kann ich dann eben sagen...
Der Huckel, der lebt im 21. Jahrhundert.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich. Ich hab ja auch über Jahre hinweg meinen eigenen Mail-Server aufgesetzt in diesem ganzen Scheißdreck.
Das nervt, ne?
Und dann irgendwann kriegt dann doch mal durch eine Sicherheitslücke kommt da irgendjemand rein und verschickt Spam über deinen Server und du hast ein Problem und weiß ja toll was. Ich lasse das jetzt alles über Gmail laufen, richte die auch mal standardmäßig als Mail-Exchange ein, sodass da auch wirklich alles draufflanscht und dann hat sich der Salat. Das ist so...
Ja, eine Uni hat halt keinen Bock auf Google.
Nachvollziehbar. Aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen. Ich verstehe auch jeden, der keinen Google hat, aber mit Spam habe ich wirklich keine Probleme. Also ich kriege alle paar Wochen mal eine Spam-Mail, die durchkommt.
Und kein Schwein schickt mir Spam.
Doch, doch, da kommt schon eine ganze Menge, aber es landet halt immer irgendwo anders. Und so diese serverseitigen Regeln und dieses ganze Zirkus-Interface ist bei weitem nicht perfekt von Gmail.
Das hat mich echt erschrocken, wie schlecht das ist, weil letztens habe ich mir mal an ein Gmail-Account geklickt und dachte mir, okay, wo kann ich denn jetzt hier mal konfigurieren?
Was willst du denn konfigurieren?
Na irgendwie halt auch mit diesem IMAP, das muss man erstmal ja einmal einschalten. Und dann halt mit irgendwelchen Gruppen und also, weiß nicht, dieses Interface war einfach, also ich finde, Interface-Design, da könnten sie echt mal eine Schippe drauflegen.
Aber eine große, also wirklich. Neulich ist mir nämlich aufgefallen, dass ich versehentlich immer wieder Termine im falschen Monat angelegt habe, im Google-Kalender.
Oder im falschen Kalender.
Naja, im falschen Kalender ging es auch. Aber im falschen Monat, weil man hat dann diese Monatsansicht offen. Und wo man auswählt, wo man das Datum auswählt, dann sagt man... Und dann sind ja immer noch gern mal die letzten Tage des vorherigen Monats und die ersten Tage des nächsten Monats angezeigt. Und bei Gmail haben die dieselbe Farbe wie der Monat, in dem du gerade bist. Dann klickst du auf, sagen wir, auf Januar und sagst dann, ja 28, das stimmt. Und dann hast du aber versehentlich den Termin auf den 28. Dezember gelegt oder sowas. Total ätzend, bloß weil die keine Grautöne können. Aber ansonsten hier diese Threaded-Ansicht, sodass man hier so diese ganzen Mails nachverfolgen kann einfach und so. Das ist echt gut. Und die haben schönes, ein echt schickes iPad-Interface für Gmail mittlerweile. Das macht echt eine Menge her.
Das hab ich noch nicht gesehen, aber globig. Gut, haben wir jetzt mal hier von Technologie aus den 80ern genug geredet?
Also was ich finde, ist ja, wenn sie die Filterregeln hin und her, dass ein scheiß iPhone einfach mal auch filtern können muss, ist ja noch nicht so schwer. Power haben die ja nun genug, oder? Zwischen den ganzen Spams hin und her zu scrollen, die Zeit, in der da das Display an ist, da hätten sie auch irgendwie die Akkuleistung zum Wegfiltern benutzen können.
Ja, aber irgendwie ist es der falsche Ansatz, dass mein Telefon mit Cloud-Computing und weiß ja teurer ist, dass dann mein Telefon anfangen soll, Mails auszufiltern. Sowas gehört auf den Server. Dafür muss es einen Standard geben im Zweifelsfall und dann sollen sie halt den implementieren und dann sollen sie das alle nutzen. Damit ich dann irgendwo im Ausland im Zweifelsfall teure Roaming-Gebühr zahle, damit ich den ganzen Spam auch kriege und so.
Außerdem ist es jetzt nur ein Ausrede, das ist mir egal. Im Ausland ist so oder so teuer. Aber der Tag ist ja schon drin, ob der Spam ist oder nicht. Da brauchst du ja nur zur Seite schieben oder von mir aus nicht anzeigen oder was auch immer. Ist doch schon einmal. Bist du alle schon da?
Den Junk wegschieben könnte er auf jeden Fall.
Ja, also der ist ja bei mir schon vorgetaggt durch den Server. So ist er nicht. Nur mein Server macht den halt...
Warum sagst du nicht, dem Server packt er einen anderen Owner rein?
Ich hab da keinen Zugriff. Bei Krücken.
Aber Bock auf dem iPhone, die Filterregeln, oder was?
Naja, aber das kann man halt wegsatieren.
Macht ja Apple Mail auch.
Ja eben. Also den Source, den Code, das haben die alle schon da. Aber nein, Steve hat gesagt, verkauft das mal jetzt noch nicht, weil dann hab ich beim nächsten Mal nichts zu erzählen, weil mit dem nächsten Update kommt das nicht.
Genau, unser Blick in die Glaskugel.
Da ist doch so.
Das ist alles, was das können wird. So eine Zeit, die er 4 Stunden lang regelreinrichtet.
Wahrscheinlich wird's kommen.
Jetzt haben wir bestimmt schon wieder 10 Kommentare, dass das bei Android natürlich alles geht.
Klar geht es da alles, weil die Features halt nicht zurückhalten.
Bei Android ist das einfach so, die sagen, nimm Gmail, fertig.
Ja, Gmail ist aber auch nicht wirklich...
Ich finde einfach cool, dass Jahu sich ymail.com geklickt hat. Das ist nicht gut. Y-Mail, also Y-Mail. Also mein ältester Mail-Account ist auch bei Jahu tatsächlich. Ja, ich auch immer noch.
Kennt ihr das? Es gibt angeblich Rating-Agenturen, die, wenn du irgendwo Kredit beantragst, da fließen alle möglichen Daten mit ein. In Amerika fließt da mittlerweile die E-Mail-Adresse mit ein. Und ein Hotmail-Account ist schon mal ein Grund, dir ein schlechtes Rating zu geben. Gmail-Account ist ein gutes Rating.
Amerika, fuck yeah! Dieses Sample von America, fuck yeah! Hier, das brauchen wir auch noch auf dem Soundboard. Von Team America, weißt du schon, ne? Hotmail, E-Mail-Adresse, Rating, abgestuft bei US.
Okay, na vielleicht können wir das ja einer hier gerade mal, der zuhört, irgendwie schnippeln in ordentlicher Qualität.
Return-Boom-Zack, oder wie?
Boom-Zack-Return.
Wollen wir jetzt mal mit einem spannenden Thema...
Aber ich hab hier gerade einen Fehler im Apple-Wetterdienst gefunden, weil überall ist jetzt hier ein Minus vor den Temperaturen.
Wir fangen mit den heißen Themen an, ja.
Also letzte Woche war hier nicht überall ein Minus, da ist doch irgendwas am Interface hier kaputt gegangen.
Oh und zwar relativ kleine Minus auch. Also relativ tiefe Minus.
Womit wollen wir anfangen, oder womit wollen wir weitermachen? Ein iPhone?
Apropos Minustemperatur, dann kann ich doch hier mal die Dinger kurz rausholen.
Ah, gutes Thema, Minustemperatur.
Du hast mehrere Dinger, die du rausholen kannst.
Ich hab mehrere Dinger, die ich rausholen kann.
Genau, das Problem ist ja, man muss jetzt Handschuhe tragen. Und da ist man natürlich mit dem modernen Smartphone, weil es ist ein bisschen am Arsch, wegen der mangelnden Leitung der kapazitiven......kapazitiven... Wissen schon, man leitet nicht mehr. Und jetzt hast du hier so spaceige... Mit so...
Mit so Power-Tasten.
Das heißt, du kannst nur mit zwei Fingern Multitouch machen?
Ich hab zwei Finger, mit denen ich Multitouch machen kann. An jeder Hand. Ich hatte das schon ein bisschen befürchtet.
Wie würdest du damit einen Triple Tap machen?
Was brauchen wir da? Der Triple Tap?
Naja, so Accessibility-Features, Zooming und so weiter.
Ach so, wenn ich jetzt VoiceOver nutzen würde.
Ja, nee, auch so Zoom gibt's ja auch, wenn du zum Beispiel so Bildschirmzooming machen willst.
Zoom macht man mit zwei Fingern.
Nein, nein, das ist Pinchen. Nee, Zoom, alles, der ganze...
Ja, ja, okay, für die ganzen...
Der ganze Screen. Nicht das Programm macht es, sondern das OS macht es.
So diese Features für...
Ja, das ist eine Art Mac, wenn du irgendwie Ctrl, Maus drückst.
Ja, das geht auch.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall drei Fingergesten im iOS.
Ja, okay, die kann man halt nicht machen, während man Handschuhe anhat.
Vielleicht mal ein Backreport an North Face.
Doch, du kannst sie machen, du musst nur beide Hände benutzen.
Ja, aber dann kann ich ja das iPhone nicht mehr halten.
Okay, was hast du da für Teile von North Face?
Die sind von North Face, die man ja eigentlich nicht kaufen sollte, weil North Face ganz, ganz schlecht seine Nähe bezahlt.
Na, macht das die leider nicht?
Ja, es gibt welche, Mammut ist wohl toll.
Also sozusagen mit dem Blut siebenjähriger indischer Kinder.
Genau, das haben sie aber sehr schön gemacht. Es sind kaum noch Blutspuren dran. Was ich am Anfang für total albern hielt, aber hier ist auf dem einen Finger, der ist so ein bisschen silberner, da ist so eine Power-Taste drauf. Da dachte ich, was ist das für ein Bullshit? Ist mir vorhin aufgefallen, wenn man nämlich im Dunkeln steht, was ja im Winter öfters mal passiert, dann sieht man den eigenen Finger noch so halbwegs. Weil das Silberne hier auf dem Zeigefinger dann auch reflektiert. Also das ist schon relativ durchdacht das ganze Ding.
Und warum ist da eine Power-Taste drauf?
Wahrscheinlich Power-Taste wegen, weil das...
Der Power-Finger ist.
Weil der sehr Power-Finger ist.
Achso, ich dachte, du musst da auf deinen Finger drauf drücken.
Genau, dann leuchtet's.
Das wär so Bluetooth-Handschuhe, ne? Das wär eigentlich ganz cool, womit man das Teil auch anlocken kann und so.
Also auf jeden Fall, ich bin echt... Mit so Gestenerkennung. Die Bedienung geht erstaunlich gut. Das ist wirklich so eigentlich nicht wesentlich schlechter als...
Soll ich die Temperatur mal kurz runterdrehen?
Ja, drehen wir mal kurz die Temperatur und dann demonstrieren wir das mal. Man kann sogar... Man kann sogar vernünftig tippen und ähnliche Späße. Machst du jetzt so ein bisschen Minus-Qualität?
Ja, ich hab mal auf Minus gemacht, damit Dennis Anzeige wieder richtig ist. Das iPhone ist auch überhaupt nicht in der Lage, die Raumtemperatur richtig anzuzeigen. Das ist mir auch schon aufgeregt.
Aber was natürlich so Handschuhe für einen extremen Nachteil haben, die sind relativ dünn. Ich meine, die bringen was. Also es ist nicht mehr ganz so kalt wie ohne Handschuhe.
Wir sind nicht wirklich warm. Und wie findet die Durchleitung statt, wenn du deinen Finger reinmachst? Bohrt sich da so eine Nadel in dein Fleisch, damit er auch ordentlich Kontakt ist?
Jaja, genau. Das wird einfach so ein bisschen Feuchtigkeit abgesaugt. Und das wird dann auch, das ist dann für die Leeren wieder, damit die wieder ein bisschen Blut nähen. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das läuft. Guck, so sieht das aus. Aber es funktioniert. Also es funktioniert wirklich gut. Guck, so sieht das hier aus.
Das ist so der Kommentar, den Hörer im Audio-Podcast überhaupt nicht hören möchten.
Das ist ja so silbernes Zeug, was an den Fingern dran ist.
Das sieht ein bisschen so space.
Man, das sind halt Handschuhe.
Relativ warm. Das ist irgendwie so ein Neoprenzeug. Also ich dachte so, na, das bringt ja wirklich gar nichts. Aber ein bisschen was bringt's.
Ja, aber für die Temperaturen, wie wir sie gerade haben...
Ja, aber für die Temperaturen, wie wir sie gerade haben, da helfen eigentlich auch nur verdammt dicke Fäustlinge.
Und also die Handschuhe ist ja ganz schön gut, dass du jetzt dein iPhone bedienen kannst, aber wie viel Minusgrader hält dann überhaupt so ein iPhone aus?
Na, bei Minus 10 funktioniert's noch.
Bei Minus 10 kurz mal rausgeholt oder bei Minus 10? Also ich meine, es ist ja erst mal noch warm, wenn man es aus der Tasche zieht.
Also es funktioniert.
Ich könnte schwören, da steht, dass es bis 0 Grad irgendwie nur genehmigt ist.
Funktioniert gut, aber wir haben halt sozusagen, also was uns halt fehlt, ist sozusagen Handschuhe, die jetzt richtig warm sind. Da würde ich jetzt auch sofort mal die Kaufbutton drücken, wenn ich das... vielleicht was in den Kommentaren...
Ein Kumpel von mir entwickelt intelligente Kleidung, also im Wesentlichen heißt es Kleidung mit Heizung drinnen. Vielleicht könnte man den hier mal auf so was anziehen.
Seit wann ist deine Heizung intelligent?
Ja, ja, na erst mal wollen sie Technik reinkriegen.
So, Operating Temperature, 0 bis 35 Grad, also bei Minusgraden kannst du, sollte man das Ding eh nicht benutzen. Non-Operating Temperature, Minus 20 bis 45 Grad. Ansonsten auch nur bis 35 Grad. Also diesen Sommer hätten wir es ein paar Tage lang schon gar nicht mehr benutzen dürfen.
Es schaltet sich dann auch ab, wenn es zu heiß ist. Das iPhone.
So ein schon bekanntes Phänomen. Was ist das denn eigentlich?
Da gibt es noch richtig so eine Bildschirmwarnung mit, ich bin zu heiß.
Gibt es auch Screenshots von dem Internet? Brauchst nicht selber.
Jungs, achso, warum bin ich eigentlich nicht im Chat?
Mach gleich Mute hier.
Wie heißt unsere Webseite nochmal? mobilemax.de So, und da gibt es so einen Button.
Hier empfiehlt jemand.
Da klickt man und dann ist man da drin.
Nils K empfiehlt, man soll fingerlose Handschuhe noch drüber ziehen über die Handschuhe. Das ist vielleicht gar nicht so eine dumme Idee.
Ja, das ist, ja.
Andere machen sich auch einfach ein fucking Loch in die Handschuhe.
Zum rüberklappen gibt es da so welche.
Ja nee, aber noch mal zusätzlich über die, die man schon hat, einfach noch mal so ein paar fingerlose Handschuhe drüber ziehen.
Und Dots.
Ach so, dass man dann sozusagen die, wenn man die einen auszieht, dass man nicht ganz...
Die Handfläche, die Handfläche ist ja nicht so das Problem.
dotsglove.com Oh, die sehen aber auch warm aus.
Muss man da nicht eh aufpassen, dass mit so einem Handschuh, dass irgendwie das Phone irgendwie nicht einem wegrutscht.
Na, darum hat er ja da so eine Noppen drin.
Genau.
Noppen.
Das sind ja Multifunktionshandschuhe, ich hör schon.
Ja, damit kannst du auch den Mount Everest besteigen.
Du, wie du da für dreckige Faszinationen hast.
Ja, die sehen ein bisschen wärmer aus, aber das sind ja so normale Strickhandschuhe.
Nee, die sind ja, die haben doch innen bestimmt dann noch mal so eine Ligerungsschicht.
Warst du jetzt noch mal der Preis von den Dingen?
Hab ich auch.
Was heißt das?
So 30 Euro oder sowas.
Na, hab ich auch so eine Handschuhe, die außen Wolle sind, aber innen sind auch so Plastascheiß, wissen schon.
Gibt's zwei Größen, Mann und Frau.
Ach, Gloves, man muss unbedingt mit S hin.
Dein Usenet Client heißt MacSoup, soll ich dir sagen.
Ach, genau, MacSoup. Oh, können wir das mal kurz aufgreifen nach den Handschuhen? Ja, das war wirklich toll. Warum soll ich so eine Software nicht weitergepflegt?
Also auf dem Amiga hatte ich ja, glaube ich, Cerberus oder irgendeinen Schnickschnack, das war ja auch so ein Mailnetz, oder? Und ich glaube, da hieß der Kleinen MicroDot.
Nicht irgendwas mit Point. Cerberus.
MicroDot. MicroPoint. Könnte auch sein.
Ja, Point. Ein Point war der Name eines Notes im Cerberus.
Ja, aber ein Dot ist ja auch ein Point. Vielleicht hieß ja das Ding deswegen MicroDot.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht ausschließen.
Ich komm ja da nicht einfach so drauf.
Das heißt immer, das ist ein Point irgendwas.
Ist schon lange her, damals.
Ja, MacSoup. Also MacSoup war wirklich ein Tool auf dem Mac. Das hat das mit diesem Threading wirklich bis zum Excess implementiert. Gerade im Usenet hast du natürlich auch mal extrem verschachtete Diskussionen.
Das hatte so eine eigene Ansicht, ne?
Ja, das hatte halt so einen speziellen View. Also du könntest halt sagen, zeig mir jetzt diesen ganzen Thread an. Das ist ja auch so schwierig nicht. Ich meine, in jedem Reply steht drin, auf welche Mail sich das bezieht. Und dann kannst du da halt einfach so einen Baum machen. Und dann musst du den eigentlich nur als Baum rendern. Und das hätte ich halt auch ganz gerne in Mail ab.
So einen Baum auch noch?
Du kennst das doch. Ich meine, wenn man...
Genau, wo dann jeder's gibt.
Wo alles so wirklich...
Wo alles so wirklich ein Punkt ist.
Echt, das gibt's aber noch?
Das ist von Berliner gemacht.
Jaja. Easydeutsch.
Der Baum sieht ja ganz lustig aus. Sieht aus wie ein Git-Commit-Graf.
So sieht es aus, wenn's zu heiß wurde.
Es sieht auch so ein bisschen so aus wie so ein U-Bahn-Plan.
Ja, wie Git halt.
Wo ist denn hier der Screenshot auf der Webseite?
Das iPhone muss abkühlen, bevor es benutzt werden kann.
In der deutschen Wikipedia gibt's oft...
Ach, so was steht da drin, ja?
Lösch mal.
So, machen wir jetzt auch wieder was, wo wir nicht mit uns quatschen, sondern wir für die Hörer quatschen.
Stefan Haller.
Weil wir haben ja noch so ein paar am Ohr, oder?
Ja, wir haben noch so einige Themen, aber man muss das ja auch mal... Ah ja, genau. Mit diesem Button. Ja, das ist so geil. Klickst du einfach da drauf und so. Ich meine, gut, das könnte man jetzt vielleicht auch nochmal so einen Zacken moderner machen, aber das ist völlig in Ordnung.
Ich guck mal...
Ach, der läuft sogar noch. Das hätte ich halt immer gerne für Mail gehabt. Aber das finde ich, an sowas muss man sich orientieren. Ich meine, wenn schon vor 10 Jahren sowas ordentlich gemacht wurde.
Pass auf, wir schreiben bei den Postbox-Jungs eine Mail. Guck mal hier.
NexSoup.
So muss es aussehen.
Genau. Wenn ihr ein Pro-Tool sein wollt, dann tut auch mal was dafür.
Ach guck mal, der arbeitet bei Ableton. Das wird ja bestimmt dann aufgefahren.
Na, da findet ja wieder alle zusammen.
Das ist ja... Schöner könnte es ja kam sein.
Na, in Ableton Live hat sich das nicht wiedergefunden. Okay, dann let's move on. Was machen wir als nächstes?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Mac Reader, äh Reader. Reader, Reader.
Reader, was es bisher nur für iPhone und iPad gab. Das ist dieser soft, weichgespülte RSS.
Dieser soft, weichgespülte?
Ja, der hat das alles so bräunlich getüncht. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich richtig schwarz und weiß. Das ist alles so wischiwaschig.
Ach so, das meinste. Ich glaube, das ist in erster Linie, das mir aber auch erst bei der iPad-Version bewusst geworden, um so ein Notebook nachzumachen. Also so, dass man so ein Journal quasi, in dem man da so rumblättert. So als ob man so seinen Mulskin da hat.
Ja, ja, ja, es versucht irgendwie so auszusehen.
Genau.
Du bist da ja ein großer Fan von.
Ich war zwischendurch mal ein großer Nicht-Fan von. Weil die iPad-Version hatte einige böse Macken, die sich im Laufe der Zeit aufgebaut haben. Aber jetzt sind die in der neuesten Version wieder alle erledigt. Und das ist wirklich, es wird immer, also er hat heute eine neue Version fürs iPhone zum Beispiel rausgebracht. Und was da echt so ein kleines hübsches Feature ist, ist man kann die Artikel, also in dieser Listenansicht, in der man all die Artikel sieht, da kann man so einen Listeneintrag, so einen Artikel nach links oder nach rechts ziehen. Und wenn man ihn nach rechts sieht, dann wird er als gelesen markiert. Und wenn man so einen Artikel hat, den will ich eh nicht lesen, brauchst du ihn nicht irgendwie draufklicken, sondern ziehst den einfach so kurz rechts rüber, und dann ist er halt gelesen. Und wenn du ihn nach links gezogen hast, dann wurde er gesternet hier. Also bei Google Reader gibt es ja so diese, dass man sich Sachen für später markieren kann. Was ich aber nie genutzt habe, was ich immer doof fand. Und jetzt kann man diese Ebene zum Beispiel auf Read It Later legen. Das heißt, wenn man irgendwie sieht, ah, das könnte ein langer spannender Artikel sein, möchte ich aber nicht jetzt lesen, ziehst ihn so rasch rüber. Was Gesten angeht, ist das echt großartig. Und der hat jetzt offensichtlich die letzte Zeit dran gesessen, das Ganze auf dem Mac zu portieren. Und das ist noch nicht perfekt gelungen, aber schon ziemlich gut auf jeden Fall.
Also ich hab das gestartet, und ich bin wieder genauso wie auch bei dieser iPad-Version und so überhaupt nicht klargekommen. Ich hab noch nicht mal eine einzige Liste meiner Feats gesehen, aber nur so komische 20 Icons, die alle gleich aussahen.
Diese Icon-Ansicht, die kann man aber aufziehen. Diese Icon-Ansicht find ich auch nicht so toll. Also bei mir sieht das jetzt hier so...
Mir ist es nicht gelungen, da irgendwas zu erkennen.
Na da ist, da nimmst du hier, wenn man es so klein macht, dann hat man hier so, hat man die Icon-Ansicht, wenn man es schmal macht, wenn man es in die Breite zieht, dann hat man die volle Ansicht. Dann sieht man, also kann man auswählen, was man gerne haben möchte.
Jimmy Wales, my ass. Kann man nicht in diese Scheiß-Wikipedia reingucken, ohne die ganze Zeit von diesen Typen angestarrt zu werden? Hab ich. Die haben da irgendwas geändert und es hilft nicht.
Man kann doch wieder LYNX benutzen.
Können wir jetzt mal wieder an ein Laberthema aufgreifen? Ich bin schon wieder am Surfen hier.
Wirklich?
Logisch.
Oder auch nicht.
Also auf jeden Fall besser als Net News Fire. Ja, klasse. Hallo? Net News Fire hab ich eh nicht lange, weil ich großer Freund von...
Nee, aber da blicke ich... Also für drei Feats geht das vielleicht, aber nicht für irgendwie... Ich hab jetzt hier wie viel? Hunderte.
Wir können uns ja mal zwischendurch bei unseren Sushi-Provider bedanken.
Sushi-Provider.
Was ist denn an dem da besser als an dem hier?
Voll übersichtlich. Wieso, was kannst du denn nicht? Ich kann nur perfekt News anzeigen. Woran redet ihr gerade? NetNews-Wire. Und jetzt Reader soll angeblich besser sein als NetNews-Wire.
Also zum Beispiel, was man hat, ist ja so diese Webview an sich. Dann geht man... Man drückt V, dann wechselt er sozusagen, dann wechselt er von der Artikelansicht in den entsprechenden Webview, wo man dann die komplette Webseite sieht. Die wird schon im Hintergrund vorgeladen. Das heißt also, wenn man so ein Artikel anfängt zu lesen, und dann sieht er, ah, scheiße, hier ist im Feed nicht die gesamte Information, dann drückt er kurz V und dann ist die Seite einfach schon da. Und er hat sich so einen hübschen Mechanismus, weil die Seiten ja meistens breiter sind als der Feed. Dann wird hier sozusagen die Feed-Spalte, nicht die Artikel-Spalte, die zoomt dann so raus, dann hat man mehr Platz für den Artikel und so. Das ist schon alles echt gut durchdacht. Das ist sehr, sehr flüssig, macht echt Laune.
Ich warte mal noch, bis das Release draußen ist.
Und dann kann er hier, hat da so Twitter-Funktionen drinne und kann sharen. Ich glaube, NetNews war halt kein Share-Button, oder?
Das ist mir total latte.
Ich will damit nur News lesen. Ich möchte ja lesen und weiterverbreiten. Das ist ja so mein Ding. Ach, das geht schon.
Für mich ist das NetNews gerade noch besser.
Probier's mal aus. Ich meine, kannst ja beide parallel ausprobieren. Hab ich ja schon.
Ich bin halt nicht so glücklich, muss ich sagen. Ja, das könnte man auch sagen. Also NetNewsWire ist sicherlich auch nicht perfekt, aber für die Anzahl von Feats, die ich so lese und was ich immer so offen lasse, also ich benutze halt auch nicht so was wie Read Later oder so, sondern mein NetNewsWire ist quasi mein Read Later.
Ich weiß gar nicht, guck mal. Ich kann ja mal gucken, wie viele Feats ich so hier habe.
Pepe hat recht. Lass uns weitergehen.
Jetzt die ganze Zeit darüber zu streiten, ob irgendwie eine Beta-Software uns gefällt oder nicht. Das bringt uns jetzt nicht so richtig weiter.
Richtig.
Das Ganze gibt es, und man kann ja seine Feats lesen, wenn man sowas überhaupt noch macht.
Genau, manche Leute sagen bestimmt...
Feats lesen ist ja auch schon so ein bisschen... das erste Dekade, wie auch immer man die nennt. Und auch vollkommen ungeklärt. Sollen wir noch ein bisschen randeln?
Dennis, was willst du?
Also Airport. Ich hab Schnauze voll. Tegel oder Schönefeld? Ich schmeiße alles raus. Also es geht gar nicht. Ich hab irgendwie zwei Time Capsules, ich habe irgendwie drei oder vier Airport-Expresse. Und ich könnte gerade keine einzige herauspicken, von der ich sicher sagen kann, dass sie funktioniert. Ich hab das Gerät. Jedes einzelne Airport-Device, das ich habe, ist fehl.
Geil, dann kann ich ja den Anti-Rand machen jetzt. Also ich hab eine zu Hause.
Ja hör dir erst mal an, was bei mir alles nicht funktioniert.
Ich dachte wir machen das so Ping-Pong-mäßig.
Ja, ich meine, solange die funktionieren, findet man sie geil. Und sobald sie dann nicht mehr funktionieren, findet man sie nicht mehr geil. Das ist ganz einfach. Aber dass alle nicht mehr funktionieren, alle! Und ich rede hier wirklich von einem Investitionsrahmen im vierstelligen Bereich. Das geht einfach mal überhaupt nicht. Das ist schlimm. Also WLAN-Wackelein, DSL-Wackelein, dann hier dieses Überhützungsproblem. Ich meine, okay, dieses Teil ist wahrscheinlich einfach jetzt hardwaremäßig braun und muss repariert werden. Sowas kann natürlich auch passieren. Aber ich glaube, es liegt auch einfach daran, dass diese Kiste einfach zu dicht gepackt ist. Festplatte drin, wird warm, schwitzt sich irgendwie ein ab, ist irgendwie so ein Käfig und geht überhaupt nicht. Und dann muss ich das Teil irgendwie eine Stunde ausschalten, bevor es wieder angeht. Und an der Stelle muss ich sagen, was mich dann auch wirklich stört, ist die mangelnde Selbstdokumentation dieser Systeme, also sie geben einem dann irgendwie relativ wenig Hilfestellungen dabei, sie wieder zu fixen. Ja, dann WLAN-Probleme, dann hab ich das Teil wieder auf 2,4 Gigahertz umgestellt, sag hier, wähl deinen Kanal irgendwie automatisch, nehmt sich den Kanal der einen Kanal neben den anderen Netz ist, was ich eingerichtet habe. So auch kein Wunder, dass danach irgendwie nichts mehr geht.
Na automatisch heißt auch wahrscheinlich random, oder?
Ja, dann versuch ich die mit diesen zwei Airport-Expressen hier, habe ich so eine WLAN-Strecke über die Straße, die muckelt irgendwie mit 50 Kilobyte pro Sekunde vor sich hin und die kann irgendwie...
Ich meine, jeder Typ, unseren Bruder und der Hund hat irgendwie so eine Station. Ich meine, die Frunk-Frequenzen sind einfach dicht in so einer Stadt hier.
Die haben sie auch auf 5 Gigahertz betrieben, das war noch schlechter.
Das ist ja auch dicht. Meinst du, du bist der Einziger mit so einer 5 Gigahertz Station inzwischen? Gibt's den auch schon seit ein paar Jahren. Aber, um jetzt mal den Anti-Rennen zu machen...
Du, in dieser Straße sind fast alle Häuser verpixelt, kannst du mir erzählen, dass die alle nur auf 5 Gigahertz sind.
Na klar, meinst du, die Schwaben kaufen nicht bei Apple?
Ja, aber die wissen nicht, wo der 5 Gigahertz-Knopf angeht. Die müssen auch da ein WLAN-4 Jahr altes, Schrott-Nokia-Handy von vor 5 Jahren da noch einschalten.
Nein, die haben auch alle ein iPhone, man bildt hier mal nichts ein.
Ja klar, ich glaub nämlich, das sind in Wirklichkeit die verpixelt, nämlich genau die, die sich nämlich mit dem ganzen Scheiß auskennen. Das nehm ich gar nicht, die die.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall total frustriert und das ist alles im Arsch. Und ich glaub, ich wechsle jetzt auf so eine Fritz-Box. Weil ich wahrscheinlich dann auch bald wieder irgendwie rumran.
Hab schon gesehen, deine Mitteihebenestation ist jetzt eine Links ist, ne? Also sagste zumindest vom Namen her.
Ja, das ist aber jetzt auch nur der Satz, weil die Fritz-Box, die ich gekauft hab, war auch im Arsch.
Der Tim, der Burgonen.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ich weiß nicht, was ich mache. Die Geräte zerrinnen in meinen Händen. Das ist unglaublich.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so toll zudrücken.
Also bei mir zuhause die Express und ich mach die WLAN und ich, Musik mach ich selten inzwischen, aber da sind zwei Leute, die benutzen, mein Nachbarin über mir, die ist auch ein bisschen weiter weg, das funktioniert alles. Im Club haben wir zwei Stationen uns mal gekauft und 5 GHz und 2,5. Und da sind ja im Club also 1000 Leute, die benutzen. Immer verschiedene und treiber und alles.
Aber auch das Ding im Club, die funktionieren. Ja klar, aber du musst die auch alle zwei Wochen neu starten. Aber hallo.
Extrem nicht.
Ja, die Express, die Express.
Ja, die Express haben wir zwischendurch, die macht kein WLAN mehr. Die haben wir jetzt Kabel auch nicht, weil dann machen wir ja nur Musik.
Aber die hängt sich nämlich dann irgendwann auf.
Aber die Extrems, die gehen.
Ja gut, und was soll ich von dir aussagen? Das heißt, die Express sind irgendwie nicht stabil, Punkt. Und es gibt keine Software ab.
Du meinst nur die Express?
Nein, auch. Also das ist das Problem, was ich mit den Expressen habe. Ich muss alle meine Expressen, und ich hab drei, die irgendwie ein Netz aufmachen, nee zwei. Und ich muss die halt alle zwei Wochen rausziehen und wieder reinstecken. Ich meine, geht's noch? Weil die einfach dann auch nicht mehr sichtbar sind. Die verschwinden dann einfach vom Netz, sind irgendwie offline, machen kein Netz mehr oder noch besser, sind nicht erreichbar, machen aber trotzdem noch das Netz, sodass sich alle darin einbuchen und dann aber kein Netz kommt. Und so ein Scheiß. Und das scheint irgendwie Systemimmanent zu sein. Also ich kann mir keiner erzählen, dass es nicht ein generelles Problem ist.
Die nicht haben willst.
Es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit, hier irgendwie zuverlässig Audio zu verteilen. Na ja, sag mir eine andere Lösung. Ich meine, es gibt schon diverse andere Systeme, aber die bewegen sich dann auch alle eher so im High-End-Bereich und sind dann so, weiß ich nicht, mit der Apple-Welt nicht so verbunden. Was weiß ich hier so, Raumfeld zum Beispiel ist ja auch ein ganz interessantes System. Die benutzen alle diesen UPNP-Kram. Oder diese, wie heißen die, Sonos? Nee, diese weißen.
Ach so.
Nicht Sonos. Sonos, wie heißen die?
Ich hab's noch nie im Live gesehen.
Wir haben hier eine iPhone und so weiter.
Wireless Multi-Room Music System.
Genau, genau, genau. Ja, und es gibt ja da so Standards. Ich hab da jetzt selber noch nicht mit gearbeitet im UPnP-Bereich, Universal Plug & Play von uns Microsoft. Die scheinen da ja zumindest ein bisschen Arbeit investiert zu haben, um eben dieses, ich share meine Musik, dann auch mal zumindest auf so Protokollebene zu dokumentieren und dann kann man das halt implementieren. Keine Ahnung, wie zuverlässig das funktioniert. Aber gibt's zumindest, was ich schon mal ganz gut finde, Pluspunkt für Microsoft. Heute bin ich mal ganz lieb zum Microsoft.
Ne, gibt später noch einen Pluspunkt für Microsoft.
Mit meinem Windows 7 bin ich da immer noch voll zufrieden. Es funktioniert einfach. Also ich benutze das jetzt immer nur 5 Minuten. Und danach muss man meistens eine Viertelstunde Updates holen, wenn wir runterfahren, aber es funktioniert.
Im Chat werde ich jetzt schon gewarnt, ich soll mir noch keine Fritzbox holen, weil ich kann mir ja auch irgendwie generic Linux da drauf ballern. Ja, da bin ich irgendwie... Ich meine, das ist irgendwie alles Dreck. Und gerade dieses Fritzbox da, diese 7390, die ich jetzt da mir hinstellen wollte, was ich auch gemacht habe, aber den nicht funktioniert hat, ist dann bei Heise gleich aufgetaucht, hat auch WLAN-Macken und neues Firmware, das reinbrennen und so weiter. Okay, okay, ne? Aber wo ich mir so ein bisschen was von verspreche, das ist halt einfach die ganz sinnvolle Kombination, dass das Teil eben auch deckt kann, dass das Teil auch ein analogen Telefon, also es ist quasi auch eine Telefonanlage, es macht SIP und so weiter.
Das ist auch eins der wenigen anderen Consumer-Geräte, in Anführungsstrichen, die auch 6 to 4 in der aktuellen...
IPv6, genau. Das haben sie jetzt auch übrigens nachgekostet.
Was war die ganze Zeit im Erbieter?
Im aktuellen Firmware, weiss ich, 84, 84, irgendwas, keine Ahnung, wir haben auch so merkwürdige Versionsnummern, die man sich nicht merken kann. Aber meine Erfahrungen sind jetzt sozusagen begrenzt. Jeder hat da sozusagen ja, Deckzeiten, der beschrotzt. Na ja, gut, ich werde das prüfen. Aber mit Airport komme ich da halt nicht vorwärts. Ich meine, das ist irgendwie, das Problem ist halt auch so diese Time Capsule und der Router, ich meine, das macht zwar auf den ersten Blick irgendwie Sinn, aber dieses Backup und Netz, ich weiß nicht, das ist irgendwie nicht der richtige Ort. Ich hätte lieber so eine Time Capsule einfach so für sich, Gigabit, Ordnung und fertig.
Und Möhrotplatten.
Genau.
Weil eine Platte mit so einem Ding drin.
Ah, wir wiederholen uns wieder wiederholen. Also ich bin einfach ein bisschen frustriert und muss Notoperationen machen und es sieht eher so aus, als ob all diese Gerätschaft von Apple, die Internet macht, on its way out ist, weil ich einfach keinen Bock mehr hab.
Ok, dann wieder kleine positive News. Aber wir wollen jetzt die Hörer ja nicht so runterziehen.
Wir können ja gleich mal bei diesem Streaming-Thema bleiben. Bisschen schon.
Ja, was wolltest du denn jetzt hier? Ich bin schon gespannt auf seine positiven News.
Na, wenn er streamt, machen wir erst Streaming. Schieb ich später rein.
Naja, dann kommen wir doch mal hier so auf das Update, weil es hat sich auch ein bisschen was getan.
Welches? 421.
421, iOS ist draußen. Das iPad ist jetzt sozusagen auch in der Gegenwart angekommen. Und ist ja auch deutlich benutzbarer seitdem, finde ich. Also das ist schon signifikant. Und naja, also es hat sich schon einiges getan. Ich hab ja auch so eine Apple TV mir mal geschoppt, so billig wie sie ist. Ich hab auch deine alte im Test, aber ich hab sozusagen auch die neue im Test. War am Anfang erst mal so nicht ganz so begeistert, aber mittlerweile funktioniert das Teil an sich ganz gut. Und mit AirPlay ist das schon cool, weil das funktioniert tatsächlich. Man kann von seinem iPhone, man kann es von seinem iPad da so hinstremen. Zumindest eben aus diesen zwei Apps. Also aus dieser Video-App auf dem iPhone. Und auf der YouTube-App, genau. Und beim iPhone ist es die iPod-App.
So rum.
Ja, und das geht. Und was ich besonders cool finde, ist, dass das Ding...
Wenn man Gejailbricks hat, dann geht's in allen Programmen.
Ja, ich mein, das wird das nächste Update irgendwie bringen. Und so, wir wissen, iOS 4.3 kommt und dann... Das werden sie jetzt ausrollen. Die haben halt erst mal zurückhaltend das so eingebaut. Aber was ich besonders beeindruckend fand, womit ich nicht gerechnet habe, ist, dass du halt streamen kannst und dann das Programm aber auch noch beenden kannst. Also zumindest bei den beiden, wo es jetzt drin ist. Also du kannst ein Video abspielen auf dem iPad und dann sagen, schick mal auf das Fernseherchen da, also auf die Apple TV. Und dann kann ich Homebutton drücken und kann in Safari gehen und kann mit dem Teil einfach arbeiten. Also ich kann alles machen, außer ein anderes Video abspielen, weil dann bin ich wieder an der Stelle. Aber er kann sozusagen diesen Streaming-Prozess im Hintergrund machen.
Ja, nicht schlecht. Wird es werkbar langsamer?
Für ein System, das kein richtiges Multitasking kann, angeblich gar nicht so schlecht. Und das ist gut. Und vor allem, dass er bringt halt auch, haben wir glaube ich auch schon mal gesprochen, aber es ist halt einfach interessant. Du hast jetzt so ein billiges Device, was du an einen beliebigen HDMI Output anschließen kannst oder Input anschließen kannst, wo du so Video so hinstreamen kannst. Und wenn sie das dann wirklich mal in allen Ups haben, dann wird es so für Präsentationssituationen mit Beamern zum Beispiel ganz interessant. Wenn du so einen Beamer hast, und du hast immer so dieses Problem, ein langes Kabel zum Beamer, und jetzt kannst du da einfach so eine Apple TV daneben stecken, Strom hast du eh schon da, dann macht das Ding irgendwie W-Lan, dann kannst du da mit W-Lan hinstreamen und hast sozusagen an deinem Beamer exklusiv so die Apple TV als Interface zu diesem Beamer. Dann kannst du deinen iTunes-Kram da hinstreamen, etc. Das macht schon Sinn.
So wie es sein soll.
Zu viel Home-Schinema.
Und? Wenn ich jetzt noch über einen Browser ginge, dann wär's ja total perfekt. Also wenn der Browser, wenn das Video, was man da abspielt, dann könnte man das auch alles könnte.
Und kann das so Full-HD-Streams über W-Lan ab?
Schafft er?
Ich hab das mit.
Die Full-HD kann doch nicht mal die Apple TV, oder?
Na ja, er zeigt dann nicht Full-HD an, weil das Apple TV macht nur 27p. Das ist eine Limitierung.
Das geht dann einfach runter. Also man kann es hin...
Man kann es abspielen.
Man kann es abspielen, aber nicht in der entsprechenden Qualität.
Ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher, ob ich es wirklich mit 1080p Content probiert habe, aber ich habe gelesen, dass es geht. Aber Glauben heißt nicht wissen, und von daher weiß ich es nicht.
Ja, aber wenn er es abspielen kann, dann runter skaliert. Also skalieren muss er sowieso, dann hätte er auch die Power für alles andere. Also eigentlich müsste er es dann nicht abspielen können.
Dann wäre die Power für was?
Wenn du einen HD-Film hinspielst, hinschickst, dann entweder kannst du es abspielen, oder kannst du es nicht abspielen.
Ja, das stimmt. Entweder geht es oder nicht.
Naja, also die Aussage, der skaliert dann runter in das kleinere Format, ist ja Blödsinn. Weil es kostet ja eigentlich fast noch mehr Arbeit. Also wenn er es decoden kann, kann er es decoden. Also kann er nun oder kann er nicht?
Wie ich sagte, ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher, ob ich es getestet habe. Und von daher bin ich mir gerade nicht so sicher, weil ich glaube, es geht. Aber Glauben heißt wie gesagt nicht wissen. Aber ich teste das nochmal. Naja und dann gibt es ja noch das R-Print. Und dieses R-Print hat sich ja mittlerweile herausgestellt. Also obwohl sie bei diesem Mac OS 10.6.5 Update das Feature so bei Default nicht drin haben, ist eigentlich alles da, was man braucht. Man muss halt nur diese eine Textdatei irgendwie in User, Caps, Tralala, irgendein Caps-Verzeichnis muss man dann halt diesen Mime-Type, diesen urf, ich weiß nicht genau wofür das steht, eintragen. Und siehe da, auf einmal kann man dann seinen Printer, selbst wenn er nicht AirPrint enabled ist, über den Mac ansprechen vom iPhone. Das funktioniert bei mir auch.
Muss man halt die ganze Zeit Mac laufen haben. Aber hast du ja eh.
Und dann hab ich aber mal auf diese Liste der Supported Products geguckt, die bei Apple da so steht. Und da stand unter anderem HP LaserJet, Color, Multifunktion, 14, 15, mit irgendwie Wireless und Hass nicht gesehen.
Kannst du auf dem Ding hier über WLAN drucken?
Das handelt sich nicht um dieses Gerät, das auf dem Tisch steht, sondern das ist ein alter HP. Aber ich hab mir das Teil geschoppt. Weil ich wollte schon immer mal einen Farblaser haben. Dann dachte ich mir so, die kosten so 400 Euro. Geht ja. Du zahlst das halt angeblich später alles in Toner.
Nicht angeblich, ist so.
Ja, das ist das Business-Modell.
Aber im Gegensatz zu Tintenpatronen trocknen die wenigstens nicht ein, wenn man sie ein paar Jahre nicht benutzt.
Genau. Ich hatte da auch noch mal auf Twitter gefragt, wie denn das so ist mit Fotos ausdrucken, weil das war so ein Konzern im Familienvorstand. Und naja, eine hellige Antwort ist sozusagen, Tintenpisser können besser Fotos ausdrucken, aber langlebiger ist das Ergebnis auch nicht unbedingt. Und wer richtig Fotos machen will, der soll lieber einen Thermosublimationsdrucker kaufen, die gibt es irgendwie auch billig. Und dann kommen da so Fotos raus oder du laufst halt hier irgendwie zu deinem Drosspa um die Ecke und steckst da irgendwie deine Speicherkarte in diesen Apparat und dann fallen dir da ordentlichen Fotoprints raus. Und ein Foto war für mich jetzt nicht so entscheidend. Ich wollte bloß mal so Farbe, ich wollte mal so, wissen schon, mal so Logos und so weiter in Farbe ausdrucken. Das war mir schon immer ein Begehr, mal so ein paar Stats und Präsentationen. Vor allem wenn du sowas machst, dass du einfach mal so Handouts machen kannst mit Farbe, Charts. Und dann hab ich mir dieses Teil gekauft, exakt genau das Modell. Und was soll ich sagen, Erprint geht nicht. Das scheiß Teil ist nicht sichtbar.
Wie?
Das geht nicht.
Ja, jetzt?
Das ist scheiße.
Wie, also auf der Apple Seite steht, dass es mit dem Gerät geht?
Ja, und dieses Gerät wird nicht von meinem iPhone G sehen.
Und hast du denn schon alle Konfigurationsmenüs und so durch?
Konfigurationsmenüs? Erprint ist ohne Konfiguration.
Vielleicht muss man das Erprint ja noch einschalten.
Ja, dachte ich auch, aber ich hab da nichts gefunden. Ja, was soll denn das? Ich meine, was schreiben die den Scheiß da auf diese Scheiß-Webseite, wenn es dann nicht geht?
Und hast du schon Sjobs at Apple angeschrieben?
Naja, ich mach ein großes Fass auf. Das ist das größte Problem, was es gibt derzeit im Internet. Nee, ich hab das Thema jetzt erstmal auf den Backburner. Ich kann ja auch das Teil drücken über den Mac. Das ist sozusagen, also wenn ich jetzt, ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich seit Wochen mit den Hufen scharre, um endlich meine Dokumente mit dem iPhone auszudrucken. Das ist nicht so der Punkt. Ich druck schon noch primär von meinem Mac. Von daher ist es mir gerade so ein bisschen egal. Ich wollte das Teil nur haben, weil das für mich sozusagen einerseits genau das Gerät war, was ich haben wollte. So Multifunktionen, etc. habe und den ganzen Schnaß halt. Und ich somit HP schon so halb gute Erfahrungen gehabt habe, gut genug zumindest. Und naja, das passt dann halt noch dazu. Das war dann so das i-Tüpfel. Ich dachte mir so, okay, alles klar, hat auch quasi aktuelle Software. Das Ding bindet sich schon deutlich besser ein als mein alter Laserjet. Das heißt, das Teil ist auch automatisch als Scanner und Fax und so weiter. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt so schön vom Rechner aus, ohne irgendeinen Scheiß zu installieren, kann ich da drauf Faxe los schicken, etc.
Mit Image Capture kannst du dann scanen, oder wie?
Du kannst das direkt in diesem Printerdialog sogar machen. Also in diesem Fenster, was aufgeht, wo du deine Printjob hast, so der Spooler sozusagen, wo du deine Jobs, dein Job, wie heißt denn das, dieses Prints? Keine Ahnung, was auch immer. Und da hast du dann noch einen extra Button Scan, und dann klickst du irgendwie drauf, und dann kriegst du einen Scanner Interface, und das ist einfach schön einfach, und zack, hier in die Datei und fertig ist.
Aber es geht dann bestimmt auch mit Image Capture.
Das mag sein. Das ist die selbe Architektur.
Wir wollten eine Print Gate im Ur geschrieben, hat aber das N vergessen.
Print Gate?
Ja, hat aber das N vergessen.
Hängt mir mal ein Skandal an hier. Genau. Morgen bin ich auf WikiLeaks.
Übermorgen bei Interpol.
So, was sind hier für kluge Anmerkungen? FrogX2 meint, er meint, dass man da ein Firmware-Update braucht. Tja, den Eindruck hab ich allerdings auch.
Updaten hilft immer. Haben sie schon mal aus- und eingeschaltet?
Aber wo ist das Firmware-Update?
Na, auf hp.com.
Das kommt doch automatisch jetzt, oder nicht?
Ich muss mal diesen Laser-Jet hier mal genauer beschreiben. Erster Scheiß-Teil. Ich hab mal eine Maus falsch rum in der Hand, deswegen läuft hier nichts.
Das passiert ja bei diesen Magic-Mores noch ganz gerne mal.
HP Laser-Jet 2CM1415FNW. Ich poste das mal hier sogar in den Chat. Next. Das waren so meine Erfahrungen. Toll, was? Er druckt ganz gut. Auch schön leise, wenn er nicht benutzt wird. Das wird langsam so mit diesen Druckern. Trotzdem traue ich immer noch so ein bisschen meinem Laser weiter hinterher. Apple-Drucker, das war schon geil.
Ja, damals.
Ja, damals, früher.
Ja, nee, ist aber auch tatsächlich wahr. Also alles, was danach kam, war erst mal eine ganze Zeit lang schlimmer.
Das hat sehr lange gedauert, bis der selbe Level wieder erreicht wurde. Jetzt kommen wir so langsam da so hin. Das ist echt erstaunlich, ne? Erstaunlich. Wo ist denn jetzt diese Fad-Lintizier? Ah, Entschuldigung, ich bin abgelenkt. Geht gleich wieder weiter.
Was haben wir noch so?
Drucker.
Legst du jetzt hier gerade Firmware-Updates runter?
Wir sind immer noch bei iOS 4... nein, nein. iOS 4.2.1. Was ich auch noch ganz interessant fand, ist, dass ja mit dem Software-Update auch noch der Safari ein paar nette Neuigkeiten hat.
Ja, Find-in-Page.
Find-in-Page.
Genau. Aber auch unter der Haube.
Man kann jetzt den Beschleunigungssensor abfragen.
Genau. Per JavaScript. Keine Anwendung gesehen, die das jetzt seriös nutzen, außer irgendwelchen Demos drüber hinaus. Aber grundsätzlich ist das natürlich schon mal ein interessanter Schritt, dass eben in Web-Apps auch sowas jetzt benutzt werden kann. Es gibt ja diesen alten Krieg mit, naja, man kann zwar Web-Apps machen, was man will, aber man kommt ja nicht an alles ran. An der Stelle kommt man zumindest jetzt erst mal wieder an so ein wichtiges Feature ran, was so vorher nicht ging. Also was weiß ich, wenn du jetzt eine Applikation machen willst, die den Accelerator ausliest und dann per Open-Sound-Control Parameter rausschicken will, dann geht das zum Beispiel. Weil du nicht nur diesen Accelerator hast, sondern weil sie ja jetzt auch Websockets eingebaut haben.
Stimmt, das haben wir auch mal genannt.
Und Websockets sind eine ganz neue Geschichte in HTML5.
Und diese Webfonds.
Wo du jetzt eben so richtig IP sprechen kannst. Beziehungsweise TCP, das ist glaube ich gut. Oder kann man damit auch ODP machen?
Na ja, so richtig am Anfang waren ja alle total begeistert und dachten, boah, geil.
Ja.
Und dann hat sich die Begeisterung aber auch wieder so ein bisschen gelegt, weil es halt auch so ein bisschen umständlich alles ist mit diesen Websockets. Also so richtig, so wie TCP-Sockets ist es nicht. Also da gibt es halt irgendwie, es ist jetzt schon wieder zu lange her, dass ich mich damit beschäftigt habe, aber also, es ist immer noch cool, ja, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass du halt echte Sockets in der Hand hast und so. Also da gibt es schon immer noch Komplikationen und Schwierigkeiten und ist ein bisschen umständlich zu benutzen.
Weiß ich nicht, das Websockets kann man damit von jeder Seite zu jeder Seite aufmachen, oder haben die auch hier dieses, wie bei Ajax, dieses Cross Domain Zeug und sowas alles?
Na du kannst halt sozusagen auch von der Seite raus. Das ist schon mal...
Von der Seite raus? Von der Seite auf eine andere Seite, oder? Also von einem Server zum anderen Server?
Von der... Moment. Nein, vergiss einfach gerade, was ich gesagt habe. Ich hab's nicht gesagt. Das Problem war, dass ich nicht nachgedacht habe. Also, ignorieren.
Weil alle hier am Surfen sind die ganze Zeit.
Nee, ich versuche das hier gerade zu verstehen aufgrund dieser Beschreibung, aber ich habe mich schon...
Ja, und hier Web-Fonts. Web-Fonts kann jetzt Safari auch.
Web-Fonts sind auch drin?
Das sind diese hübsche kleine Standard, dass man endlich mehr als Areal und...
Verdana.
Verdana nutzen kann im Netz, weil Browser jetzt True-Type-Fonts unterladen können, massenhaft. Und Google bietet da also eine richtig schicke API, wenn ich mich nicht alles täusche. Ich hab sie noch nie eingesetzt, aber wo man dann einfach so eine Zeile in sein CSS-File reinkopiert und schon hat man ein paar mehr Schriften zur Verfügung. Und die kümmern sich um den ganzen Lizenzscheiß und schieben einem im Gegenzug nur ein paar Cookies unter. Also keine Ahnung, was die immer machen.
Nur ein paar Cookies unter schieben.
Ja, was Heise gemeldet hat, ist ja, dass sie auch noch solche Verbesserungen in dem UMTS Handshake irgendwie mit eingebracht haben.
Genau, das ist...
Fast Dormancy war mir vollkommen neu, dass es das überhaupt gibt.
Was Heise gelesen heute?
Ich bin vorhin drauf hingewiesen worden.
Ja, hab ich auch gelesen.
Ja, das ist so eine Art Sleep-Mode für UMTS.
Sleep on Demand.
Wer demandet denn das? Also das Netz sagt...
Da steht zumindest drin, dass es beide Seiten können muss, sonst geht's irgendwie nicht.
Ja, das heißt, im Netz muss es vorhanden sein, es fragt sich natürlich jetzt wieder, welches Netz das kann.
Das ist ja nicht diese...
Werbung für Siemens Nokia steht ja da, weil die sagen ja, sie können's. Die haben's ja rausgefunden. Apple hat ja nicht davon berichtet, sondern die haben rausgefunden, dass das iPhone das wohl macht.
Und wenn ich mir jetzt so eine Basis-Station hole, so ein Funkmast für zu Hause, dann hole ich mir selbstverständlich einen von Siemens Nokia. Weil der kann mit meinem iPhone am besten. Oder wie so Werbung. Oder fragen Sie noch heute bei Ihrem Mobilfunk-Provider nach, ob er auch die moderne Mobilfunk-Setting von Siemens Nokia...
Das Update ist ja leider erst seit einer Woche draußen. Da kann man ja noch nicht so richtig sagen, ob die Batterie länger hält, weil bisher hab ich noch nicht neu geladen.
Interessant.
Ich müsste mal wieder...
Weißt du, hast du nicht neu geladen?
Das war jetzt ein Witz, aber du hast ihn genauer getroffen. Weil der war für dich. Ehrlich gesagt, aber ich guck auch schon gar nicht mehr hin, wie oft ich lade, weil irgendwie am Anfang hab ich das immer gemacht, so 5 Tage, 4 Tage, 3 Tage, 6 Tage, so mit dem ganz 2G noch. Das hat er nicht so viel. Aber inzwischen, ich weiß auch nicht.
Ist einfach zu deprimierend.
Nee, ich häng's einfach dran und es ist mir auch schnuppel.
Was ich das Gefühl habe, dass mit 4.2, und zwar sowohl auf dem iPad als auch auf dem iPhone, vielleicht hab ich auch nur natürlich einen höheren Alkoholpegel, aber ich hab das Gefühl, dass meine Tippgenauigkeit schlechter geworden ist.
Das hab ich auch, aber nicht erst seit 4.2, sondern schon überhaupt seit 4.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, ich tipp oft daneben.
Also ich hab das, dass mir Buchstaben einfach fehlen zwischendurch. Dass ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, dass ich die angetippt habe.
Ja, dass ich so tippe wie früher, aber irgendwie die Taste daneben erwische.
Also ich hab das seit 4.2 jetzt. Und zwar hatte ich mit 4.2 Betas auf dem iPad, hatte ich ja auch mal die ganze Zeit drauf. Damit hatte ich das nicht, aber das hab ich jetzt erst so seit entweder seit dem Golden Master oder seit der Finale. Ja, Golden Master ist ja final.
Also ich glaub, es kam bei mir mit der 4.0. Vielleicht auch mit der 4.1. Aber schon vorher, vor 4.2 auf jeden Fall schon.
Das ist mir auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen negativ aufgefallen. Aber ansonsten...
Das kann aber auch mein Brain sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob es anders ist. Aber auf dem iPad sind doch die Tasten groß genug. Dann müsste es da eigentlich gehen, oder?
Ja, eigentlich schon. Das ist es ja gerade. Also ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass ich die Tasten getroffen habe. Aber es erscheint kein Buchstabe auf Bildschirm. Total nervt. Vielleicht werde ich auch einfach alt. Und diese junge Hip-Hop-Musik. Ach, Hip-Hop ist wahrscheinlich auch schon durch, oder?
Hip-Hop?
Ja, ich glaube, man wird alt, wenn man sich über Musikstile aufregt, die eh keines auch mehr hört.
Mensch, Postbox hat mich auf was eingesetzt. Also neuer Mailkleint.
Nicht jetzt während der Sendung, Tim.
Mailkleint wechseln ist wirklich hart.
Nicht während der Sendung.
Und parallel dazu Firmenupdates.
Beim Drucker. Ich hab Postbox auch irgendwie ewig, also dreimal hab ich diese 30 Tage Testzeit und immer Mail ab noch parallel und so. Und am Ende hab ich mich dann doch...
30 Tage Testzeit. Das ist auch so ne Krankheit, ne? Mit diesen 30... Was für 30 Tage sind das? So 30 Tage ab Launch und dann 30 Tage. Und auch wenn du das Programm nur einmal aufgerufen hast, ist vorbei. Das find ich ja, das versteh ich ja überhaupt nicht. Warum zählen die Programme nicht einfach, wie oft sie benutzt worden?
Wie oft find ich auch doof, weil wenn du so ein App hast, was dann gleich dreimal abstürzt, dann schaffst du dir ein Auto an und dann hast du aber schon dreimal von deiner Nutzungszeit weg. Es gibt ja so...
Ja, machst du halt so was wie 100 Launches oder was weiß ich.
Nutzungszeit würde ich ja spannend finden.
Mindestens vier Wochen oder was weiß ich, so und so viele Launches oder keine Ahnung.
Wie viele Wochen sind 30 Tage?
Ja, aber Tage, wo du es auch wirklich benutzt hast. Das meine ich.
Aber ich hab halt meine Mail-Accounts ja eh konsolidiert und jetzt also die Setup-Time für die nächsten 30 Tage war sehr gering bei mir, sozusagen.
Du nimmst dann immer einfach die Einstellungen und dann...
Genau.
Was kostet das?
29 Dollar oder so.
Oh Gott, um zu gucken, wie geizig der Huckel ist.
Naja ey, ich kauf mir nur ein Programm, wenn ich davon überzeugt bin. Also ich kauf mir jetzt nicht jeden Schrot.
Das wäre für Tim ja schlecht, weil der ist ja von gar nichts überzeugt.
Also ich kauf iPhone-Apps hierfür. Du darfst auch mal nicht schon so ein Hörrad nicht.
Ich bin vollkommen verklärt und total Apple-manisch verschrieben. Das wird halt dabei übersehen. Aber ich finde, da muss innovativer rangegangen werden an diese Trial-Zeit. Weil ich hab das ganz häufig, Programm interessant, mal runterladen. Dann willst du zumindest einmal starten, um zu sehen, womit du es zu tun hast. Und dann läuft sozusagen dieser Demo-Counter. Dann hast du vier Wochen später mal Zeit, dir das mal in Ruhe anzugucken, weil du hast es dann irgendwie gespeichert. Und dann kommt da gleich ein Buch mit, ja, ich bin abgelaufen, musst du jetzt kaufen. Und dann hast du auch keine Chance mehr, es zu testen.
Aber genau das ist ja der Punkt, wie auch im Chat ganz richtig erwähnt wird, mit dem Mac Store, Mac Apple App Store. Da kannst du ja nur kaufen. Da gibt es ja das Konzept von Demo oder so gar nicht.
Dann kannst du die Demo ja immer noch auf deiner Webseite haben.
Na eigentlich ist wahrscheinlich dann der Weg, dass du free dir eine Variante runterladen kannst, die aber irgendwie beschränkt ist. Und dann kannst du den In-App-Purchase machen zum Upgraden oder sowas. Das ist dann bestimmt der neue Trend.
Lass uns über den App Store reden. Den hatte ich hier eh noch auf meiner Liste. Ich weiß.
Habe ich ganz elegant umgeleitet.
Okay, das ist jetzt ein Themawechsel. Dann will ich jetzt mein Ding schnell einstreuen. Weil es jetzt schon einen größeren Cut hat. Eben nicht, aber deins ist ja auch ein neues.
Aber jetzt habe ich gerade so schön übergeleitet.
Ja, du machst doch ganze Überleitungen kaputt.
Ach so, dann ich warte wieder.
Ja, aber dann surft Dennis.
Ich schreibe mir danach Dennis Thema auf, auf die Liste. Dennis Thema. Dann machen wir eine schöne Überleitung, Dennis. Nee, das ist das Abenteuerliche da dran. Mag ich so daran mit dir zu Podcasten. Das ist immer Abenteuer, Thrill und Excitement.
Einer muss ja für das Spannende, sonst schlafen die Hörer ja voll ein.
Mac App Store, wann kommt der denn jetzt eigentlich? Im Januar oder so? Hat jemand nachgerechnet, wann das Announcment war?
90 Tage hat er gesagt.
Ja, das sind drei Monate.
Wann war das Ding eigentlich?
Da war ich auch schon.
Guck in Mobile Max, wann wir unsere Folge hatten, die das Thema behandeln hat.
Ach, wir behandeln doch mal alles total verspätet. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, es wird jetzt irgendwie Januar oder Februar kommen. Ich meine 90 Tage, das müssen sie ja dann auch erstmal liefern. Ich frage mich jetzt, wie sie bestimmte Sachen da lösen werden. Ich meine, mal andersrum. Habt ihr euch irgendwelche Gedanken darüber gemacht? Was das bedeutet?
Naja, so ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen reicht schon.
Naja, ich sitze halt so manchmal da, so abends zum Entspannen. Und denke mir so, wie wäre denn das jetzt, wenn der App Store schon auf Mac wäre und ich jetzt dieses Programm, das ich mir gerade runter lade, über den App Store klicken würde und mit diesem irgendwie draufklicken und sofort an der richtigen Stelle und so. Und eben dieses Problem, also das, was mich eigentlich am meisten interessiert, ist tatsächlich, wie sich das mit diesen Trial und Beta und sonst was Versionen verhält. Ob die dann wirklich eben diesen Parallelfilm fahren. Auf der Webseite kannst du dir die Trial und die Beta und was auch immer runterladen. Und im App Store gibt es dann irgendwie mit Woche Verzögerung die Releases und ohne Demo-Version oder ob es dann eben diesen Weg gibt. Die hauen jetzt alle die Gratis-Versionen, die aber irgendwie beschränkt sind rein. Vielleicht gibt es ja da auch eine zeitliche, also du kannst eine zeitlich beschränkte ab in den App Store oder sowas reinstellen und dann kannst du einen In-App Purchase machen, um auf die Vollversion abzugraten oder sowas.
Gibt es da schon einen In-App Purchase von Anfang an?
Es gibt keine Aussage darüber.
Also man würde ja annehmen, dass ihr das...
Vermutlich wird es keine geben, aus dem einfachen Grund, weil das ja bedeuten würde, dass eine neue API kommt, aber da es ja jetzt auch mit 10.6 schon geht und du jetzt ja sozusagen Programme, die nur gegen Mac OS 10.6 programmiert, in den Store kommt, es da aber kein In-App gibt, gibt es das halt nicht. Du kennst dich ja auf dem Macintosh. Das heißt, alles was dein Programm tut, muss Macintosh API sein und du darfst ja keine private API auch nicht mehr benutzen. Und alles ist mindestens 10.6.
Wie alles mindestens 10.6?
Du hast da so eine Zehntal-Taste auf deinem Computer.
Habe es jetzt nicht so schnell gefunden.
Was? Hat dein Teil das irgendwie anperrt?
Ja, aber es kann auch sein, dass in dem Moment, in dem man muss sich ja irgendwie diesen Mac Store installieren, und das wird ja wahrscheinlich ein Installationsprogramm sein.
Aber die Installer, die machen ja keine API-Changes innerhalb von Sub-Binddienstes.
Es gibt diese API einfach nicht. Ja, die können das auch nachrüsten. In Mac OS 10.6 gibt es nicht. Sie können es nachrüsten, aber jetzt gibt es das nicht.
Jetzt gerade kannst du nicht in Apps machen, weil es das einfach nicht gibt. Doch, aber du kannst ja schon Apps einreichen.
Du kannst ja Apps schon einreichen. Die sollen ja jetzt in ein paar Tagen dann verwirkbar sein.
Ja, aber als Entwickler kann man sich doch auch, ich hab den entsprechenden Account nicht, aber als Entwickler kann man sich doch auch den Mac Store schon runterladen, kann sich dieses ganze Getöse, was man dafür braucht, schon installieren.
Kann man?
Na, ich glaube...
Den Store kann man schon runterladen?
Na, ich weiß nicht, ob den Store selber, aber auf jeden Fall dieses...
Man kann Apps schon zu denen schicken, aber...
Man kann auch die entsprechende Mac OS-Version runterladen, mit der das dann alles geht. Man muss ja auch testen können, ob dieses ganze Installationsprozedere und ob das dann vernünftig läuft.
Wieso muss man das testen können?
Naja, weil man wissen will, ob es funktioniert, bevor man es anreicht. Macht sich gut.
Aber dein Programm muss ja da nichts...
Doch, doch, beim iPhone testet man auch nicht vorher, ob das schon mit dem iPhone runtergeladen werden kann. Man kann nur testen, ob das Programm auch mit dem iPhone läuft.
Auf jeden Fall, ich hab nichts davon gehört.
Ich schon. Das ist von In-App-Chat.
Das war nicht die Rede. Und ich vermute, weil davon nicht die Rede war, würde es das nicht geben. Mich würde es auch nicht wundern, wenn das alles erst mit Laien kommt und sie da sozusagen einen Mac-App-Store-RP-Teil in ihrem OS quasi fest mit drin haben und dieser ganze Climbim mit ich kauf was dabei ist und so weiter.
Was mich ja mal interessieren würde, wird Laien dann kostenlos werden? Dann wär doch eigentlich nur konsequent, weil wenn sie damit dann eine größere User-Basis erreichen, könnten sie ja so argumentieren, also beim iPhone ist ja auch immer die neueste Version kostenlos.
Es ist ja echt kein Problem, selbst wenn sie Geld nehmen.
Ach, ich weiß, also so die Mac OS-Adaptionsrate ist nicht so extrem hoch.
Also wenn du jetzt ein Software updates...
Aber hallo.
Das war ja auch billig.
Auch bei den anderen.
Aber bei den anderen gibt es viel so...
Tiger ist wirklich nur ein verschwindend geringer Teil des Mac Marks.
Tiger, das war 10,4, ne?
Das ist nicht viel.
Liebte Nora kann bei Omni Group mal die Statistik-Seite rausfinden. Die haben sowas nämlich. Da sieht man die Adoption-Rate ziemlich gut.
Aber nur für ihre Software.
Aber sie könnten noch an dem Moment einfach ihr Geschäftsmodell ändern. Sie könnten noch sagen, wir verdienen jetzt ein Betriebssystem darüber, dass wir diesen Mac Store drin haben, dass die Leute darüber kaufen wie Bekloppten und darum können wir unsere Software kostenlos raushauen. Das machen sie doch beim iPhone genauso.
Ja, aber das ist nicht Apples Weg, weil Apple macht Dinge nicht sinnlos, kostenlos, weil die Leute es ja auch so kaufen und dann machen sie da schon Geld und warum sollen sie nicht überall Geld machen? Wenn sie da ein gutes Produkt liefern, dann kaufen die Leute das auch. Das ist das, was du durch die Bank überall siehst. Apple macht keinen nennenswerten Discount, sondern sie investieren in gute Qualität und dann kaufen die Leute es eben auch zu einer höheren Preismarge, als vielleicht der normale billig PC-Höcker für angemessen hält.
Das MacOS ist auch kostenlos, wenn du den Mac kaufst.
Nee, aber ich muss für iOS, auf meinem 3GS, muss ich für iOS 4 kein Geld bezahlen. Und beim iPod hatten sie es schon mal, dass du dafür Geld bezahlen musstest für ein Software-Update und haben es rausgeschmissen.
Also ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass sie das OS gratis machen.
Und insofern warum nicht?
Ich kann mir das auch vorstellen, aber ich halte es nicht für wahrscheinlich. Ich denke, sie werden da einfach ihren Preistick drauf machen. Ist ja auch egal. Mir ging es jetzt eigentlich auch ein bisschen mehr um diesen Upstore und welche Konsequenzen das hat. Wolltest du jetzt schon ein Thema einbringen?
Nee, aber ich wollte dir kurz die OS-Verteilung erzählen. Bei Omni Group, also die messen halt nur die Zugriffszahlen auf ihre Webseite und ihr wisst ja Omni Group, Omni, wie heißen die ganzen Apps?
Scruffle, Outliner, Plan, Focus, Omni Web, Omni, Omni, Omni Disk Sweeper und so weiter und so fort. Und diese Software-Update-Checks, sind das?
Ja, genau. Und Leute auf deren Webseite wahrscheinlich, also weiß ich gar nicht, ist egal. Hab ich im Chat gepostet, die ist einfach update.omnigroup.com, dann kann man sich das da auswählen. Auch die einzelnen Unterversionen kann man auch wählen, aber ich hab jetzt erstmal Haupt-Major-OSes geklickt und die meinen Tiger hat noch 20% Leopard komischerweise noch 15,5% wahrscheinlich weil sie viel abgegradet haben auf Snow Leopard. Wahrscheinlich, obwohl, egal. Und Snow Leopard ist bei so knapp 65% und 10.3 wird da gar nicht mehr aufgelistet, das ist wahrscheinlich unter Ferner-Leafen oder keine Ahnung.
Okay, das würde Max Punkt stützen.
Kann sein, dass, aber Leopard lief ja auch noch auf PowerPC, sonst könnte es der Grund sein, dass ganz viele Leute bei Tiger hängen geblieben sind, weil sie noch alte Hardware haben oder so. Aber eigentlich lief Leopard auch auf PowerPC noch. Das war das Letzte. Deswegen wundert es mich ein bisschen, ob Tiger mehr hat als Leopard, aber gut. Oder haben die das einfach mal vertauscht?
Wieso, Tiger wird kontinuierlich weniger?
Ja, aber der Anfang sieht ein bisschen komisch aus.
Der Anfang sieht tatsächlich irgendwie merkwürdig aus, weil am Anfang sieht es so aus, als ob Tiger dann irgendwann mal auf 40% gewesen wäre, während Leopard schon auf einem absteigenden Ast gewesen wäre.
Da haut irgendwas nicht ganz hin.
Tiger 20,7%. Ich meine, das ist Omni, wobei ich jetzt bei Omni eher erwartet hätte, dass sie...
Wobei das kann natürlich auch daran liegen, dass sie irgendwie da angefangen haben, ihr Updatesystem einzuführen, zum Beispiel. Kann sein, ne? Dann sind natürlich die allerersten, die immer sofort alles aktuell haben, auch die, die ihr Betriebssystem gerne aktuell halten, und dann erst im Laufe der Zeit kriegst du eine halbwegs realistische Verteilung.
Man ist Tiger auf den Markt gekommen, doch nicht erst 2009.
Tiger, nee, nee. Das ist jetzt nur das letzte Jahr, warum auch immer. Müsste da eigentlich schon auch mal ein bisschen länger gucken, aber die haben halt immer nur das letzte Jahr anscheinend. Da ist es ein bisschen blöd.
Leute, die Omni-Group-Software einsetzen, das da schon eher Leute sind, die ihren Rechner auch aktuell halten und sich ein bisschen auskennen mit dem Zeug. Ich glaube, so der kleine... 29. April 2005 kam Tiger. Und 2007 kam Leopard.
Genau, zweieinhalb Jahre später.
20 Prozent?
Das ist schon schon viel. Das darfst du echt gar keinem Programmierauftrag-Jemand erzählen, weil der sagt, du musst noch für 10.4 programmieren.
Na gut, aber ob das jetzt sozusagen... Ich meine, wir können ja mal hier bei MarketShare, tra la la, gucken. Ihr wisst schon, hier die Jungs, die mit den Web, also sozusagen die Webseiten analysieren, wobei ich glaube, dass Apple die Betriebssystemversion in den String mit eingebaut hat, das ist bei Safari auch eine Weile her.
Trommelwirbel, Trommelwirbel, Trommelwirbel.
Das ist jetzt extrem spannend zuzuhören, während wir hier ins Web starren und darauf warten, dass die Webseite lädt.
Also ich hab hier gerade so eine Statistik von Apple Insider, und die ist allerdings schon vom Ende Februar, also jetzt schon deutlich älter. Aber da hatte 10.5 noch über 50% Marktanteil, und da war 10.6 auch schon ein halbes Jahr alt. Und Taija auch so mit knapp unter 20% immer noch. Und selbst ältere Versionen haben auch so 5%.
Aber dieser Store, da könnte ich... Ich mein, das ist im Prinzip die erste Maßnahme, wo die Entwickler einen riesen Incentive haben, die letzte und aktuellste Version des OS zu targeten. Und nur die. Weil du weißt, wenn du in den Store gehst mit deiner App, da musst du nichts anderes unterstützen. Und du musst auch das neueste unterstützen. Das hat aber auch den riesigen Vorteil, dass du sagen kannst, okay, jetzt kann ich aber auch alles, was bei 10.6 dabei ist, als gegeben voraussetzen. Objective-C 2.0 und der ganze Parallel-Processing-Kram hier. Wie heißt das? Genau, Blocks, die ganze moderne Programmierung, also Garbage Collection. Das macht natürlich was aus. Und ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass wir moderne Software sehen.
Ich glaube, was wir massenhaft sehen werden, sind so eben diese kleinen Apps, die auf dem iPhone so unglaublich gut funktionieren, dass die verstärkt auf den Mac kommen. Also hier Reader, würde ich sagen, der ist wie gemacht für diesen Mac Store, oder App Store, oder wie auch immer der heißt.
Der ist wahrscheinlich auch dafür gemacht.
Der ist wahrscheinlich auch dafür gemacht. Hier Flight Control, das ist jetzt auch rausgekommen, wird ja gerade über Steam vertrieben, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Und auch wie dafür gemacht, also so diese Apps, der Twitter-Client, der dann plötzlich nicht mehr wie Echo Phone im Augenblick irgendwie 20 Dollar kostet, sondern der dann irgendwie mal für 239 zu haben ist, oder sowas, das wird...
Aber ich finde es eigentlich eine gute Sache, weil es kommt mir so vor, als wenn die Preise gesunken sind dadurch.
Wodurch?
Na, durch diesen App Store.
Durch welchen App Store? Durch den Mac App Store?
Nee, durch den iPhone App Store erstmal.
Welche Preise?
Von Programm.
Von IOS Programm?
So grundsätzlich. Also sonst, also wenn es nicht diesen App Store gäbe und die hätten ihre Programme auf irgendeiner Webseite irgendwie zum Runterladen gemacht, dann wärs teurer, dann würde so ein Flight Control keine 80 Cent kosten, das kann sich einfach keiner leisten, sowas, das geht nicht. Wegen Abrechnungskosten und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn jetzt der App Store auf den Desktop kommt, dann denk ich auch, dass es ein bisschen die Preise runterziehen wird, weil es einfach alles besser händelbar ist. Und dann ist auch der Anreiz, das zu kaufen wieder größer, also das kleinere Preise, dafür größere Abnahmemengen.
Ja vor allem die ganze Handlingebühr, ich meine, der Developer muss halt 30 Prozent an Apple abtreten, aber das sind eben auch nur 30 Prozent, weil gerade, also was ich immer so höre von Entwicklern, allein Werbung, ja, also irgendwie.
Na Apple macht jetzt nicht wirklich Werbung. Es sind schon so ein paar Sachen, die gefeaturet werden, aber ich meine, die haben 300.000 Apps im iPhone Store, die werden nicht alle beworben. Also es geht einfach nicht. Also Apple macht so gesehen keine Werbung.
Na gut, sagen wir mal Platzierung, ja.
Also überhaupt sozusagen, wenn du Glück hast.
So ein Katalog, ja nicht so in der Top-Liste, gut, lassen wir das raus. Handling von Verkäufen, Lizenznummern ausgeben und der ganze Support, der dafür gemacht wird, mit Lost License Number, Recovery, Downloading, Updating, genau. Ja, überhaupt auch so Installationsprobleme.
Lizenznummern sehen und dann fallen weg auch durch den Mac Store.
Du musst dir einfach nicht mehr kümmern um den Scheiß. Weil du packst es wirklich in den Store, machst Urlaub, kommst wieder, guckst aufs Konto, yeah. Naja, so ist es doch. Du musst da nichts mehr machen. Du brauchst da wirklich nur noch aufs Konto gucken.
Ich glaube, du hast ein Haufen Nachteile.
Du musst schon auch noch Support machen.
Ja, wenn du nicht programmieren kannst, schon. Aber ansonsten?
Soll dein Programm funktionieren? Überhaupt nicht. Was ist doch im App Store?
Wäre doch nicht drin, wenn es gehen würde.
Ja gut, aber ich denke, der Aufwand ist geringer. Und sonstige Reseller fallen irgendwie weg. Also ich hab unterschiedliche Zahlen gehört, was sozusagen dieser zusätzliche Aufwand alles so ist. Aber vom Verkaufspreis bleiben sicherlich derzeit im besten Fall 50% hängen. Und von daher ist der 70-30-Cut auf jeden Fall eine Verbesserung. Ganz klar.
Na aber für jeden eine Verbesserung ist das die große Frage.
Ja, für manche nicht, die natürlich schon ein festes Modell haben, wie sie ihr Zeug losgangen. Aber zum Beispiel Omni Group hat eigentlich sowas. Und die haben auch gesagt, wir gehen App Store. Also sie wollen den ganzen Scheiß eigentlich auch loswerden.
Na, dass sie da loswerden, weißt du, ausschließlich in den App Store, oder werden die noch zusätzlich ihr Zeug so parallel vertreiben?
Das weiß ich auch nicht, da wurde schon gerätselt. Aber warum sollten die beides betreiben, macht ja auch keinen Sinn.
Na ja, weil erstmal gibt es halt auch noch Versionen, die sie targeten, wo es den App Store nicht gibt. 10-4, 20% ihres Marktes. Also das können sie jetzt nicht einfach ignorieren. Also das ist ein Transitionsprozess. Dazu kommt, dass es bestimmt auch... Das ist eine der Hauptfragen, die ich mir stelle. Wie ist das eigentlich mit Upgrades? Dazu hat sich Apple meines Wissens noch nicht geäußert. Und bei iOS ist es halt so, wenn du da ein Programm einstellst und du willst unter diesem selben Titel dann Updates raushauen, hast du keine Möglichkeit, dem Update einen Preis zu geben. Aber das ist natürlich für Applikationen, wo, was weiß ich, muss jetzt nicht immer gleich Creative Suite als Beispiel machen, aber jedes größere Programm. Wir wissen, wie das ist. Da gibt es irgendwie Dot-Releases, da gibt es Dot-Dot-Releases und das sind halt kostenlose Fixes. Und dann gibt es halt Major-Upgrades, wo drei, vier, fünf Programmierer eineinhalb Jahre daran arbeiten. Und das können sie nicht dann einfach zu dem Original-Verkaufspreis machen und nur darauf spekulieren, dass es ja immer genug Neukunden gibt, die das dann entsprechend mitfinanzieren. Sondern es muss natürlich auch irgendwann mal für die Altkunden, die nachziehen und die quasi Features kaufen, die nie auf einem Zettel standen zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie ihr Portemonnaie mal gezückt haben, auch zur Kasse gebeten werden können. Und meiner Meinung nach ist das ein Feature, was wir hier sehen werden, auch wenn das noch nicht angekündigt ist, aber das muss kommen, gerade weil auf dem Mac einfach die Applikationen anders sind. Aber ich denke, man muss sich auch ein bisschen davon trennen, von der Art der Applikationen, die wir sehen werden. Ich denke, diese App Store wird vor allem erstmal eine Menge Programme hervorbringen, die wir so bisher noch gar nicht hatten. Erstens, weil sie eben nicht zu einem so niedrigen Preis produziert und verkauft werden konnten, damit sich das überhaupt lohnt. Und dass für die Leute eben auch diese Eintrittsschwelle niedrig genug ist. So kleine Spiel-Ups. Genau, so ein Kram. Ich rechne vor allem mit einem sehr hohen Casual-Game-Anteil. Utilities. Doch auch. Alles.
Einfach alles.
Ja, nicht alles.
Doch.
Nee, da wird kein Autocut und da wird kein Photoshop über diesen Store vertrieben werden. Gerade weil diese Major-Update-Problematik ungeklärt ist.
Und so Mozilla, Firefox. Nee, aber auch hier dieses Postbox wahrscheinlich. Also wenn die so... Also das sind... Also wäre mal spannend zu sehen, ob die das... 29, also vom Preisgefühl...
Ja, das kann sich da reinpassen.
Aber das müsste deutlich billiger sein.
Weiß ich nicht. Also ich bin ja... Also ich besteh da jetzt nicht unbedingt drauf, dass da die Apps dann auch so ramschig rübergehen. Also ich zahl auch mal 30 Dollar für eine coole Produktivitäts-App. Also für eine, die... Also wie mein Mailclient wirklich ein essentielles Kommunikations-Tool ist.
Omni nimmt auch in IOS richtig viel Geld für ihre Apps.
Verkaufen die sich denn da auch gut?
Die sind da gut dabei.
Also ich hab ja manchmal so das Gefühl, dass Programme, die am Anfang teurer sind, dann im Laufe der Zeit deutlich günstiger werden. Und dann von den selben Publishern irgendwann mal die Programme von Anfang an so günstig kommen. Also gerade bei irgendwelchen Spielen und sowas.
Der Standard-Business-Plan für Start-ups ist start-high. Und dann kannst du da immer noch runtergehen. Wenn du schon niedrig anfängst, dann hast du keinen Spielraum.
Aber dass sie dann anfangen, beim nächsten Spiel, was sie rausbringen, auch gleich von Anfang an den Preis geringer zu machen.
Wenn sie sich vorher schon mit Breakeven und so konsolidiert haben und dann schon wissen, wieso der Hase läuft, klar.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man einfach wesentlich mehr Umsatz macht, wenn man es billiger verkloppt.
Das ist die alte Regel, aber da gibt es halt auch zwei Kirchen. Die eine Kirche sagt, Masse durch geringer Preis lohnt sich irgendwann. Und die anderen sagen, wir haben gar keine ab, mit der man eine Masse erreichen kann, sondern wir müssen das über den Preis reinholen und wir tun es dann auch. Und das geht halt auch. Man guckt dir die Top-Grossing-Ups bei iOS an, da ist ganz vorne immer ein Navigon. Und das kostet was? 60, 70 Euro? Das ist die Applikation, die am meisten Geld verdient. Und nicht...
Nein, nein, lang nicht mehr.
Ergo? Geld verdient.
Ja, aber sind die immer noch dabei da vorne? Ich glaube, die sind schon länger Zeit nicht mehr dabei.
Ich soll gerne mal reingucken, aber das war auf jeden Fall nicht...
Umsatz start, Navigon 90 Euro, als zweites iOutbank 3 Euro. Und dann Umsatz, ja, als drittes kommt wieder Navigon, aber da steht gratis, verstehe.
Was?
Und danach dann TomTom 40 Euro, Need for Speed 4 Euro, Bild 80 Cent, WhatsApp 80 Cent, Modern Combat 55, TomTom Europa 80 Euro, Angry Birds 80 Cent und so weiter und so fort.
80 Euro für dieses TomTom, sind die denn alle total besoffen, diese komischen Navigationshersteller, die haben doch echt...
Und Doodle Jump immer noch auf Platz 15. Krass, die müssen also schwimmen in Geld.
Aber ich glaube so ehrlich gesagt...
Aber das zeigt, es gibt Klassen von Programmen, wo die Leute bereit sind, auch hohe Preise zu bezahlen und damit kann man auch viel Geld verdienen. Du machst halt dann nur ein Fünftiesel der Stückzahl, aber 80 Mal so viel Geld pro Einheit.
Aber ich glaube, mit diesem Navigationssystem ist das auch so ein deutsches Phänomen. Ich glaube, dass kein Amerikaner bereit wäre, so viel Geld verdienen.
Dann kannst du dann mal in einen amerikanischen Store reingehen und stürmen, wie es da aussieht.
Da fällt mir gerade ein Microsoft Lob die Zweite.
Ja?
Habe ich heute gelesen.
Lob dem Microsoft.
Lob dem Mic... Die haben nämlich jetzt Open Street Map Support angekündigt. Erstens haben sie ihnen irgendwie richtig viele hochqualitative Luftbilder geschenkt, damit die Open Street Mappler fleißig die...
Also nicht geschenkt, sondern zur Nutzung freigegeben ist richtig sehr, ne?
Genau.
So wie Yahoo das auch schon immer gemacht hat.
Aber eben mit dem Zweck, dass die Community leichter Wege nachzeichnen kann. Und dann haben sie irgendwie noch ein eigenes Edit Tool angekündigt. Also da gibt es ja so Java Tools, die wirklich ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig sind oder so einen strengen Open-Source-Gui-Geruch haben. Und da haben sie angekündigt, dass sie jetzt auch ein cooles Tool dafür bauen wollen. Mal sehen, ob sie das auch für andere Plattformen raushauen. Und ja, benutzen das angeblich. Bei Bing Maps finde ich ja echt schön. Das ist Open Street Maps, das ist echt nach wie vor immer noch eins meiner Lieblings-Open-Soße-Projekte.
Ja.
Das kann man gar nicht oft genug sagen, dass man da mal, also die könnten erstens mal ein Flatter-Button sich auch hindengeln und zweitens jeder, der noch nie bei Open Street Maps irgendeinen Weg eingezeichnet hat oder irgendeinen Gartenzwerg im Nachbarsgarten soll das mal tun.
Ich hab bei denen mal wirklich eine fehlende Straße mitten in Berlin eingezeichnet. Haben sie auch noch nachgetragen?
Ich hab auch so einen Weg da schon eingetragen. Ja, es geht schnell.
Bei Bing?
Nee, also Open Street Maps.
Was heißt, sie haben es eingetragen? Du hast es eingetragen.
Ich konnte da keine Linie ziehen, sondern ich hab gesagt, da fehlt eine Straße. Achso, du hast so einen Bug-Report gemacht. Genau, so ein Bug-Report. Und dann haben sie die Straße nachgetragen.
Es gibt ja auch eine Straße in Berlin, die seit drei Jahren verändert ist. Und es ist nur ein Open Street Map richtig. Nur. Nicht in meinem TomTom, nicht bei Google Maps. Ich guck gleich nochmal bei Bing, ob sie da...
Ich glaub bei Google Maps, also ich guck jetzt nochmal nach, da ist bis heute der S-Bahn-Ring nicht geschlossen. Und der ist jetzt ja wirklich seit 10 Jahren dicht.
Wie kann denn das sein?
Der S-Bahn-Ring ist nicht geschlossen.
Wenn er doch Ring heißt.
Steht nicht Ring dran, steht S-Bahn C.
Naja, also der Ring, den gibt's jetzt ja noch nicht beliebig lange, so die Ringbahn, die im Kreis fährt. Und aber jetzt auch schon...
Das heißt, wenn man da drin einpendet, dann stirbt man da.
Du wusstest bis eben gerade nicht, dass es eine Ringbahn gibt in Berlin?
Aber ich bin schon mal an der U-Bahn eingepennt und die haben mich an der Endstrasse noch nicht aufgewacht. Und dann ist der Zug wieder zurückgefahren und hab mich gewundert, warum die U-Bahn auf einmal auf dem anderen Gleis fährt.
Ich nehm alles zurück. Die Ellen-Abstein-Straße ist bei Bing drin.
Ja, die benutzen ja auch Open-Speak-Bremsen.
Na, tun sie das jetzt schon wirklich? Also ist das Kartenwerk, was wir jetzt hier sehen, jetzt schon OSM-synchronisiert?
Na, ich vermute, sie wären einfach OSM als zusätzliche Quelle benutzen, oder? Also, die wären vermutlich keinen eigenen Renderer, dafür einfach nur gemacht haben. Ich denke mal schon, dass die das eher so als Informationsköder nehmen. Aber da müsste man mal noch ein bisschen nachrecherchieren. Nee, das Tolle ist halt auch bei Open-Speak-Map-Bär vor allen Dingen, dass du eben an die ganzen Informationen rankommst, der die selber auch rendern kannst. Da gibt es ja verschiedenste Renderer mit unterschiedlichsten Prioritäten, was da überhaupt gerendert werden soll. Und Offline-Maps und den ganzen Krimpel ist einfach ein...
Oh geil, bei Google Maps kann man zwar nach der Ellen-Abstein-Straße suchen, und er zeigt einem auch so eine Barke an, wo sie sein müsste, aber sie ist nicht als Straße verzeichnet. Das ist ja auch cool.
Nichts können die.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, wer Ellen Abstein ist. Naja, also ist alles so eine Sache, aber es stimmt schon. Aber sie haben ja diesen Steve, wie heißt der Steve Case?
Genau, den haben sie sich ja auch geschnappt.
Den Gründer von OSM haben sie eingestellt und das sieht mir schon so aus, als ob die da das ernst meinen. Also ich muss sagen, ich bin so ein bisschen verwirrt von diesem Bing Projekt, weil das macht ja so den Eindruck, als ob da bei Microsoft tatsächlich sich mal eine Gruppe hat etablieren können mit einem innovativen Ansatz, die auch in der Lage sind, so ein Shipping-Produkt da was zu machen.
Wie sagt man so schön? Not macht erfinderisch.
Also ich würde jetzt den Zustand, in dem sich Microsoft befindet, noch nicht als Not bezeichnen. Nein, das ist keine Not.
Nein, die haben immer mehr Gewinn.
Aber weißt du, die müssen halt ein paar mehr Jahre vorausblicken als wir und die sehen die Not glaube ich schon.
Ja, dass sie was machen müssen, sind sie schon. Aber ich meine ja offensichtlich was.
Steve Balmers Kommentar, so was ihre größte Schwierigkeit in der Zukunft ist, den fand ich schon sehr insight-voll. Er meinte so, ja, unser größtes Problem wird Windows 8.
Wieso? Weil 7 so gut ist.
Ja, weil sie nicht wissen, wohin sie das eigentlich führen sollen.
Ja, in Epstein war eine jüdische Pianistin.
Das ist Not.
Das ist 1942.
Ja, das ist Not. Das ist ja nicht Microsoft.
Ja, aber Microsoft ist cool. Microsoft Connect gibt's auch.
Aber ich bin ja mal sehr gespannt, was jetzt losgeht. Microsoft hat angekündigt, wie heißt das? Streetview?
Nee, StreetSight?
Ja, dieses Sideview.
Genau, davon hat man auch nichts mehr gehört.
Erstmal hab ich zum ersten Mal erfahren, dass sie sowas haben. Dann hab ich mir in Amerika das angeguckt, da gibt's das schon wie Streetview. Jetzt haben sie angekündigt, dass sie das machen wollen. Ich bin mal gespannt, wenn all die Leute, die gegen Google Streetview auf die Barriere gegangen sind, wenn die jetzt nicht genau gegen Microsoft auf die Barriere gehen, dann wissen wir, was gute Lobbyarbeit ist. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass da bestimmte Politiker dann plötzlich gar nicht mehr so ein großes Problem damit haben, wie bei Google. Und auch die Presse. Ich bin schon mal sehr gespannt drauf.
Bin ich auch mal sehr gespannt drauf.
Was kreuzt denn jetzt rum?
Das ist aber nicht die Mariann-Stadt. Ja, nee, es performt gerade so Windows-typisch überhaupt gar nicht. Aber ja, ansonsten Lob für Microsoft, ja. Nee, aber es ist schon cool, dass sie auf jeden Fall OSM supporten. Ich finde das gut.
Ja gut, die Frage ist, was wird da unterm Strich für OSM wirklich dabei rauskommen?
Also ich meine, das ist ja sowieso das Witzige in diesem Land.
Das kann auch sein, dass der Typ in einem Jahr wieder genervt abhaut. Das haben wir auch häufig schon gesehen.
Aber das steht ja auf einer Basis, die breit genug ist. Also da muss man sich wegen einem Typen sowieso auch nicht so wahnsinnig Sorgen machen. Also da gibt es ja...
Stimmt schon. Was ja interessant ist, der Typ hat ja nicht nur OSM gegründet, sondern er hat ja auch Cloudmade gegründet. Ich weiß gar nicht, was mit dieser Bude ist, die gibt es ja noch. Die hat Microsoft nicht gekauft, oder? Die auch selber so OSM-Karten und so weiter machen. Also er hatte ja quasi ein Business-Modell. Und...
Stimmt.
Was ist damit? Und wird er das Business-Modell jetzt bei Microsoft machen? Na, ich glaube, Microsoft hat ein anderes Interesse. Mit Microsoft kann man auch ein ganz anderes Business-Modell verfolgen, weil er ganz andere Möglichkeiten hat. Also, ja, ich hab mir noch nicht wirklich viel Gedanken darüber gemacht. Ich fand den Schritt nur ziemlich bemerkenswert. Und ich denke, dass sie versuchen, da bei den Maps irgendwie dran vorbeizuziehen. Und wenn sie irgendwie cool genug sind, in Deutschland Street-Four zu starten, ohne Häuser zu verpixeln, dann haben sie eh schon gewonnen.
Na, die Sache ist ja außerdem noch... Also, ich meine, die sind da eigentlich gar nicht schlecht aufgestellt. Die haben ja dadurch, dass sie mit Yahoo da sich angebundelt haben, haben sie ja sozusagen Yahoo Maps schon sozusagen auch als Datenquelle sich mit eingekauft, sozusagen. Und machen jetzt ja hier fleißig weiter, scheinbar.
Goa, gerade hier microsoft.com Klele oben. Hat schon jemand die Kinect ausprobiert von euch?
Aber irgendwie ist Microsoft gerade langsam.
Ich überlege, ob ich mir eine kaufe, um daraus ein Katzenspielzeug zu bauen. Also ich stelle mir das so vor, man hängt sich so eine Kinect an die Decke, dann so einen kleinen Mini-Beamer, über den wir auch nochmal reden können, so daneben, der dann so runtergeht.
Wollen wir kurz mal erklären, was Kinect überhaupt macht?
Das wissen alle, oder?
Sind wir ein Informationspodcast oder sind wir keiner?
Das ist das aber nicht Microsoft.
Also Kinect ist dieses 3D-Scanner-Teil, was so ein random Infrarot-Pixel-Feld in den Raum rein strahlt und dann mit einer Kamera das Ganze wieder aufnimmt und jede Bewegung registriert und aus dieser registrierten Bewegung ein 3D-Modell macht und aus diesem 3D-Modell in Echtzeit auch noch Körper, Gesten etc. erkennen.
Also eigentlich ist es ein Controller für die Xbox-Spielkonsole. Wollen wir mal an der richtigen Seite anfangen? Die wollen da mit so diesem V-Markt abgreifen.
Aber das ist alles USB, das kannst du irgendwie an deinen Rechner ranstellen. Es gibt auch schon Treiber für Mac und für PC.
Und die Hacke haben die auch schon losgelegt. Microsoft hat gesagt, ist okay, bastelt mal schöne Sachen.
Na, also das Ding war offensichtlich nicht sonderlich stark abgesperrt. Es hat keine zwölf Stunden gedauert, nachdem es auf dem Markt war in Deutschland, bis es die ersten Treiber gab. Und dann hat irgendjemand von Microsoft gesagt, die verklagen wir alle und das wäre hier gegen unsere Sicherheitsmaßnahmen und so. Und da waren die am Anfang ziemlich, vielleicht haben sie auch nur einen falschen Pressesprecher auf dem falschen Fuß. Das kann sein.
Weil am Anfang waren sie so ein bisschen Microsoft-mäßig drauf.
Sie waren so ein bisschen Microsoft-mäßig drauf und dann haben sie offensichtlich irgendwann mal mitgekriegt, Moment mal!
Das ist jetzt das Beste, was uns passieren kann.
Das Beste kann uns eigentlich gar nicht passieren. Und sie haben so versehentlich im Vorbeigehen mal eben, glaube ich, so den Standard gesetzt. Also ich gibt jetzt, ich lese so einen Blog von jemanden, der macht immer so Video-Animationen mit Processing. So sehr geile Sachen. Er stellt da im Wesentlichen halt, also ist kein Blog zu lesen, sondern das sind immer so Video-Animationen. Und der macht so für irgendwelche Fernsehsender irgendwelche Animationen und sowas, wo dann Vögel rumfliegen und hat dann so Schwarm-Modelle, die er dann implementiert und in Processing. Und das sieht alles sehr geil aus und 3D. Und der hat jetzt irgendwie seit zwei Wochen so eine Kinect. Und das ist wirklich noch so Bam, Bam, Bam. Jetzt hab ich da schon zwei angeschlossen von. Und zwei, wenn man die parallel zusammenlaufen lässt, dann hat man das und das Bild. Und das ist schon extrem geil.
Einfach um so random Noise zu erzeugen und so Gesten-Input zu machen.
Nee, du kannst dann so, also was ja relativ einfach geht offensichtlich, das war ja so einer der ersten Schritte, dass irgendjemand, hat er dann so ein Bild, also du siehst so eine Aufnahme von der Kinect und dann kann er das ganze 3D-Modell so ein bisschen drehen. Also du hast ja eine 3D-Aufnahme und dann kannst du das natürlich auch irgendwie als Live- wie 3D-Video-Stream in irgendeinem 3D-App laufen lassen und dann kannst du natürlich auch die Kameraperspektive ändern. Und dann hast du natürlich so schwarze Stellen, weil die Kinect guckt ja nicht wirklich hinter dich. Und das probieren sie jetzt gerade zum Beispiel hinzukriegen, indem sie einfach noch eine zweite Kinect anschließen.
Ah, dass man so einen richtigen 3D-Rundum-Scanner macht.
Dass man so einen richtigen 3D, und das funktioniert im Augenblick noch nicht so richtig gut, weil sich doch ziemlich gegenseitig stören die beiden Systeme.
Ja, weil die sich gegenseitig mit so Punkten besprühen.
Wahrscheinlich. Aber es ist, man kann was erkennen und es ist, man hat ein 3D-Modell und es gehen echt geile Sachen mittlerweile. Und vor allen Dingen an einer Geschwindigkeit, die ist sagenhaft.
Eigentlich müsste das dann nur funktionieren, wenn du sozusagen eine vorne und eine hinten hast, dass die Teilhände die Pixel der anderen sieht. Eigentlich müssten die direkt gegenüber stehen.
Also die haben so einen 90-Grad-Winkel jetzt gehabt. Und vielleicht sind die auch noch, obwohl so sauber ist das Bild.
Bei 90 Grad ist natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die eine einen Pixel erzeugt, die die andere dann sieht, die sie aber nicht einem eigenen Pixel zuordnen kann, relativ hoch. Während wenn sie sich gegenüber stehen, musst du nur verhindern, dass sie sich nicht direkt gegeneinander in die Kamera reinstrahlen.
Na ja, was da auch noch, du hast wahrscheinlich dann noch so tote Flächen dazwischen. Die wollen wahrscheinlich dann wirklich drei oder vier aufstellen, dass sie wirklich so ein komplettes Rundum-Modell haben.
Na ja, okay, das stelle ich mir knifflig vor, gerade wegen dieses Prinzipes. Aber das ist natürlich ein geiles Hackerspielzeug. Also gerade jetzt für Medienkunst ist das natürlich der Knaller, weil du damit so Interaktions-Dinge im Raum machen kannst, ohne viel Hardware installieren zu müssen. Und das finde ich schon, finde ich echt einen innovativen Ansatz. Wie ist diese Buhl, die das erfunden hat? Ich meine, Microsoft hat das ja nur gekauft, es war irgendeine israelische Bande, die haben das irgendwie angeboten, die meinten, das hätten sie auch Apple angeboten. Microsoft hat es dann gekauft. Und dann, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie groß der Anteil von Microsoft war ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie es gekauft haben. Die Kernidee in dem Sinne ist jetzt nicht bei Microsoft entstanden. Man kann ihnen sozusagen jetzt nur auf die Schulter klopfen, dass sie das Projekt auch wirklich bis zu einem verkaufbaren Produkt gebracht haben und nicht auf halber Strecke verenden lassen. Also ich bin da sehr gespannt und es hat so ein bisschen dieses Ding wie so mit dieser V-Mode, die wir ja hier auch fleißig nutzen. Und das sind so schöne Universalteile, die einfach für noch eine ganze Menge Sachen gebraucht werden können, die man so noch gar nicht hat. Also wenn ich mir zum Beispiel vorstelle, ein Roboter, der mit dir interagieren soll, der klassische japanische Traum des Haushalts-Helfer-Roboters. Das ist ja ein Kernproblem dieser Robotik, die Umwelt gut zu erkennen. Und wenn man sich anschaut, was die Xbox schon an Gesten und Bewegungselementen eines Menschen erkennen kann, wenn du das wiederum auf einen Roboter zurück übersetzt, der selber sich bipedal bewegt, der könnte ja dann sozusagen schon auf so eine größere Menschenmenge losgelassen werden und interagieren. Wie viele Menschen kann das Teil gleichzeitig zwei oder so? Das ist, glaube ich, beschränkt auf zwei.
Also zwei kann es auf jeden Fall. Da habe ich schon schöne Videos gesehen, wie sie sich gegenseitig versehentlich verkloppen. Aber das will ich gerne in Aktion sehen, bevor ich das allzu weit noch traue, was das da an Gesten kann.
Da gab es aber auch schon YouTube-Videos, wo die auf irgendeiner Messe dieses Kinect vorgestellt haben. Da konnte man Halo spielen, glaube ich, oder so. Und dann haben da Leute probiert und nervt aufgegeben, weil es irgendwie komisch ist wohl.
Also ich kenne Leute, die sich das gekauft haben und die finden das ganz toll.
Also ich persönlich muss sagen, ich hab lieber was in der Hand. Aber vielleicht bin ich da auch schon wieder fast schon zu oldschoolig.
Naja, ich meine, irgendein Plastik-Dinge in der Hand halten kannst du immer noch, wenn du magst. Also davon hält dich ja...
Ne, klar, aber dieses Gehampel irgendwie, das so... Aber vielleicht...
Also ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass es einfach so was geben wird, wie dass du da noch so ein... dass du da irgendwelches Zubehörspielzeug gibst. lässt du irgendwo in China produzieren, irgendwie ein Schwert oder so was. Dann baust du noch eine kleine LED, eine Infrarot-LED, damit es halt so ein bisschen für die Kamera leuchtet, damit es sich noch besser positionieren kann. Und schon hast du was in der Hand.
Aber wir könnten zum Beispiel unseren Podcast so quasi als 3D-Modell live übertragen. Da müssten wir nicht so eine Videokamera nehmen, sondern wir machen sozusagen nur so 3D-Daten-Streaming. Und man kann so hier unsere Schemen...
Aber ich hab grad voll die Vision. Also, pass auf, jetzt geht's ab. Mach dir mal diese Scheiße aus. Genau, gar nicht als angemacht. Also ich will dir was erzählen. Also in der Zukunft, wenn du dir mal eine Wohnung shoppst, Quatsch, also suchst, so wie Max gerade. Heute gibt's ja irgendwie Schlafzimmer, Wohnzimmer, Küche. Also Küche, sag ich jetzt mal, wird abgeschafft, weil wird eh nur noch geliefert. Also der Raum wird damit frei für andere Sachen. Und dann in der Zukunft, weil ich höre schon mit diesem Schwert so für Kinect und so, du brauchst da irgendwie Raum und Platz, wo du das spielen kannst. Das heißt, was heute noch Küche ist, ist in der Zukunft mal der Spielraum. Das ist dann so ein Raum schon ausgestattet mit lauter Kameras und Zeug und Reflektoren und Bildschirme und all so einem Shit.
Holodeck.
Holodeck, genau. Das ist sozusagen die Küche wird zum Holodeck in der Zukunft.
Das ist ein schöner Sendungstitel übrigens.
Das brauchst du ja noch. Aber die Küche wird halt frei, weil man ordert eh nur noch, weil es geht gar nicht mehr anders. Und dann hast du diesen Raum und da zockst du dann. Und noch ein paar Jahre weiter, könnten schon so 50 oder 100 sein, dann endet es halt so wie in der Matrix. Dann ist es wirklich das Schlafzimmer, legst du einfach nur ins Bett und ab da wird nur noch gezockt. Zum Spielzimmer.
Die Küche wird zum Holodeck?
Weil man die nicht mehr braucht. Also meine Küche ist jetzt schon... Okay, da steht meine Waschmaschine und mein Server und mein Fahrrad. Ich hab einen Kühlschrank und da ist halt meine Metzomix drin. Ja, einen Waschbecken hab ich auch, weil die Pizza, die ich bestelle, muss man ja schon auch noch mit irgendwas schneiden. Ich bestell keine Pizza. Ich bestell eigentlich nie, aber ich bin auch nie zuhause. Ich esse eigentlich gar nicht zuhause.
Dann brauchst du auch keinen Holodeck, wenn du nie zuhause bist.
Genau, das würde ich dann im Holodeck spielen. In dem speziellen Raum dafür.
Ja, so kommt es bestimmt.
Aber naja, also mal ehrlich, dieses Kinect braucht schon ein bisschen mehr Platz, oder? Man kann das nicht so am Schreibtisch, man könnte jetzt hier zocken, auch wenn jetzt hier alles noch so zugestellt wäre. Man könnte ja am Schreibtisch jetzt schon zocken.
Ja, aber es gibt Leute, die haben dafür so ein Wohnzimmer.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch immer alles voll.
Wie der Chat richtig bemerkt hat, ist Dennis noch zu haben, ja?
Also, wer ihn will, wir können ihn gerne abgeben.
Bei unserem hohen Mädchenhöreranteil, Dennis, da ist auch noch was drin für dich.
Na ja, keine Zeit.
Wir könnten dir da auch helfen. Ansonsten kannst du auch eine Kinect kaufen. Ich hab hier gerade einen schönen Tipp bekommen, motionswinger.com.
Gibt es dann schon Porno Games auf Kinect?
Jaja, hier motionswinger.com.
Und dafür braucht man keinen extra Raum.
Das ist immer das Wohnzimmer. Ja, guck dir an, hier motionswinger.com.
Ja, aber weißt du, warum ich das Schlafzimmer erwähnt habe?
Du kannst dich auf deinen dreckigen Teppich knien. Und entsprechende Bewegungen machen. Da kannst du deine Avatare da...
Stimmt, waren das nicht die, die auch damit geworben haben, dass man da auch so Tier-Avatare mit reinpappen kann?
Oh man, ey, die sind neu.
Das ist doch richtig schöner Dreckskram.
motionswinger.com Holy shit, das geht?
Das sind drei, das sind drei, guck mal hier. Ein schwarzes Schaf, ein Esel und ein Tiger am Boden.
The times of watching prom is over. Großartig, ja. Das ist doch Rule 37.
Next Generation Adult Entertainment. Aber man ehrlich, das ist doch hier ein Mockup, oder? Weil man kann hier gar nichts klicken, das ist doch nur Spaß. Also Pre-
oder No-Button geht auf jeden Fall nicht. Das würde mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen... Schade eigentlich. Ja, das wollte man ja bloß mal sagen.
Sehr gut.
Welches ist jetzt eigentlich die Reusper-Taste? Siehst du, wenn man jetzt so ein Kinnick ist, dann könnte man so eine Handgeste für Reusper machen. Und dann möchte man eine Hand wehgelten.
Schöne Idee. Kann man mal machen. Gut, nach diesem Fake. Jetzt vielleicht mal das ernste Thema. Dennis, dein Thema.
Ach, ich darf jetzt? Also, ich hab jetzt zu Hause mein, es ist nur ganz kurz, ich hab zu Hause ja hier mein Router auf Freebies, etc. Vorspül, Vorspül, Sporspül, Skip, Skip, Skip.
Oh, jetzt gibt's es ja. Krass, logisch.
Und für die Hörer, die jetzt nicht wissen, was ich geskippt hab, die müssen halt Sendung minus 5 hören, also 5 zurückhalt oder so. Und jedenfalls hab ich dieses Intel Motherboard mit so einem Atomprozessor. Und ich hab hier durch Zuschriften und Twitter und so gehört, dass das auch ganz viele irgendwie so haben. Und da hab ich doch gestern erstaunt festgestellt, da gibt's eine neuere Version, die ist ein bisschen schneller, hat aber exakt den gleichen Stromverbrauch wie vorher. Das heißt also, man könnte sich jetzt irgendwie seine Kiste pimpen, kostet wieder mal 70 Euro oder so.
Bisschen schneller.
Das war ja wirklich cool. Das Ding heißt Intel D525MW. Das Ding vorher hieß halt 510, das neue heißt jetzt 525.
Das ist in dem PC-Bereich, die die ganzen Produkte bezeichnen, immer so mega sexy und einfach zu merken sind.
Ey, aber Intel Atom ist doch, kann man sich doch mal gut merken.
Was die es dabei denn gedacht haben, weiß ich auch nicht. Aber die Amerikaner finden Atom wahrscheinlich immer noch toll.
Also ich habe eine gegen komische Bemerkung, wenn sie es mal lange durchziehen würden. Also zum Beispiel auch Core 2 Duo, hat sich ja voll eingebürgert.
Core 2 Duo fand ich schon einen echt bekloppten Namen. Also 2 und Duo, das hat mir echt Hirnschmalz gekostet.
Das war halt die zweite Version. Weil vorher hieß es Core Duo oder Core 1 Duo, dann kam Core 2 Duo.
Was kommt danach? Core 2 Bi Duo?
Nee, Core 3 Duo, was denkst du denn? Nein, Core 3 Duo kommt natürlich oder Core 3 Quad. Aber was haben sie gemacht?
Aber ist doch voll logisch.
Ja voll logisch heißt doch lange nicht, dass sich das einem sofort erschließt.
Doch, das hätte sich erschlossen, hätten sie es konsequent weiter können. Aber was machen sie? Core i5 und Core i7. So, da weiß keiner mehr Bescheid. Und Core i3.
Besser als die ganze Scheiße über Jahre lang Pentium zu nennen.
Ja, das stimmt auch.
Jetzt soll es halt durchziehen mit dem Core 2 Duo. Core 3 Duo, Core 4 Duo und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, PowerPC war auch so albern.
Du weißt schon, was ich meine. Ich gehe aus den beliebigen Taiwan-Webseiten und dann kannst du halt überlegen, ob du den PC MX3M4-7-25 kaufst oder den BDSM-242930BDWW oder auch dieser Laserbreiter CM14-4. CM15, das hab ich schon wieder vergessen, wie der Scheißtal heißt. Jetzt muss ich schon mal meinen eigenen Bruder nicht mehr gerade gekauft haben.
Genau wie ich in der letzten Sendung ewig überlegen musste, wie dieser Samsung-Beamer heißt. Fiel mir einfach nicht mehr ein.
CM1415FNW. Wer denkt sich sowas aus?
Ja, aber die machen halt auch viele Geräte. Die haben bestimmt schon 100.000 Produkte released, die HP-Jungs.
Ja, und dann sollen sie den Blümchenwiese nennen und Blümchenwiese Pro.
Gibt's schon, da war schon ein bisschen...
Welche Blümchenwiese Pro, das ist der Titel.
Aber habt ihr auch gelesen, das ist die Grafikkartenhersteller. Also ich glaube, AMD war es in dem aktuellen Fall, aber der Konkurrent hier, Nvidia, macht das auch, dass die ihre Mobile-Chips irgendwie einfach mal umgenannt haben, um diese Zahl zu hören, weil sich die meisten Kunden blicken eh nicht mehr durch und denken alles klar, 6.500 ist noch ein bisschen besser als 6.400 und dann machen sie irgendwann, wenn sie ganz alten Schrott CPUs noch oder GPUs noch loswerden wollen, dann renummern sie einfach alle mal ihre Karten und irgendwie der Kunde blickt nicht mehr durch und nimmt halt immer das mit der höheren Nummer, obwohl es eigentlich der alte Schrott mit einer neuen Zahl ist.
Also die haben wirklich ein oder dasselbe Gerät unter zwei verschiedenen Namen verkauft. Und zwar, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, haben sie, also unter dem Namen einer besseren Serie, das heißt, sie haben irgendwann mal diese Serie eingeführt, haben wahrscheinlich darauf gewartet, dass so die Reviews kommen, hey, der ist ganz gut. Und jetzt, wo dann der blöde Consumer dasteht und sagt, ja, das war irgendwas mit 6.000 und dann, ah, da ist ja einer, die kostet nur die Hälfte von den 6.000.
Genau, der alte Chip war halt 5.000, der neue ist halt 6.000 und dann führen sie plötzlich irgendwann den alten Chip auch unter 6.000 ein, damit die Leute nicht das Gefühl haben, nee, das ist ja das Vorserienmodell, das will ich nicht. Ja, voll Verarsche.
Das ist echt alles voll Verarsche. So geht das gar nicht. Wir prangern das an.
Aber wer denkt sich solche Produktbezeichnung auch aus? Das würde mich wirklich mal interessieren. Haben die irgendeine Logik? Das ist die Abteilung sowieso innerhalb unserer Firma, da hat die vier...
Marketing heißt das, das heißt Marketing.
Wenn ein Produkt schlecht ist, muss halt ein neuer Name her. Nee, das klar. So mit den 6000ern, 4000ern. Aber irgendwelche Samsung-Monitore, die haben ja wirklich so 5, 8, 3, 4, 3, 1, B, Schrägstrich, römisch 2.
Ja, aber ich kenne auch so eine Firma, da heißt es irgendwie 10, 5, 6 und 10, 6, 1 und...
Was sind wir sie uns für einen?
Die machen die die ganze Zeit nur auf Excel-Spreadsheets, die starten die ganzen Tage.
Aber wie gesagt, das war ja die Frage. Hat es eine interne Logik? 10, 6, 1 und 10, 6, 2? Das hat eine Logik, das sind Versionsnummern, die wurden mir irgendwann mal erklärt. Vielleicht haben diese Produktnamen ja auch eine interne Logik. Ich möchte sie nicht verstehen müssen, aber ich würde trotzdem mal gerne wissen, wie sie entstehen.
Nächste Sendung dann.
Naja, die sind vollkommen übermüdet, weil sie zu viel arbeiten müssen. Dann kippen sie halbschlafend auf die Tastatur, treffen natürlich mit der Stirn oben auf die Zahlenleise und dann haben sie ihre neue Modellnummer.
Ach so ist das!
Ja, so ist das.
So entstehen ja auch immer die Mobile-Max-Folgen-Nummer, ne?
Ja, wir sollten mal erwähnen, wir sollten auch mal hier noch mal Dank sagen, und zwar für die Refinanzierung der Pri-Show-Sushi-Runde.
Ich hatte Chicken.
Ach so, das hast du ja selber bestellt. Hättest du aber auch Sushi haben können.
Hattest ich ein bisschen Nigiri.
Naja, siehst du mal, ein bisschen Nigiri.
Und noch vielen Dank für meine One-Purse-Word-Lizenz. Der hört jetzt bestimmt zu, und ich bedanke mich noch mal ausdrücklich.
Genau, das Ganze kommt ja hier im Wesentlichen von euren Spenden hier über Flatter. Und da gibt es ja das tolle neue Feature, dass man jetzt auch subscriben kann. Subscriptions.
Das muss ich mal machen.
Das heißt, wenn man so einen Flatter-Button geklickt hat, dann kann man ihn nochmal, also vorher stand da so Flatter drauf, und dann wenn du da drüber hovers, dann steht da Subscribe, und dann kannst du nochmal draufklicken und dann geht so eine Bubble auf.
Muss man da irgendwas für machen?
Also bald klicken.
Ja nein, als Flatter-Nutzer schon klar, aber wenn man den dann einbaut, muss man da einen neuen Button für einbauen oder?
Nein, das geht generell mit allen Buttons. Du kannst sozusagen, wenn du einen geflattert hast, kannst du dann nochmal draufgehen und dann geht halt so ein Fensterchen auf und dann kannst du sagen, für drei, sechs oder zwölf Monate bitte diesen Button zum ersten des nächsten Monats automatisch flattern.
Kannst du mal gucken, ob das hier bei meinem Ding da auch geht? Also prinzipiell, du musst nicht Subscriber werden.
Ich weiß, ich hab das jetzt bei, es war ja gerade Datumswechsel, da hab ich das kurz beobachtet und bei Mobile Max waren es halt schon, ich glaub so 100 oder so. Das ist super. Das hilft uns auf jeden Fall weiter und wer...
Ja, noch ein bisschen mehr brauchen wir, damit wir uns auch noch zusätzlich Wasabi bestellen können, weil nur Sushi war ein bisschen doof.
Da war kein Wasabi dabei.
War nur ein Spaß.
Mich würde immer interessieren, oder was ich mal machen wollte, ist mal so ein Chrome oder meinetwegen auch Safari-Extension schreiben, die automatisch sobald irgendwo auf einer Seite, auf der ich draufkomme, ein Flatter-Button ist, den sofort klickt. So nach dem Motto, hier hast du, also dass das dann keine Nomen ist. Das wird dann entsprechend wenig.
Und warum willst du die Person selbst den Flatter-Button hinmachen und ob er gar keine Counter hat? Oder wie verstehe ich das?
Nein, ich will einfach, ich möchte eine Erweiterung. Also mir passiert das, dass ich, weil zum Beispiel in RSS-Feeds und so, ich klick da relativ selten drauf. Ich hab keine Ahnung, so irgendwie so, hab ich dann das Gefühl, dass es jetzt irgendwie was ganz Besonderes sein müsste, wo ich da draufklicke oder irgendwie sowas. Und ich hätte gern einfach, dass ich ohne, dass ich dran denken muss, sobald ich einen Artikel lese oder meinetwegen auch 30 Sekunden auf der Seite drauf bist, dann kommt da irgendein Skript an und sucht für mich die Seite ab, ist da ein Flatter-Button und ja, dann klicke ich den. Dann kriegt der einzelne natürlich immer deutlich weniger, aber ich hätte sozusagen meine Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie besser verteilt.
Was willst du jeden Button klicken, der da kommt?
Wär jeder Flatter-Button.
Na, wenn auf der Seite was steht, was du nun überhaupt nicht unterstützenswürdig findest?
Ich fand's doch gut genug, es zu lesen.
Also wenn du sagst, halt 30 Sekunden verweildauern, Flatter?
Also ein Flatter-Click lässt sich nicht zurücknehmen, aber eine Subscription lässt sich zurücknehmen.
Ich will ja auch den Flatter-Click gar nicht zurücknehmen, das ist ja auch okay.
Ich sag nur, wenn du sowas baust, was automatisch wegflattert, ich halte das für impraktikabel.
Aber man könnte es ja auch so machen, dass unten ein kleiner Timer erzeugt, drücke innerhalb von der nächsten 10 Sekunden hier drauf, wenn du das jetzt nicht flattern möchtest. Aber einfach um den Ansporn zu erhöhen.
Ich muss ja erstmal sagen, hab ich ja letzte Folge hier gesagt, hier mein Cube-Bastel-Projekt, hab ich ja auch Flatter reingebaut und hatte jetzt irgendwie so 40 oder so Klicks und hab jetzt irgendwie 11 Euro daraus bekommen, was voll cool ist, weil da kann ich mir schon wieder ein paar neue LEDs oder Chips oder sowas von shoppen. So, ist schon mal extrem cool. Seitdem bin ich jetzt auch voll auf dem Flatter-Film und versuche alle zu überreden. Mach doch einfach mal ein Flatter-Button hin, dann klick ich auch.
Dennis, vielleicht auch mal was um deine tote Software wieder zu reaktivieren hier für deinen Ease-View zum Beispiel. Da gab's ja richtig viel Nachfragen. Flatter-Button dran und vielleicht...
Ich steig da später ein, wie immer. Es ist wie mit Google Wave, weißt du, da mach ich mir wieder voll den Kopf und dann ist es weg.
Wie hat das bei dir funktioniert?
Hervorragend. Hervorragend. Also ich hab jetzt, wenn ich das richtig sehe, hab ich, ich durchschau dich die Statistik noch. Also Flatter-Revenue ist immer das, was ich verdient hab im Vormonat. Wenn ich also am 10.12. jetzt was gut geschrieben kriege, dann ist das immer noch von...
Für den November.
Für den November. Da hab ich 41,21 Euro verdient. Das ist jetzt dafür, dass ich...
Mit deinem Blog.
Ich hab so dieses kleine, genau, Blog. Wir müssen reden ist dabei und die Märchenschule, die Märchenschule verdient praktisch nichts. Wir müssen reden, hab ich neulich mal ausgerechnet. Das war jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Das war seitdem, also es gibt 35 Euro oder sowas. Und der Rest kommt über meinen Blog. Und zwar im Wesentlichen über zwei Artikel. Der eine, der hat mal richtig reingeknallt. Der hat über 100 Euro gebracht. 110 Euro in einem Monat oder sowas. Das war, liebe Nichtraucher, hier stinkt. Dieser Nichtraucher-Artikel.
Ja, Rahn-Safen, wa?
Rahn-Safen, ja.
Immer drauf, immer drauf.
Das finde ich auch ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen problematisch an diesem ganzen Konzept.
Naja, vielleicht war das alles Nichtraucher, die auch die Schnauze voll hat.
Jaja, klar. Und jetzt hier für meinen kleinen Google-Artikel. Der, der so in 20 Sekunden zusammengekotzt war, der hat auch ein bisschen Geld gebracht.
Kleiner Google-Artikel?
Ach, ich hab so ein paar Screenshots gemacht.
Ach so, mit Street View die Geschichte.
Genau, mit Street View und so.
Meine verpixelte Vergangenheit.
Genau, sozusagen, das wir gerade aufzeigen.
Ach, das ist sicher was, tritt vorreden, ich reg mich gleich wieder auf. Gut, egal, genug Werbepause.
Genau.
Habt ihr euch schon eure Steve Jobs Actionfigur gekauft eigentlich?
Ich hab meine schon kaputt gemacht.
Ja?
Nee, ich warte auf die Schiller-Actionfigur.
Ich hätte ja lieber eine Steve Jobs Voodoo-Doll. Aber ich glaub, die ist irgendwie zurückgezogen worden, diese, oder? Ist das ein Gerücht, das Apple dagegen vorgegangen hat? Bin mir grad nicht so sicher.
Wo geht gegen Apple eigentlich nicht vor?
Ähm, gute Frage. Gegen eine ganze Menge Sachen eigentlich, ich meine, wenn man das abzieht, was alles so geht.
Stimmt, es gibt nach wie vor mehr Dinge auf diesem Planeten, wo es gegen Apple auch nicht vorgeht, als wo gegen sie vorgehen. Aber das mit diesem MacBook Air, wo es mir gerade einfällt.
Ja, ich meine, was weiß man da eigentlich genau? Also diese Photofast, wie heißt die? Photofast heißt die Bude. Ähm, hat angeboten ein SSD-Kit für das MacBook Air. Ähm, jetzt weiß ich grad nicht für welches eigentlich. Das war doch auch nur eine 256. Das kann ja sozusagen nur fürs Kleine gewesen sein, weil das Große gibt's ja nicht.
Die war einfach die Sau schnell. Die hat wohl doppelt so viel Datendurchsatz wie die von Apple.
So, und jetzt geht sozusagen das Gerücht, das Apple dem Einhalt geboten habe. Da frage ich mich natürlich, warum? Beziehungsweise auf welcher Basis? Und das Druckmittel, was sie wohl an der Stelle haben, ist, dass sie ja für jemanden, der... dass sie sozusagen auf Leute, die Firmen, die quasi jetzt die Lizenznehmer sind bei ihnen und Third-Party-Kram verkaufen, Doc-Connector etc., andere Sachen, wo eine Lizenz erforderlich ist, wahrscheinlich auch dieses Airplay, dass sie da ja sozusagen dieses Druckmittel des Lizenzentzugs haben, was natürlich so einem Hersteller, der potenziell nur von sowas lebt, dann auch eine ganze Menge Druck gibt. Aber ich weiß nicht, es wurde ja hier gemunkelt. Es wurde auch, weil es gibt da wohl auch einen Proprietary-Connector, mit dem diese SSDs angeschlossen sind. Ich dachte, ich bin bisher immer davon ausgegangen, dass es sich dabei um eine Art Standard handelt.
Ich dachte auch, dass das jetzt als nächstes ein Standard umgesetzt wird.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ich hab so einen Teil noch nicht auseinandergenommen und wenn das halt wirklich ein Apple-Connector ist, wo sie wieder so eine Lizenzgeschichte drauf haben, dann mag das natürlich sinnvoll sein. Also sinnvoll im Sinne von, dann ist es erklärbar, was da jetzt eigentlich passiert ist. Ansonsten frag ich mich, wie sie so Druck ausüben können oder auf welcher Basis sie jemanden verbieten wollen.
Weil so für Festplatten-Upgrades und so weiter Vielleicht ist es ja mit dem Druck ausüben auch alles nur irgendwie fake, damit sie dann in der Presse stehen, damit sie demnächst dann halt noch mehr davon verkaufen. Kann man so sagen, jetzt geht's doch.
Na gut, das ist ja nicht unbedingt, was mit dem man gerne in der Presse steht, dass man irgendwie böse Druck ausübt auf irgendwelche Firmen.
Wobei Apple sich dann schon beschwert hätte, da hätte sie schon gesagt, die haben gar nichts gesagt. Aber wahrscheinlich ist das auch das, was sie erreichen wollen, dass Apple sagt, wir haben gar nichts gesagt. Weil das heißt, sie würden gar nichts sagen. Also ist immer alles sehr politisch.
Nee, Apple sagt da sowieso gar nichts drüber. Das machen die nie.
Also 30% mehr Performance soll das Ding bringen, angeblich.
Aber dass es immer noch etwas schnelleres gibt als Apple, ist jetzt auch nichts Neues.
Ja, aber dass Apple das probiert, vom Markt zu drängen, was das Nachrüst-Kit ist, was ihr in Rechner noch schneller macht, das ist schon was Neues.
Aber was soll denn Apple? Ich kann es mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen. Was soll die das denn stören? Das ist doch denen wurscht.
Ja, das ist ja gerade die große Frage, die wir stellen.
Das ist halt die Frage. Ich habe hier nur diesen Artikel bei itwire.com gesehen. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich dachte, ihr wisst es vielleicht.
Aber ich finde es ein cooles Konzept, dass man das Ding ausbaut und dieses USB-Teil da reinschieben kann.
Das finde ich eine coole Idee. Die haben doch so ein Gehäuse.
Die SSD ist doch dieses lange Stäbchen, sozusagen. Und du kaufst ja ein neues, was schneller ist. Und das hast du ja das alte übrig. Und für das alte haben die so ein längliches USB-Teil. Da schiebst du das rein und hast es dann gleich als USB.
Ach so, verstehe, dass du da sozusagen den Storage noch gleich weiter machst.
Ja, finde ich schon nicht so doof.
Ist ja nicht ganz billig.
Weil da lohnt sich es halt auch gleich abzugraben, weil man das alte auch nicht wegschmeißen muss, sondern was auch damit machen kann. Da könnte schon sein, dass Apple was dagegen hat. Aber was soll die dann stören? Da würde ich ja auch denken, das ist doch cool. Da kann man Leute noch mehr Geld ausgeben.
Vielleicht hat es ja auch irgendwelche tatsächlichen Gründe.
Weil Apple das rausbringen wollte.
Vielleicht gab es irgendwelche Inkompatibilitäten oder sowas. Ich meine, es muss ja nicht immer... Also es gibt ja... Das muss man ja auch sagen. Ich meine, es gibt da viel zu Recht-Theme gegen Apple, aber es gibt ja auch viele Gründe, wo das so getan wird, als ob Apple irgendwas runtergenommen haben. Und dann war es gar nicht Apple. Ich kann mich zum Beispiel daran erinnern, dass hier für euren Lieblingsclient... Wie heißt dieses Gold? Nee, wie heißt denn dieses Java-Welten, dieses Java-Spiel? Hat doch irgendjemand einen iPad-Client geschrieben, der dann auch nach 20 Sekunden aus dem Apple Store raus war, wo der Auto dann nachher meinte, ja, ich wusste gar nicht, ich hab den dann einfach so eingereicht. Dann war ich mir gar nicht mehr sicher, ob die das überhaupt wollen, ob ich damit vielleicht einen Urheberrechtsverschluss begehe. Und darum habe ich den selber wieder rausgenommen. Und dann haben sich natürlich alle schon aufgeregt, dass Apple jetzt Minecraft hier entfernt hat aus dem App-Store. Aber dann war es gar nicht Apple. Da war Apple ausnahmsweise mal nicht schuld. Und das gab es schon in eigenen Situationen. Das gab es auch mit diesem Browser, der Flash kann. Wie heißt das Ding jetzt? Skyfire, da dieses furchtbare Ding. Das haben sie ja auch selber aus dem App-Store rausgenommen. Auch alle so, ah, jetzt hat Apple das wieder rausgenommen. Typisch. Nee, haben sie selber gemacht, weil ihre Server-Kapazitäten mit dem Anstrom nicht gerechnet haben und ihre Server nicht mehr hinterher gekommen sind. Es ist nicht immer zwangsläufig gleich Apple schuld.
Dass wir das mal hier gesagt haben, wa?
Ja, gut. Kann ich jetzt was apropos Fanboy hier über PhoneGap so ein bisschen und so? Du kennst PhoneGap nicht.
Erklär doch mal. Du bist jetzt unter die iOS-Developer gegangen.
Ich bin jetzt unter die iOS-Developer gegangen. Ich hatte neulich so eine Idee für ein kleines App, was man mal machen könnte, wo ich gedacht habe, hm, am Anfang wollte ich mir einen Entwickler suchen, aber das war dann relativ schwer, jemanden zu finden, der Zeit hatte und so. Und die paar Leute, die ich angequatscht habe, die hatten alle nicht so richtig Bock. Dann hab ich gedacht, na probier ich es mal alleine. Und hab angefangen, das mit PhoneGap umzusetzen, dieses App.
Was ist das?
Genau, das wollte ich gerade erzählen. Das ist so eine Bibliothek für diverse Plattformen. So OpsSource jetzt mal. Mit der man in HTML und JavaScript native Apps schreiben kann.
Also WebApps.
Also eigentlich ist es erst mal nichts weiter als ein WebView, der im Fullscreen-Modus läuft, sozusagen. Und jetzt kann man sich aber Erweiterungen für PhoneGap schreiben, mit denen man dann auch, die man dann zum Beispiel auf dem iPhone in Objective-C schreibt. Und damit kann man dann weitere Funktionalitäten nutzen. Also zum Beispiel kann man da auf die Kamera zugreifen, man kann E-Mails verschicken über dieses eingebaute Interface, man kann native Controls anlegen und alles und Spaß. Und am Anfang war ich so ein bisschen, ach ja, jetzt hier in JavaScript irgendwelche iPhone-Programme schreiben, wie albern ist das denn? Und bin jetzt aber sehr, sehr angetan davon, weil zum einen JavaScript kann ich, HTML kann ich, ich konnte also sofort loslegen, ich konnte schon diese Funktionalität nutzen, die Funktionalität war relativ einfach nutzbar. Und es hat mich so an diese IOS-Programmierung dran geführt, weil ich wollte halt, ich wollte irgendwie, zum Beispiel ich wollte dieses, dieses Sendenformular, da gibt's ein Plugin für, mit dem man sagen kann, hier mach mal eine neue Mail auf und füll das schon mal für mich aus, hier das und das. Und da wollte ich ein Attachment dran haben, weil ich gerne ein Attachment verschicken wollte, ich wollte mein Datei verschicken, per Mail. Und darum hab ich einfach dieses Plugin genommen, hat ja einen Quellcode und hab den dann entsprechend erweitert um die Funktionalität, die ich brauchte, nämlich ein Attachment da dran hängen. Was, muss man echt mal sagen, dieser iOS API macht echt Spaß, extrem einfach war. Also es war im Wesentlichen ein Zweizeiler, den ich da gebraucht habe. Noch ein bisschen hier Glue-Code, damit er mit der JavaScript-Funktionalität zusammen arbeitet. Und jetzt hab ich das erweitert, dass es JavaScript kann. Und ich hab eins geschrieben, mit dem man ein Plugin, mit dem man Bilder im Fotoalbum abspeichern kann. Und jetzt kämpfe ich mich so langsam an die iOS-Programmierung ran. Und das macht echt Spaß, weil es ist, wie gesagt, wenn man ein bisschen JavaScript kann, kann man leicht anfangen, hat einen leichten Einstieg, hat eine Idee. Und da man sich diese Plugins angucken kann, hat man immer auch schön abgeschlossene Funktionalitäten, die schon da sind. Wenn man sich irgendwo so den Quellcode von irgendeinem iOS-Programm runterlädt, dann weiß man ja nie, was spielt so womit zusammen. Dagegen bei so einem Plugin, das hat eine haargenau definierte Funktionalität. Man kann es ausprobieren, kann gucken, ob es das ist, was man haben möchte. Und wenn es das ist, dann kann man es immer noch um eigene Funktionalitäten erweitert.
Das heißt, im Wesentlichen, ich habe diese Dualität nicht so ganz verstanden. Auf der einen Seite ist es eigentlich alles Webview, aber trotzdem ist es auch, kannst du sagen, jetzt hätte ich das ganz gerne, aber nativ. Und dann habe ich hier noch ein paar Libraries dazugeschrieben. Aber alles, was ich jetzt hier in JavaScript geschrieben habe, läuft dann intern in so einem Webview ab. Sodass, obwohl es eine App ist, es ist immer noch eine Webapp.
Also wenn man so ein Projekt anlegt, es gibt bestimmt tausend andere Wege auch noch, aber wenn man so ein Projekt anlegt, dann hat man erstmal ein Webview und hat da eine HTML-Datei, die wird reingeladen. Und in diese HTML-Datei packt man ein bisschen JavaScript-Code rein. Und die gesamte native Funktionalität, die so vorhanden ist, die wird über JavaScript-Hooks aufgerufen. Also das JavaScript kontrolliert alles und lädt sich diese Funktionalitäten dann rein. Und je nachdem, wie sicher man sich fühlt bei der Entwicklung mit iOS, kann man dann entweder sagen, ich bleib komplett in dieser JavaScript- und HTML-Welt und hab dann eben entsprechende Einschränkungen. Oder man sagt, ich guck mal in die und die und die Richtung, wie ich mir iOS-Funktionalitäten dazuschreiben kann, damit ich die von JavaScript aus nutzen kann. Und das ist für mich jetzt gerade eine sehr schöne Kombination.
Das ist alles open source und frei und dralala.
Und theoretisch funktioniert es auch. Sie haben so eine Kernfunktionalität, die funktioniert auch unter Android, Symbian, Blackberry, den üblichen Kandidaten. Das ist eine relativ große Auswahl. Für so einige Sachen mag das echt ganz gut sein. Das, was ich jetzt mache, das wird nur unter iOS funktionieren, weil wenn ich auf die Kamera per Coco zugreife, dann funktioniert das eben zwangsläufig nur auf dem iPhone. Insofern, aber reicht mir komplett. Macht viel Spaß. Cool. Großartige iOS-Programmierung. phonegap.com Genau. Und man muss gar nicht so viel... Es ist wesentlich einfacher, als ich gedacht hätte. Also ich bin nur noch nicht in irgendwelche Memory Leaks reingetreten oder sowas, aber das ist schon... Diese API ist, was ich bisher gesehen habe, relativ elegant, finde ich. Also man kommt sehr schnell zum Ziel, wenn man sich so ein bisschen an die Apple-Richtlinien hält.
Was uns so ein bisschen mal zu iPhone-Ups bringt, was so in letzter Zeit so erschienen ist und was vielleicht empfehlenswert ist, wo seid ihr denn so ein bisschen hängen geblieben?
Rage 3D HD oder wie heißt es?
Das heißt, man fährt die ganze Zeit wie in so einer Geisterbahn.
Ja, quasi.
Eigentlich durch die Gegend und muss Zombies erschießen.
Ich find's furchtbar öde. Ich fand's für den Keramik-Tron echt ideal.
Ah, Klo.
Für den Keramik-Tron. Also damals so kurz...
Hast du so ein iPhone da so neben der Kette baumeln? Wo früher so ein Comic-Buch lag, oder nach einer alten Zeit auch.
Genau, wenn jetzt 3D-Zombies weggepustet mit der Shotgun... Nee, klar, das ist öde. Also ist jetzt irgendwie nichts, womit man sich tagelang beschäftigt und so weiter und so fort. Aber die Levels sind ja auch relativ kurz. Das hast du in 0,0x durchgezockt. Das ist wirklich so ein Kurzwall-Shooter. Die Grafik ist durchaus sehr ansprechend.
Was hat man in 0,0x durchgezockt? Ich versage da immer.
Nee, dann fängst du auf easy an, die erste Runde. Dann hast du es auf easy super schnell durch. Weil da gehst du auch nicht kaputt. Und du kannst auch, wenn du tot bist, noch mal gleich an dem Punkt weitermachen. Also ist halt wirklich so richtig, komm, wir ziehen dich durch, schieß einfach. Der Reiz liegt da eigentlich vor allen Dingen natürlich in der Grafik und irgendwie so mal ein bisschen ballern, weil das was halt richtig nervt auf dem Phone, wenn du so eine Shooter oder so eine 3D-Geschichten spielst, diese Touch-Drag-Steuerung, das... Also auf dem iPad geht's noch vielleicht gerade so, aber irgendwie so richtig rocken.
Es gibt doch diese Demo, dieses von Epic hier. Citadel-Dingens. Ich komm da mit dieser Steuerung nicht.
Die Steuerung ist total ätzend.
Mit dem einen machst du vorwärts rückwärts und mit dem anderen kannst du dich aber drehen.
Nee, nicht nur, dass man es schwer blickt. Das ist halt auch einfach durch dieses Wischen. Dann wischst du oder tatschtest über den Rand drüber. Dann hat es keinen Kontakt. Und dann suchst du erstmal wieder diesen... Nups, das ist halt kein intuitives Interface. Und bei diesem Rail-Shooter, dann guckst du halt hier mit Neigung ringsrum. Kannst auch zur Not draggen oder so. Aber eigentlich steuerst du halt so augmented-reality-mäßig. Und ballerst halt rum. Das ist halt einfach intuitiver Zugang. Schöne Grafik und kurzweilig, also...
Ich liebe ja Programme, die komplett ohne Accelerometer-Bedienung auskommen, weil die kann man halt auch noch nachts im Liegen spielen. Während man dann immer so aufrecht im Bett liegen muss, um diese Sachen zu spielen. Also was ich schade finde, ist, dass man die dann nicht so kalibrieren kann. Also ich glaube ein paar Programme machen das, aber so grundsätzlich würde ich sagen, ich liege jetzt, so wie ich jetzt bin, das sozusagen mein Null. Und jetzt möchte ich gerne dazu relativ meine Kontrolls haben. Aber das sehen die irgendwie so alle nicht vor. Trotzdem gibt es ein Game, wo ich sagen muss, das hat mich echt gefangen. Also das war, am Anfang dachte ich mir, was soll das? Aber dann spielst du das und dann kriegst du richtig, zack, das ist dieses The Incident. Auch nicht neu. Hübsche Zeit nach Weile. Hast du schon mal gespielt? Dieses Abit aufgelöste Männchen?
Mich hat das auch nicht gekickt.
Ich fand das ganz cool. Vor allem diese krasse Speed, mit dem diese Scheiße da runterballert. Du musst irgendwie nach oben. Von oben fallen aber die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Dinge. Propeller, Kühlschränke, allen möglichen Scheiß. Und kracht so runter. Du musst dann immer so hochhopfen, darfst irgendwie nicht getroffen werden. Und dann musst du halt eben auch so mit links, rechts kippen dann immer ausweichen und springen.
Das war doch auch so ein Spiel, was dann irgendwie so iPad als Display und iPhone als Control jetzt irgendwie kommt.
Das ist da glaube ich auch noch mit drin, ja. Aber der eigentliche Spielwitz, aber was mir noch mehr entgegenkommt, was ich richtig cool finde, ist dieses Astronut. Das ist nicht Astronaut, sondern Astronut.
Das ist so, wo man so Planeten dreht, dann muss man nicht von einem...
Auf sowas stehe ich ja total. Also das ist irgendwie so meine Vorstellung von Casual Gaming. Ja, ist echt super. Du hast, vor allem ich finde das Setup ist cool. Du hast auch nur so zwei Button-Bedienungen. Du hast so springen und boost. Und eigentlich brauchst du nur dieses springen. Du bist halt quasi in so einer Galaxie, wo das viele Planeten sind und der kleine Astronaut. Du springst sozusagen und überwindest immer die Gravitation deines jeweiligen Körpers. Aber wo du dann genau landest, das hängt sozusagen genau von deiner Bewegungsrichtung ab. Und wenn du jetzt nicht so direkt auf so einen anderen Planeten zugesprungen bist und dann gleich wieder von seiner Gravitation eingefangen wirst, sondern irgendwo dazwischen rum eierst, dann kann es sein, dass du die Götze halt sowieso rumwirbelst und alle möglichen Himmelskörper, die da sind, zu greifen nach. Die haben aber nicht genug Gravitation und zwischendurch fliegen natürlich irgendwelche bösen Raumschiffe und sonstigen Space-Monster und können dich irgendwie fangen. Das zackt total. Also ich mag das voll gerne. Das ist so richtig schönes Casual-Game, kann ich euch sehr empfehlen. Toll.
Also mich macht sowas ja wahnsinnig, so dieses, wo es um nichts weiter geht, als zum richtigen Zeitpunkt irgendwo drauf zu ditchen. Ich kann ja nur nochmal Trainyard allen ans Herz legen.
Hab ich ja auch probiert mit Trainyard. Und? Da spielt man ja eeeewig diese Demolevel irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, eine halbe Stunde habe ich da irgendwie, war ich immer noch in diesem Tutorial, es ging irgendwie nie so richtig los. Kommt immer mehr dazu, aber es gab keine wirkliche Herausforderung, weil diese Level so einfach waren.
Die sind relativ einfach am Anfang, aber die werden...
Also ich hab es zeitlich nicht geschafft, irgendwann mal irgendwo hinzukommen, wo es schwierig wurde. Und dann wurde es dann schon langweilig. Da kamen dann auch immer mehr Features, das hat mich verwirrt, das hat mich zu wenig trainiert. Aber da kann man auch seinen Weg drin finden, das ist schon nett, aber das ist auch gut, ich mag das auch. Astronaut fand ich aber noch... Ich bin auch so ein alter Asteroids-Fan, ich mag das irgendwie so mit diesem Planeten und so Spacewar-Style.
Ja, gar nichts gegen einen zu wenden. Wie hieß denn dieses eine Spiel? Das dürfte dir dann auch gefallen. Das gibt's fürs iPad. Ach scheiße, das war so... Das, wo du nämlich von Astronauten erzählst, das ist so was... Es sind so entweder Sonnensysteme oder Zellen, die sich umeinander drehen. Und zwar geht das darum, du bist... Du hast so eine kleine Zelle oder Planet oder wie auch immer du das jetzt nennen willst.
Du kannst andere aufsaugen.
Und wenn du mit einer anderen zusammenstößt, wenn die andere kleiner ist als deine, dann gehört die zu dir.
Osmo komm oder...
Irgendwas mit Osmo. Ja, das stimmt, das spricht dafür, dass es... Und das ist auch so, dass... Genau, dann saugt man die anderen Zellen auf und wenn die anderen Zellen größer sind...
Osmos.
Und wenn die anderen Zellen größer sind als man selber, dann wird man von denen aufgesaugt, dann hat man Probleme. Dann hat man aber immer noch Zeit, schnell wegzukommen. Dann verliert man zwar unglaublich schnell Masse, aber...
Man hat auch mehrere Awards gewonnen, weil es auch so schick gemacht ist. Und so eine schicke Dudelmusik im Hintergrund hat immer...
Das ist super schick gemacht.
Echt schön gemacht.
Und das wird vor allen Dingen auch, das wird dann auch irgendwann noch so, kriegst du nämlich so Gravitationssysteme rein, relativ schnell. Also einige Level sind da extrem frustrierend von. Ich hab dann irgendwann das Verbot bekommen, das weiter zu spielen, weil ich mich jedes Mal so furchtbar drüber aufrege. Von meiner Freundin. Ja, aber es ist, das könnte was für dich sein. Ich glaube, du könntest da ja auch dich schön in den Wahnsinn betreiben. Osmos, Osmos, Osmos... Ha, Osmos, genau.
Willi, du bist gerade in dem O...
Ach, Carcassonne, haben wir jemals Carcassonne empfohlen? Ja, genau, das hab ich auch noch mal gemacht.
Da sind auch die Navigons auf Platz drei.
Na, TomTom.
Nö, in dem Fall war's grad Navigons.
Also ich hab jetzt grad noch mal geguckt.
Osmos und Osmos für iPad. Ah, dass die nicht Universal machen können.
Weil das eine 2.39 kostet und das andere 3.99.
Na, drauf geschissen. Dann kostet's halt 6 Euro für beide.
Nimm die iPad-Version.
Nee, viele spiel ich normaler. Ja, keine Ahnung, nee, dann kauf ich halt... ist halt das Dove, dann kauf ich eben dann das andere irgendwie nicht, weil mir das dann irgendwie zu doof ist.
Ist doch egal, Stelle vor, das gibt's einfach gar nicht fürs iPhone. Nee, ich meinte nicht Galcon Fusion, aber Galcon Fusion ist natürlich auch ein ganz großartiges Spiel.
Galcon ist auch ganz großartig. Da kommt dann wahrscheinlich meine Affinität mit den Teilen her.
Auch schon uralt, dieses Ballerteil da mit den Planeten und so. Galcon ist ganz toll.
Das hab ich ja glaube ich schon vor Ewigkeiten auch mal empfohlen.
Aber im US Store, warte mal, da ist hier TomTom auf Platz 3 und ansonsten seh ich da nichts, was irgendwie an Navigation erinnert.
Na ja gut, aber es ist auch nicht so, dass es jetzt nicht so spezifisch deutsch ist. Du meinst, die Deutschen kaufen einfach so richtig viel Navigationssoftware. Mehrere aber gleichzeitig wahrscheinlich.
Es ist halt eine Autofahrernation.
Haben wir doch gesagt, dass da waren noch 3 oder 4 Navigationssysteme in den Top 10 alleine. Also ich mein, das ist ja schon... Macht ja schon Angst.
Das ist eine Nation von Verdichtern und Längern. Wo ist meine Haltaste?
Wo ich ja nur so mittelgut drauf abkann, sind so diese ganzen Kamera-Apps, die es plötzlich so gibt fürs iPhone.
Irgendwie wurde ich ja in den Kommentaren vom Blog hier darauf hingewiesen.
Gebashed, was für eine Null bist, Huckel. Du hast ja überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Echt gar nicht. War doch voll nett formuliert. Nee, aber tatsächlich hat mir dann jemand gesagt, wie man doch vom iPhone direkt die Filme runterkriegt. Also es war jetzt nicht sonderlich intuitiv, aber...
Nein, mit iMovie.
Mit iMovie.
Seine Behauptung war, man könne mit iMovie nicht direkt die Filme vom iPhone holen. Und die Wahrheit ist, doch, es geht, aber wie?
Ja, man muss halt im Menü auf Import gehen und kann dann das iPhone auswählen. Ist jetzt auch nicht so unlogisch, aber irgendwie geht halt dieses iMovie auf und macht halt links unten gleich so ein Panel auf mit, hier holt ihr deine Clips irgendwie vom File-System und keine Ahnung was, und aus deiner iPhoto-Library. Aber das iPhone wird halt nicht angezeigt. Das würde ich mir auch erwarten. Dachte ich halt so, okay, hier ist irgendwie mein Media-Browser und jetzt hol ich mir mal da Media-Clips irgendwie in mein Projekt rein, aber muss man erst über Import gehen. Aber war auf jeden Fall ein cooler Tipp, hat meinen Workflow direkt vereinfacht und dann gab's noch ein cooles Kommentar, oder ich weiß gar nicht, gab's das in den Kommentaren? Da haben wir ja letztes Mal gesagt, dass ich eine Canon 40D Spiegelreflex-Kamera hab. Und da gab's auch irgendwie einen Hinweis, ich weiß eben nicht, ob's auf den Kommentaren waren, dass man eben auch mit den Kameras, die nicht Video aufzeichnen können, herstellerseitig, dass es da ein Tool gibt, mit dem man das dann doch kann. Und zwar bei allen Kameras, die dieses Live-View-Feature haben. Und das Live-View-Feature ist, dass die Kamera den Spiegel runterklappt und dann das Live-Bild sozusagen direkt über USB streamt. Weil es gibt halt ja auch Canon-Software, mit der du die Kamera fernsteuern kannst. Und dann hast du eben auch diesen Live-Preview auf dem Rechner und kannst scharf stellen auch darüber. Ach so. Und den greifen sie einfach direkt ab und speichern das in einen Videofile. Und das Video ist dann zwar nicht HD, wie bei den modernen Spiegelreflexkameras, aber es ist moment... Immerhin... Sagt mir die Dimensions lieber Feinde. Sagt da nämlich der Feinde auch. Warte, ich guck noch mal. Aber es war schon mal auf jeden Fall größer als DV...
27p?
Ich gucke, warte, Moment.
Und ist das... Was braucht man dafür, ist das dann in QuickTime eine verfügbare Videosource?
Du brauchst so ein extra Tool und das Tool ist echt nicht schön.
So was, also nicht so ein Treiber, der das mal so macht, sondern...
Das ist ein extra Tool und das benutzt halt das... Also es gibt... Was heißt es? EOS Movie Rack. Und die Filmgröße, die daraus fällt, ist 1024x680, also auch 27p knapp verfehlt. Aber es ist halt immer noch größer als TV. Und größer als PAL und so. Also das Video ist schon echt okay von der Qualität, muss ich echt sagen. Auf jeden Fall besser als das iPhone. Und ich hab halt meine Canon-Objektive dafür. Ja, das gibt's auf SourceForge, dem Friedhof der Open Source-Projekte. Und es gibt irgendwie auch noch einen Weg, das mit G-Photo 2 irgendwie so. Aber es geht. Also ich konnte mir dann Binary runterladen, konnte das starten, meine Kamera ranstecken. Und das ging instantan. Und ich konnte aufnehmen. Die Sache ist, die aktuelle Version ist bei denen irgendwas eins, drei irgendwie. Und die Mac-Version, die es da gibt, die ist noch eins, neun irgendwas. Also noch relativ hinterher. Und ich hab versucht, das von Hand zu bauen. Ich hab mir auch das Canon SDK, was man zum Compilen braucht, an Start gebracht. Aber gebaut bekommen hab ich es eigentlich nicht. Ein voller Aus...
Er ist irgendwie anders gesucht. Nicht so viel Erfolg gehabt gerade.
Nee, aber geht, ist cool. Und damit werd ich jetzt meine nächsten Cube-Videos dann auch aufnehmen. Das noch mal zum Feedback-Update und Erfahrungsberichten.
Du hast ja auch noch dieses andere Tool von deinem Hardware-Bastelein erwähnt, diesen Logic Analyzer.
Ich bin ja irgendwie jetzt, wo der Winter anfängt, ich hab ja voll im Bastel-Modus und da gibt's halt, also es gibt halt ja Oszilloskope in digital und allen möglichen anderen Trödel und das Problem ist halt auf Mac hat man da immer wenig Freude mit, weil diese ganzen Elektronik-Bastler halt Mac nicht so als Zielplattform entdeckt haben. Und was es halt auch gibt und was eigentlich immer ziemlich hilfreich ist, sind so Logic Analyzer. Und die gibt es auch für USB. Und da gibt es schon einen, nämlich USB, also USB-EE. Irgendwie Logic Analyzer, wenn man da noch sucht.
Was macht ein Logic Analyzer genau?
Na, der, du hast so in der Regel 8 oder 16 so eine kleinen Kontaktklemmen, in Anführungsstrichen, ja, und die klemmst du auf deine Leiterbahnen oder an deine IO-Pins von den Chips. Und der registriert oder misst halt einfach nur, ob Strom an Strom aus ist, also 1,0 Nullen. Also im Gegensatz zum Oszilloskop, wo du halt auch wirklich den Stromanstieg als Kurve siehst und das Rauschen und so weiter, konzentriert der sich halt darauf, wirklich nur 1,0 Nullen zu registrieren. Und dann kannst du halt auf so einem Zeitstrahl diese 1,0 Nullen sehen und dann eben gucken, wo deine Logikfehler sind. Also wenn du zum Beispiel so ein serielles Protokoll sprechen willst, in so voll analog, ja, dann musst du halt hier eine Clock an und aus die ganze Zeit machen und dann zum richtigen Zeitpunkt eine 1 schicken und zum richtigen Zeitpunkt eine 0. Und wenn du das Ding halt so vor dir hast und die Schaltung und das funktioniert nicht, dann weißt du halt nicht wieso. Und mit dem Logic Analyzer kannst du dich auf die entsprechenden Output-Pins hängen und dann in so einem Zeitstrahl dir eben genau auf den entsprechenden Outputs anzeigen lassen. Zu welchem Zeitpunkt ist denn der jetzt an und der andere aus und so weiter und so fort.
Und weil er halt einen Logic Analyzer ist, kann er verschiedene Protokolle auch und kann schon selber mitlesen, was du über deinen seriellen Bus da geschickt hast. Also zum Beispiel SBE heißt das Zeug, Serial Programming Interface und der Logic Analyzer kennt das und der liest einfach die ganze Zeit mit, der merkt sich ja auch die Werte und dann kann er sagen, du hast gerade eine 3 durchgeschickt oder du hast jetzt gerade hier folgenden Text durchgeschickt und wenn du halt ganz viele Pins hast und so weiter, der Logic Analyzer, der hilft einem da. Da kommst du halt mit mausolos vorweg.
Ich glaube, das ist auch gleich die High Level. Das heißt, du kannst ja auf den USB-Port klemmen und dann sagt dir der was für USB-Pakete.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das mit den teuren Logic Analyzern geht. Naja, um das jetzt nochmal wieder rüber zu holen an das Thema, so ein Oszilloskop, da gibt es das auch auf den digitalen, aber Oszilloskope sind halt ziemlich teuer, geht ab 500 Euro los und eigentlich will man eins für so 1000 noch was. Und Logic Analyzer sind halt an sich auch relativ teuer. Die USB-Logic Analyzer gab es bisher oder in den letzten Jahren eigentlich auch immer nur für PC. Und jetzt gibt es halt seit einem Jahr circa einen USB-Logic Analyzer für einen Mac, der kostet halt 49 Euro. Und der ist halt echt cool. Also der ist so für Mikrocontroller basteln.
Das ist dieses Teil von Zaleel.
Ich poste das auch gleich nochmal in Chat.
Und wer es hier nicht live hört, diese Links sind auf mobilemacs.de. Heiß und feucht.
Ja, das ist ja... Das waren doch Hotlinks.
Genau.
Es nähert sich ja auch der Weihnachtszeit. Also wenn man jetzt so einen Mac-User kennt, der irgendwie Elektronik bastelt und so. Und 150 Euro sind ja nur so im Rahmen. Also für die Eltern vielleicht. Dem kleinen Sohn, wenn man so einen kleinen USB-Logic Analyzer. Und das Coole ist eben, die Software läuft auf Mac, Linux und Windows. Also dann ist da echt flexibel und das gibt es halt sonst nicht. Und das Interface ist auch einigermaßen...
Aber du kaufst da mit einer Lizenz wahrscheinlich auch nur eine Plattform, ne?
Ne, das ist glaube ich egal. Und was halt auch cool ist, sie tun halt auch ein SDK raus, was du halt bei den anderen auch nicht tun kannst, dass du dann halt die Daten selber analysieren kannst. Also du kommst an alles ran. Und du kannst halt auch bidirektional dann mit dem Ding kommunizieren und zum Beispiel wohl auch angebliche Signale zurückschicken. Aber da hab ich jetzt noch nichts rausgefunden, weil das ist glaube ich erst angekündigt, das SDK. Aber die kümmern sich halt so, dass die Leute da auch dann mit diesem Tool rumbasteln können. Und für uns Mac-User ganz besonders schön natürlich, es ist gefertigt aus einem Unibuddy-Aluminiumgehäuse, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab.
Ah, na warum hast du denn das nicht gleich gesagt?
Bestrichst sofort.
Ist mir doch egal, was das macht.
Ja genau, das hat bestimmt auch so den Formfaktor, dass es auf irgendein Apple-Gerät genau perfekt drauf ist, wie groß war die Apple TV?
Ja, naja, dann macht das ja auch was her.
Da kann man die auch stapeln.
Weil es mal jemand von der Verwaltung kommt.
Es kommt echt hübsch daher, kompakt in so einem kleinen Täschchen, dann hast du diesen kleinen Unibuddy-Plömpel, den du mit USB ransteckst und dann deine kleinen Kontakte da und so. Das sieht eigentlich alles ganz gut aus. Und funktioniert auch ganz gut. Genau, also jetzt für Mikro, Controller, Basteln ist das schon mal der Drescht.
Fein, fein!
Ja, und dann gibt es ja, hab ich letztens erwähnt, dass ich mir ein FPGA-Board bestellt hab und irgendwie das Cube-Interesse ist ja auch echt ganz groß. Und kann jetzt nur als Update sagen, das FPGA-Board ist angekommen, aber ich hab's noch nicht von der Post abgeholt. Gibt's jetzt also noch keine Neuigkeiten, aber kommt noch alles.
Es bleibt spannend.
Genau. Äh, genau.
Dein Ansatz? Hardware.
Verstehe, hab ich mir gerade bei Amazon geschoppt.
Hoffentlich über unsere Affiliate-Links.
Und zwar unser beliebtes Thema, weil da kann man sich ja stundenlang mit beschäftigen, sobald man sich beim Laden zuguckt, Akkus. Und zwar haben wir gelabert hier, wir haben diese Eneloop-Dinger. Tim hat ja auch immer noch seinen Sanyo-Lader. Die haben, ich mach das jetzt mal sehr schnell, die haben ja 2000 mAh, haben langsam Entladungszeit, deswegen eignen die sich für Geräte, die irgendwie länger in meiner Schublade rumliegen oder irgendwie so anderen Kram. Und da gibt's jetzt neue, die heißen XX, also auch Innaloop und die haben 2500, das heißt, die haben 25 Prozent mehr Power, was schon nicht so wenig mehr ist. Die kommen also schon langsam in diese normalen Akkus, die eine schnelle Entladung haben. Und die gibt's jetzt, weil die gibt's erst ab September und bei Amazon kamen die Klicken, ich hab grad welche geholt, kosten auch vier Stück 13 Euro gerade oder so.
Was hast du jetzt schon an Geld in Batterien investiert, die letzten sechs Monate?
In Batterien gar nichts, weil ich hab Akkus. Ne, ich hab die Akkus hab ich glaub ich Anfang, ob ich das dieses Jahr gekauft oder Anfang letzten Jahres, weiß ich gar nicht mehr genau. Aber ich hab mein Leben lang so wenig in Batterien und Akkus gesteckt, weil es halt Akkus sind. Also die kaufst halt einmal, die halten halt ein paar Jahre. Also ich hab da echt wirklich, glaub keine 50 Euro in meinem ganzen Leben für Batterien ausgegeben.
Und ist es ökologisch wertvoll?
Nachhaltig, nachhaltig.
Nachhaltig, das ist da schon wertvoll.
Man muss den Nippel auch durch die Nachhaltigkeit ziehen.
Ja, find ich gut. Dass die sich so verbessern, ist cool. Außerdem sind sie schwarz.
Wir sind schwarz, ja. Und wenn man danach sucht, das ist auch voll geil, weil die heißen XX.
Ist das so geil?
Was siehst du denn, wenn du nach XX suchst, dann siehst du, wie geil das ist. Weil man nach XX sucht, das ist halt Porno.
Ach so, nur nach XX, dann.
Ist denen ja auch egal.
Wenn sie sich gleich um das Handy nennen können, dann wären sie bei den ganzen Companies nicht mehr super gewesen.
Okay, lande ich hier bei Meister.
Das ist bestimmt auch super ideale Vibrator-Batterie oder so.
Okay, bei Google-Apps 3 und XX ist nicht Porn. Ich tippe mal noch eins dazu, mal gucken.
Also das Einzige, was ich hier finde, was halbwegs an Porn erinnert, ist Deckhengst-Battle um Vollblutzucht. Aber das ist wirklich ein Rennpferd.
Auf Amazon?
Nicht auf Amazon, auf Google!
Ein Deckpferd-Kauf auf Amazon.
Ich hab mir noch nicht auf einmal so ein Deckhengst geschafft.
Dieses Google, das ist alles ganz schöner Schweinkram.
Ist leider beim DHL verstorben.
Da wo wir gerade bei Hardware sind, ich glaub wir hatten es letztes Mal schon angesprochen, ich bin mir grad nicht ganz so sicher, aber ich hab mir mal so testweise diesen Taschen-Biemer geschoppt.
Ich hab dir ja schick.
Beamste damit in deine Tasche hinein.
Ich bin nur damit, damit mach ich Taschenbiljard-Beleuchtung. Das ist der Samsung SP-H03. Und dabei handelt es sich um einen LED-Biemer mit RGB-LEDs. Das heißt, und DLP-Technologie ist also komplett...
Hat da irgendeinen Namen genannt, der keine Abkürzung war?
Naja, so ist das halt heutzutage.
Wie, ist das RGB-LED unten, DLP-Fahrrad noch davor?
Kein Fahrrad. Ist ja RGB.
Aber ein DLP ist ja mit Fahrrad eigentlich, oder?
Nein, nein, nein. Nein, DLP ist erstmal mit DLP. DLP sagt ja nur, dass du einen Spiegelchip hast. Und dass du dann damit, wenn du sozusagen nur eine weiße LED nimmst und ein Ding, hast, dann hast du einen monochromen Bildschirm. Weil du ja der Spiegel... Also der Spiegel ist ja sozusagen nur Lichtpixel an, Lichtpixel aus. Lichtpixel geht da, wo es hin soll oder geht ins Off. Und wenn du halt eine weiße LED hast, das war die erste Methode, die diese LED-Beamer gemacht haben, da hast du so ein Fahrrad gehabt, was vor dieser... Also da ging es gar nicht um LED, sondern da hast du ja erstmal eine normale Projektor-Lampe gehabt. Das war sozusagen die erste Generation. DLP's kamen, normale Projektor, Halogenbirne, macht weißes Licht. Und dann hast du so ein Farbrad, was halt so verschiedene Farben hat. Am Anfang waren es glaube ich nur RGB und das irgendwie so mehrmals im Wechsel pro Rotation. Und dann haben sie später aber auch mehrere, also mehr Farben noch gemacht, noch einen anderen Mix gemacht. Aber das ist halt dann diesen... Erstmal wieder ein bewegendes Teil, da muss ich halt dieses Farbrad drehen. Und dann hast du so diesen Effekt gehabt, wenn du so horizontale Bewegungen gehabt hast in deinem Film, dann kann das halt so Farbfeldern führen. Oder wenn du so die Hand vor deinen Augen hin und her machst...
Wie man das so macht beim Kino.
Dann merkt man halt das Effekt sofort. Aber bei horizontaler Bewegung hast du halt diese Farbverzeihung. Also es ist vor allem nicht optimal und man will ja auch keine beweglichen Teile haben. So, dann kamen die LEDs auf und wurden immer lichtstarker. Und das hat dann auch die Möglichkeit eröffnet, direkt mit RGB zu arbeiten. Also jetzt auch blaue LEDs oder weiße LED wahrscheinlich mit einem Farbfilter davor. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie es funktioniert. Auf jeden Fall benutzt du dann eben drei Spiegel und misch das dann eben danach zusammen. Also hier sind wahrscheinlich, ich hab wirklich echt drei DLP's drin, die echt zu billig geworden. Na wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, das Teil ist scheiße klein. Wie groß ist das hier eigentlich?
Also nicht viel größer als eine Kippenschachtel.
Ja, ein bisschen breiter. Dafür aber auch nicht so hoch. Also rummäßig Kippenschachtel, oder?
Also das hat hier einen Standfuß von sieben mal sieben Zentimeter und es ist zweieinhalb hoch. Also wirklich klein. Dazu kommt nochmal der Akku mit nochmal ein Zentimeter. Also dreieinhalb hoch, weil man den Akku drunter hat und das will man eigentlich. Das heißt, das Ding läuft komplett auf Akku, macht, muss man sagen, nur 30 Lumen. Und das ist also für jegliche beleuchteten Raum, kann man sagen, ist es eigentlich grundsätzlich ungeeignet. Also wenn der sperr dich beleuchtet ist vielleicht. Und wenn du da, wo du hin leuchtest, mit deinem Beamer nicht auch noch eine Lampe ist, dann mag das gehen. Aber besser ist dunkel. Aber wenn du jetzt wirklich sagst, ich will mir einen Film angucken in einem dunklen Zimmer, völlig ausreichend. Also was weiß ich, so Schlafzimmer, Kino, ja, total ausreichend. Auch wenn das Ding nicht volle Auflösungen hat, der macht nur so 800 x 480. Und du kannst damit VGA da reingehen. Du hast da eine kleine Mini SD Slot. Du kannst über USB eine Platte anschließen, USB-Stick anschließen zum Beispiel. Wobei du dann auch das Netzteil angeschlossen haben musst. Also wenn da so ein USB-Stick ist, der zu viel Power zieht, dann sagt er irgendwie, ja, ich könnte dir zu viel Power liefern auf dem USB-Port, da reicht jetzt mein Akku nicht, um den Beamer zu betreiben und auch noch diesen USB-Stick zu powern. Da musst du dann eben auch externes Netzteil anschließen. Aber ich war erstaunt, was das Teil, wie weit das fokussieren kann. Also du kannst locker in einem dunklen Raum 5, 6 Meter Abstand von der Wand haben und immer noch ein sackscharfes Bild erzeugen. Also das war echt irre. Und das Teil kann so direkt von der SD-Karte HD abspielen. Also du kannst da wirklich 1080p Filmchen drauflegen und der spielt das ruckelfrei ohne...
Welches Format?
MP4, also so wie man es haben will.
Also Handbrake anwerfen.
Also er kann auch noch andere. Ich hab jetzt nicht alles ausprobiert. Für mich war jetzt nur MP4 entscheidend.
Hast du mal einen Stick da? Dann kopiere ich mal meinen Blade Runner. Ups, ich kopierte mal einen Film drauf.
Ich hab keinen drin. Das Teil könntest du aber über USB mounten, wenn wir hier so einen Mini-USB-Adapter-Kabel haben. Hab ich hier irgendwo. Also es hat auch noch so ein halbes Gig eingebauten RAM. Aber ich hab jetzt noch keine Micro SD geschoppt.
Ich hab jetzt eh drei Gig groß.
Dann wird es da nicht drauf passen.
Und der ist eh HD. Mein Film.
Der Film. Ja, also ich hab da 1080p Filmchen, halt nicht so einen kompletten Movie, sondern so einen Kurzfilm drauf kopiert.
4GB SD-Card gibt's, würde ich das ja gern immer ausprobieren.
Ja, ich hab keine mini SD. Schade. Hab ich mir bestellt, aber hab ich jetzt irgendwie noch nicht. Und jetzt find ich noch nicht mal so ein USB-Kabel. Na ja, wie auch immer, ist ja auch nicht so wild. Jetzt hier ein Beamer im Audio-Podcast demonstrieren, ist ein bisschen langweilig. Tatsache ist, das Teil lässt sich so, naja so, gerade so erträglich über das Menü bedienen. Was ich ein bisschen scheiße finde bei dem Teil ist, dass du, du kannst den sehr leicht einschalten, indem du einfach drauftatscht, dann geht er an. Aber du kannst ihn nicht leicht ausschalten, weil du dann eben durch dieses Menü gehen musst. So mit irgendwie Yes-No-Buttons und so ein Kack. Und er ist nicht so richtig ausschaltbar. Also er hat keinen Ausschalter. Also wenn du ihn wirklich richtig ausschalten willst, Akku abnehmen, genau, das ist die einzige Wahl. Dann ist er halt wirklich aus. Das kann man auch leicht machen, aber finde ich halt so ein bisschen...
Aber muss der so wie so große Beamer noch ein bisschen nachkühlen, dass dann irgendwie der Lüfter nachlaufen muss?
Da läuft ein Lüfter. Der ist nicht sehr laut.
Und läuft der nach, nachdem du ihn ausgeschaltet hast? Also geht der noch eine Weile?
Ich glaube nicht.
Na jetzt wurde der Akku abgenommen, hat er sicherlich nicht.
Nein. Wenn er aus ist, ist er aus.
Bei diesen normalen Beamern ist das ja immer gefährlich.
Ja, bei den normalen Beamern ist das halt dieses mega heißen Halogenlampen. Wenn du die nicht nachkühlst, dann gehen sie ja halt kaputt. Und das ist natürlich hier nicht der Fall. Also LEDs haben dieses Problem nicht. Trotzdem entwickelt das insgesamt noch so viel Wärme, dass er gekühlt werden muss. Das ist was mich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen verwundert hat.
Weil auch LEDs halt noch nicht 100% Wirkungsgrad haben. Und jedes Prozent Wirkungsgrad, was sie nicht haben, wird halt in Wärme umgewandelt.
Ich fand mir noch so einen kleinen Punkt, so viel Watte rausbrätst.
Genau, du musst aufpassen, dass du nicht schwarze Löcher machst.
Und hier hast du so einen kleinen Anschluss für den Stativ.
Also das ist schon das geile Weihnachtsgimmick. Muss man halt mal gucken, wie auch wirklich der praktische Einsatz am Ende aussieht.
Also ich find das ja, ich find ja die...
Aber warum auf dem Klo denn? Wie sagst du ja, auf dem...
Klo mit einer Apple TV und einem Mini Beamer.
Nein, nur mit dem Ding. Wobei, da müssten sie auch dieses Airplay einbauen. Dieses Airplay ist einfach cool. Wir haben was schon erzählt, dass Airplay auch mit Filmen funktioniert. Also man spielt den Film auf dem iPhone ab und streamt zum Links. Egal, das Ding müsste auch hin streambar sein.
Also was ich ja... Ich bin ja ernsthaft am Überlegen, mir so ein Ding zuzulegen und zwar einfach nur, um es senkrecht nach unten zu hängen. Irgendwie auf ein Stativ drauf, damit man...
Da schläfst du doch sofort ein, wenn du so gerade...
Wenn du einfach auf dem Rücken liegen kannst und...
Meinst du nicht, du schläfst sofort ein?
Wenn ich dann einschaffe, ist doch auch okay. Aber so dieses, um im Bett noch irgendwie einen Film oder eine Serie zu gucken, ist das schon echt großartig. Und dann mit dem VGA-Adapter irgendwie direkt das iPhone anzuschließen oder das iPad. Und dann braucht man da nicht viel. Dann ist das auch schon ganz schick. Also das ist... Und so um in einer perfekten Dunkelheit ist das ja wirklich gut genug.
Also in einer perfekten Dunkelheit, in einem dunklen Raum ist das Ding ausreichend.
Okay, perfekte Dunkelheit braucht man nicht, aber...
Also im Club hat es ja auch schon jemand vorgeführt und da war Licht und ich fand da die Helligkeit eigentlich doch schon beeindruckend für so ein kleines Ding.
Ja, aber ich hab zum Beispiel jetzt hier...
Hier ist aber auch ganz schön hell, hier sind zwei dicke Lampen an.
Ja gut, aber so hell wollen wir es dann auch haben während der Sendung, dass wir uns irgendwie sehen. Und ich wollte halt hier das als Alternative testen zu einem Bildschirm, dass man hier einen großen Screen hat, dass wir endlich mal hier so ein Ding haben, dass wir alle auf die gleiche Webseite gucken können, wo ich sonst halt einen großen Bildschirm verkaufen müsste. Es gibt größere LED-Beamer, die ich mir jetzt noch nicht so genau angeschaut habe, die deutlich mehr Loomen machen. Und das wäre eine Option. Ich hätte ihn halt gerne in leise. Sollte schon mindestens so 1024, 760, so was in der Größenordnung machen. Aber die Entscheidung ist noch nicht gefallen. Aber ich glaube, so grundsätzlich möchte ich das ganz gerne haben. Es ist erstaunlich, was diese LED-Technik jetzt an neuen, kompakten Teilen so ermöglicht. LED sind ganz toll.
Ja, 222 kostet der Gescheit.
Also mit diesem ganzen Gebimsel, was ich scheiße finde bei dem Teil, um das gleich noch dazu zu sagen, hat kein HDMI. Also du kannst mit Composite-Video reingehen und der kann sowohl USB-Host als auch USB-Client, also er kann sowohl als Festplatte agieren, damit du drauf kopierst, als auch, dass du Festplatten anschließt. Und eben VGA haben wir schon gesagt, aber er hat halt kein HDMI-Eingang. Und das wär's eigentlich, weil wenn du dir denkst, diese kleine Apple TV an so einem kleinen, kompakten LED-Biemer, und es gibt Modelle, die jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel mehr kosten, die HDMI haben und auch noch relativ kompakt sind, die beiden Teile zusammen, brauchst du nur noch Strom, hängst das irgendwo oben an die Wand, in die ideale Produktionsposition und kannst dann per WLAN, über Airplay, da einfach direkt drauf zugreifen oder eben dann von dem Teil, die die Daten von deinem iTunes irgendwie runterholen. Also jetzt in so einem Apple-Environment. Oder du kaufst ja halt eine entsprechende andere Box, die dann den OPNP-Krempel macht, falls hier jemand Windows hat. Hat hier jemand Windows? Der eine Hörer hat gerade gezuckt. Wir haben nämlich auch Windows-Leute, die zu hören.
Ich hab ja ein Windows 7 zu Hause, ich bin voll zufrieden.
Stimmt, du warst da. Achso, ja, du arbeitest ja regelmäßig damit. Ich? Und Hockel? Auch du, Brutus?
Na, ich hab so eine Virtual-Box, da hab ich von Arbeitswegen so ein Windows XP drin. Aber ich hab mir ein Bildschirme im Hintergrund von damals.
Ist okay, aber wenn er rausgeht, wascht euch nochmal die hin.
Ja, nee, das mach ich ja sowieso, wenn ich die Virtual-Box zu mache.
Nachdem ich einen Mac angefasst hab, bevor ich ein Windows anfasse, fass ich mir auch mal die Hände, hallo?
Desinfiziert. Aber ich hab, ja, das ist nämlich eine ganz große, große Heldentat noch gewesen. Da gibt's nämlich von Dilbert, auf dilbert.com gab's früher so Wallpapers. Und da war einer, wo Dilbert da steht und so, kurz der Doc Bird da steht und so sagt, out out you demons of stupidity. Und mit dem Stab wackelt. Und irgendwann wollte ich mir das in meine Virtual-Box-Windows-Installation reinklicken, weil dieses Windows ist einfach, also dieser Bildschirmhintergrund passt einfach zum Windows, wie der Arsch auf dem Eimer, wie man so schon sagt. Dann hab ich den aus dem webarchive.org noch rauspummeln müssen, weil die hatten ja dilbert.com redesigned und da galt es wieder.
Da hängt auch in unserer Mathematik immer der Aufkleber, oder? Hatte beide ausgedruckt, ist aber weg, ne?
Weiß ich nicht mehr. Aber ich hab noch die Desktop-Hintergründe.
Zielpunkt war das, glaube ich, der hat das noch.
Ja, ja, ich auch. Hab ich mir gesichert.
Fällt mir ein, hat zwar jetzt gerade überhaupt nichts mit dem Thema zu tun, aber das war ja auch gerade nicht. Das war so ein richtig schöner Facepom. Und zwar, da ging es darum, dass irgendjemand einen Artikel geschrieben hatte, dass er es ja gut findet, dass Google bei Chrome jetzt mal so ein paar Features auf so echt überflüssige Sachen scheißt und so etwas nicht einbaut wie Firefox, die ja wirklich jeden Dreck einbauen, der nicht bei drei auf den Bäumen ist. Und da hat er als Beispiel gewählt, die Funktion, dass man, wenn man mit der rechten Maustaste oder mit, wie nennt es, Kontextklick, wie nennt es das immer, wenn man auf ein Bild klickt, dass man dann den Befehl hat, als Bildschirmhintergrund festzulegen. Was wirklich noch nie ein Mensch auf diesem Planeten gebraucht hat. Und Chrome hat das nicht. Und dann hat man jemanden den entsprechenden Bug-Report rausgesucht bei Chrome, der besagt, hey, baut auf der Stelle dieses Wallpaper-Feature ein. Das ist das Einzige, was ich in meinem Browser nutze. Und da gibt es ungefähr 500 Leute, die Kommentare dazu geschrieben haben, dass sie dieses Feature auch ganz dringend haben wollen und dass das auf jeden Fall rein muss. Und dass ich sofort Chrome einsetzen würde, wenn es dieses Feature hätte. Und das fährt mir gerade ein wegen Bildschirmhintergrund.
Ich wechsle mein Bildschirmhintergrund ja immer nur pro OS-Update. Weil dann liefert Apple neu und dann suche ich mir wieder einen aus.
Apropos.
Du benutzt nicht die offiziell sanktionierten...
Ich benutze ja andere, aber ich hab jetzt einen seit mehreren OS-Linieces. Aber, du hast es vorhin angesprochen, ich hab mich ja voll gefreut. Ich hab mir halt seitdem ich Mac OS X benutze, mein Terminal nicht umkonfiguriert und hab immer das gleiche Colorscheme. Jetzt hab ich es geändert mal auf so ein dunkleres. Und habe voller Schrecken festgestellt, dass man diese Ansie, Escape, Sequence, Colors nicht so leicht editieren kann. Und du hast auch das Problem, oder wie?
Ich hab von Problem gar nichts gesagt. Ich wollte das Thema eigentlich aus einem anderen Grund aufgreifen, weil man kann einfach den Typ Computer-Benutzer daran erkennen, welche Terminal-Farben man verwenden kann. Na wie sieht es bei euch Terminal aus, wenn du Terminal startest? Welche Farben hast du denn?
Also ich hatte jahrelang...
Weiß, weiß, weiß, weiß auf schwarz?
Aber nicht das knallige Weiß, sondern so ein bisschen natürlich abgedämpftes Weiß. Ganz bisschen. Weil ganz knallig geht halt nicht.
Dunkelweiß.
Kein Grau. Kein Grau.
Gips.
Aber ich glaube es ist kein richtig komplettes Weiß. Bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher. Und der Text ist halt schwarz oder halt auch wieder so fast so ein schwarz.
Also wie man es halt auch in...
Hellschwarz.
Nein, aber so wie man es halt im klassischen Print halt macht, da drückt man ja auch kein volles Weiß und kein volles Schwarz.
Genau, weil es blendet halt.
Ja.
Der Kontrast darf halt auch nicht zu stark sein. So und diese ganzen Typis, die noch von früher irgendwie von ihren DOS-Schirmen, ja oder Unix halt, irgendwie schwarzer Schirm, weißer Text und sich dann dieses Vollknallen lassen. Ich krieg schon bei HTML-Seiten eine Krise, die schwarz sind mit weißem Text. Da lese ich eine Weile und dann habe ich Zeilen im Gesicht, weil irgendwie das nachblendet wie ich auch.
Aber ich hab hier mir geguckt, meinst ja auch nicht schwarz und knallweiß, sondern so ein...
Ja, aber schon wieder anders als alle anderen Seiten. Wieso denn?
Was hast du denn?
Weiß auf schwarz oder schwarz auf weiß? Ich hatte auch weißer Hintergrund, schwarze Schrift, leicht getweekt und immer einen roten Cursor.
Roter Cursor?
Roter Cursor. Das hatte ich mir immer beim Earn abgeguckt und das fand ich immer total schick.
Extravagant.
Ja, roter Cursor fand ich gut, Block-Cursor natürlich.
Aber hoffentlich kein F-00-Rot, oder?
Stimmt, Block-Cursor ist auch noch so eine Frage. Hast du Block-Cursor, Dennis?
Und jetzt hab ich's mir halt, weil ich meinen... Ich war ja früher auch Text-Mate-Benutzer, ne? Also so ein Text-Editor. Das ist ja gleich die nächste Frage, eigentlich der Text-Editor, ne?
Du warst früher Text-Mate-Benutzer.
Jetzt benutze ich gerade tatsächlich Mac-Wim, ja? Wim mit... Ja, ich weiß, jetzt Max als... Mac-Wim?... BB-Edited-User wird jetzt wahrscheinlich gleich ins Essen fallen. Nee, aber da hab ich mir sowieso schon ein dunkleres Colorschema gemacht, weil es irgendwie einfach angenehmer war zum Arbeiten. Also halt alles so... Wie sagt man denn zu diesen... Passt nicht, ey. Ja, also halt so nicht so harte Kontraste. Und jetzt hab ich mir meinen Terminal auch so umgestellt, weil das Problem ist, wenn man einen dunklen Editor hat und dann dauern zwischen allen möglichen Terminats hin und her schaltet die Weiße, dann macht das bei Nacht-Hacking-Sessions die Augen müde. Deswegen hab ich mir jetzt erst mal so ein dunkles Theme noch angelegt. Ich bin noch nicht ganz sicher, welches jetzt mein Default-Theme wird, ob das Weiß immer noch Default ist und dann nachts das Dunkle, aber...
Gute Güte, da hab ich ja richtig ein religiöses Netz reingetreten.
Aber das Problem ist, bei dem dunklen Theme, und das hab ich da halt vorher auch schon mal gelesen ist, wenn du halt dich auf einer Linux-Kiste oder sowas einloggst, wo halt immer Terminal-Colors an sind für LS und so. Das machen ja auch manche Mac-User an. Horrible. dann gibt's halt einen Typ Entry, der dunkelblau ist. Und dieses dunkelblau, das kannst du einfach nicht lesen, mit einem dunklen Hintergrund im Terminal. Und da man bei Terminal-App das nicht umkonfigurieren kann, musst du halt dir so ein symbolgetriebenes Zusatzplugin für Terminal-App installieren, um in der Lage zu sein, deine ANSI Terminal-Colors umzudefinieren. Und da dachte ich mir ja schon, Jesus fucking Christ.
Was hast du denn für Farben, Max?
Was ich für Farben habe, aber ich würde gleich noch mal danach über was. Also ich hab ganz klassisch Schwarz, Text, Weiß, Hintergrund.
Ganz klassisch ist ja eigentlich...
Na ja, Schwarz auf Weiß. Ich hab Schwarz auf Weiß. Was ich ja viel spannender finde, ist die Schrift, die man dazu verwendet. Ja, weil das ist... also ich bin ja... Ich wechsle immer zwischen Deja Vu Sans Mono, das ist eine Schrift, die auf jeden Fall bei Ubuntu dabei ist, so eine Open Source Schrift, oder Bitstream Vera Sans Mono. Das sind so die beiden.
Aber wieso nicht die Menlo? Die ist doch die schönste von allen jetzt.
Weil ich die tatsächlich nach wie vor nicht so schick finde, wie so eine Deja Vu Sans Mono.
Aber die ist doch von der abgeleitet. Du nennst Menlo, ja? Ja, also ich als typografieaffiner Mensch, ich hab mich ja jahrelang eigentlich schon immer an dieser Monaco auch gestört, die ja der Default von vorher war. Und ich hab auch schon andere Schriften, wie eben diese Deja Vu Sans und die Bitstreamer ausprobiert in der Zwischenzeit. Und dann hat ja irgendwann Apple gesagt, bei Snow Leopard war es ja glaube ich, dass sie jetzt eine neue Terminal Default Schrift machen. Eben die Menlo. Und die ist jetzt von einer, ich glaube von der Deja Vu ist sie abgeleitet. Und sie haben da so ein paar Refinements dran gemacht, die ich allesamt auch ziemlich sinnvoll finde. Und das ist jetzt meine neue Terminal Schrift, weil der Vorteil ist bei der, im Gegensatz zu Monaco, ist die Anti-Aliast auch im Terminal zu vertragen, weil die Monaco in kleinen Font-Sizes, wenn man da Anti-Aliasing anmacht. Jetzt gerade habe ich tatsächlich 13 Punkt, weil irgendwie finde ich gerade große Terminal Schrift auch geil. Aber früher hatte ich 11, glaube ich, oder 10. Und die Monaco, wenn du sie mit Anti-Aliasing anmachst, dann ist sie so weggeschwommen und war echt schlecht zu lesen. Und die ist mit Anti-Alias total schick. Die ist so richtig... Also mir geht ein Herz auf, wenn ich die angucke. Die schönste Mono-Space-Font, die ich bisher so hatte.
Interessant. Also ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass wir hier so eine Tiefe rauskriegen. Ich sag mal kurz mein Setup.
Du hast grün auf schwarz.
Monaco, 14 Punkte. Anti-Aliast.
Auf 14 Punkte geht's dann wahrscheinlich schon wieder.
Grün auf schwarz. Ich liebe Monaco, ich find's großartig. Aber ein Terminal ist für mich einfach grün auf schwarz und das Einzige, was noch gehen würde, wäre Bernstein.
Also mein erster Computer-Monitor hatte Bernstein.
Aber grün auf schwarz.
Das war immer, wenn mein Kamerateam vorbeikommt, damit er so richtig hackermäßig aussieht.
Aber bei ihm ist es ja wenigstens aus Alter-Tradition.
Seitdem Matrix das verwurstet hat, ist es durch.
Naja, es ändert ja nichts daran, dass das richtig ist. Also ich meine, das ist halt einfach mal ein Computer-Terminal. Hat einfach mal grün auf schwarz. Ich hab's auch mal mit dieser Menlo probiert und die waren mir alle zu typografisch. Ich mag diese geilen Schrägen bei Monaco.
Aber die Monaco ist echt keine schicke Schrift.
Das M kann man doch gar nicht mehr lesen.
Und vor allem die Sache ist, bei der Menlo kannst du eben wirklich genau so eins, kleines L und großes I extrem gut unterscheiden. Bei der Monaco war ich da in diesem...
Ich mach mir mal ein neues Setting, das nenne ich jetzt Huckel. Menlo Regular 13, sagst du?
Ich fahr die da auf 13, genau.
Hinter Anti-Alias ist sozusagen bei Default On Text ist schwarz, aber nicht ganz so schwarz, sagst du?
Genau, immer so ein paar Prozent eins ranziehen.
Wie viel denn so?
Naja, wie gesagt, so gefüllte 3 bis 5 vielleicht.
3 bis 5, dann mach ich mal 5%.
So wie es dir halt angenehm ist.
Und Bold Text, Bold Text habe ich ja so ein helles Grün und auch mein Cursor, der muss auch so richtig grelles Grün sein, der ist ja nochmal heller.
Also bei meinem dunklen Theme ist der Cursor auch ein grelles Gelb, bei meinem hellen Theme ist der Cursor halt ein Rot, relativ Vollrot. Und Bold ist bei mir halt ein weißeres Weiß, also da ist es Vollweiß-Bold. Damit es halt so richtig bold knallt.
Ich denk Schwarz auf Weiß.
Also für welches Theme sind wir denn jetzt?
Ich wollt jetzt erstmal dein Default, das du normalerweise benutzt.
Kann man ja auch keine Themes exportieren und ihm rüber schicken und Zeug?
Ja, also da hab ich halt jeweils glaube ich die gleiche Farbe für Bold Text, oder? Ich guck mal.
Ich weiß nicht, kann man Themes exportieren?
Na dann?
Wollen wir mal unsere Lieblings...
Ja, lass uns mal Themes tauschen. Wir stellen die dann alle auf die Webseite auch noch.
Ja genau, dann können auch Leute ihre Settings...
Kann ich zwischendurch mal?
Zeig mir deine Terminal Settings.
Machen wir eine kleine Web-App für. Und, aber jetzt...
In-App-Purchaser.
Flatter-Buttons, der ganze Kram. Aber jetzt nur noch als Erwähnung, weil das als Link dann auch praktisch ist. Wenn man halt ein dunkles Theme hat, dann hat man eben dieses Problem mit diesen Ansie-Colors. Und da gibt es eben ein Tool, ein Plug-In, was Symbol benutzt. Und da kann man dann in Terminal App über Preferences diese Colors umdefinieren, was sonst halt nicht geht. Und das heißt irgendwie, ich muss noch mal kurz googeln, Terminal.app Ansie-Colors. Und das Tool heißt Terminal Colorpad. Wenn ich das hier richtig interpretiere. Was ist das, wie, wo, was? Na, das ist ein Plug-In um, ich schick dir das mal hier kurz rüber. Oder mein...
Oh Gott, wie soll das? Ich glaube, das soll so Leopard und Color...
Ach du Scheiße, was hat der denn geraucht? Ja, da hast du halt ein zusätzliches Preference-Paint auf jeden Fall, mit dem du diese Ansi-Colors umdefinieren kannst. Wie gesagt, das Dunkelblau ist halt das Schlimmste, das kann man auf einem dunklen Hintergrund kaum lesen. Das müsstest du ja eigentlich auch haben, das Problem, wenn du ein schwarzes Terminal mit grüner Schrift hast.
Ich glaub, der hat einfach Ansi-Farben abgeschaltet, oder?
Na, wenn du auf dich zum Beispiel in eine Linux-Kiste einloggst und eine LLS macht und dann diese dunkelblaue Schrift kommt, die zu lesen, oder machst du die Ansi-Colors einfach komplett aus?
Ich glaub mich nicht auf die Linux-Kisten ein.
Achso, ja, das ist natürlich auch ein valider Punkt, ja. Also das kann man ja auch ausschalten, dieses Coloring von LLS.
Doch, manchmal tue ich das, aber mir ist nicht bewusst, dass irgendwo so Farbe...
Also Colored Bash Prompt hast du denn irgendwo?
Das ist eigentlich so Standard-Farbe, oder?
Das ist so ein bisschen, dass das schon nicht mehr so meine Zeit, ne?
Ja, ich mach das auch nicht. Ich mag auch keine Colored Bash Prompt.
Ja, da bin ich Rock'n'Roll. Wobei ich das durchaus verstehen kann, wenn man jetzt Farbe benutzt, weil... Da kann man dann...
Das lenkt nur ab.
Die sind auch so hässlich, die Farben.
Ja, ich mach das auch lieber so mit Content. Ich hab eher so LS-Optionen gesetzt, die vielleicht den Slash irgendwie hinter den Direktories packen und so, da weiß ich auch Bescheid.
Was ich neulich gefunden habe, ist ein...
Ich hab ja mein Terminal noch mit 300 Bit pro Sekunde benutzt. Und deswegen mag ich auch diesen VI so. Weil der VI ist der einzige Editor, den man benutzen kann.
Auf der arschlampsten Leitung.
Wo man sozusagen dem Programm immer schon 20 Sekunden voraus ist. Also in dem Moment, wo das letzte Bildschirm-Update gelaufen ist, ist mein letzter Editier-Command schon 20 Sekunden her gewesen. Weil ich das einfach alles blind reingetippt hatte. Ich wusste, wie ich da hinkomme. Das ist das Schöne an diesem VI. Und bis der Bildschirm dann irgendwie mal geschafft hat, den ganzen Update hinterherzuschieben, war ich schon längst mit dem Typen fertig.
Also ich bin ja jetzt auch, wie gesagt, von Texten-Mate auf Macgevim umgestiegen. Ja, das ist jetzt nicht so was wie Gevim.
Ich will das nicht vorwerfen. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es sowas gibt.
Den gibt es schon relativ lange und ist auch sehr beliebt. Und hat viele Leute dazu gebracht, doch mal wieder Vim zu benutzen. Weil der hat halt so ein paar Preferences. Und irgendwie ist es halt so mit Native Mac GUI rings rum, auch wenn man die GUI natürlich am allerwenigsten braucht.
Also läuft der, der läuft eben terminal oder was?
Ja, das ist halt wie Gevim so. Ist halt ein GUI-Vim mehr oder weniger. Der kann halt mehr Colors. Das heißt, du hast halt irgendwie coolere Colors-Gems und so. Und ähm, auf jeden Fall habe ich den jetzt in Benutzung. Habe eigentlich auch kaum Plugins installiert. Das Einzige, was ich halt installiert habe, ist der Nerd-Navigatel, nee, Nerdtree. Das ist halt so ein Project-Browser, sozusagen so ein File-Browser zum irgendwie Files öffnen. Das ist wahrscheinlich für die Vim-Puristen oder die VI-Puristen schon viel zu viel fürlefant. Aber ich komm damit jetzt echt ganz gut klar. Und dann hab ich mir dieses O'Reilly-Buch über Vim geschoppt, äh, ja, geschoppt oder downloadet. Ich glaub, geschoppt und gedownloadet, vielleicht, weiß ich nicht. Ähm, und da hab ich ja erst mal überhaupt Vim verstanden, das Konzept, also das, oder das VI-Konzept von der Navigation und warum diese Keys alle so komisch sind, in Anführungsstrichen. Aber das ist ja total geil. Bin ich ja voll abgeschnallt, weil ich dann erst mal gecheckt hab, dass, zum Beispiel, wenn man C, I, W tippt, ja, dass man dann Change Inside Word und so. Und man hat so dieses Basic von Movement, dann Zeichenzahl oder den Delimiter und dann halt die Operation Replay, Substitute und so weiter.
Da setzt du die Zeichen bis vor dem nächsten Komma und das hast du mit drei Buchstaben getippt.
Oder alles innerhalb der Klammern oder alles inklusive der Klammern und so. Wenn man das halt einmal geschneit hat, ist das schon echt ein cooler Editor. Und der Vorteil ist natürlich, den gibt's halt überall.
Naja, ich liebe wie AI.
Also Emacs gibt's auch überall und ich hab auch früher mal, ganz früher mal Emacs benutzt und fand Emacs auch eigentlich auch toll, aber...
Emacs US. So, nachdem wir jetzt die Hälfte unserer...
Ich muss noch bei uns empfehlen.
Hörer verloren haben. Warte, hier, lass noch mal.
Damit wir auch die andere Hälfte verlieren.
Was? Damit wir auch die andere Hälfte der Hörer verlieren. Max!
Wegen Terminal.
Mein Notebook kippelt.
Ein Programm, auf das ich mittlerweile wieder schwöre, nachdem ich es lange Zeit nicht benutzt habe, ist D-Term. Also D-Term. Und das ist... Man hat einen Shortcut auf dem Mac, mit dem kann man... Also bei mir ist es...
Das ist jetzt auch ein Terminal-Emulator?
Ja, ich probier's gerade. Nee, nee, es ist kein vollwertiger Emulator. Ich probier's gerade zu erklären. Dann, ich hab einen Shortcut, zum Beispiel, bei mir ist es Apfel Shift Return. Und egal, wo ich gerade bin, also wenn ich zum Beispiel in BB-Edit gerade ein Dokument aufhabe, dann macht er mir so einen Eingabeprompt auf. Und zwar genau in dem Ordner, in dem sich gerade die Datei befindet, mit der ich gerade... Im Finder oder was? Im Finder, in BB-Edit, im Xcode, in PHP Storm, überall. Egal, wo ich bin, also ich mach... So Eklipszeug halt. So, also was weiß ich was, jetzt mach ich hier jetzt PwD, bin ich genau da, wo sich dieses Dokument befindet, was ich gerade offen habe. Und das ist natürlich extrem praktisch, wenn man... Ja, man muss ja hin und wieder mal einfach jetzt eine Datei touchen, oder ein LS will man machen, oder man will da einen neuen Ordner anlegen, oder sowas.
Also er öffnet das Terminal an der Stelle, wo du gerade bist.
Na ja, er macht erst mal nur so ein Mini-Terminal auf, was sofort wieder zugeht. Du kannst entweder Return drücken, dann führt er den Befehl auf, oder du drückst, ich glaube, Shift-Return.
Ein Launchbar-Terminal, sozusagen.
Nee, Abfüll-Return, dann macht das im Terminal auf.
Bumzack, Return.
Bumzack, Return. Und es ist wirklich...
D-T-E-R-M.
Hast du das gekauft, oder was? Ich hab das schon gekauft, ja. Auf Max-Kosten können wir es jetzt kostenlos herunterladen. Führt euch eingeladen.
Das ist ja cool.
Das ist sehr cool.
Haben wir.
Es funktioniert am Anfang nur mittelgut.
Geil, jetzt kommen ja die richtig geilen Texte hier raus.
Es gibt eine Freeware, sondern man kann es auch kaufen, oder was?
Nee, ist jetzt Freeware.
Genau.
Drag & Drop geht übrigens auch ins Terminal.
Die Command-Line über alles, das hat was.
Guck mal, es funktioniert sogar in MacWim.
Darf ich eigentlich...
Was denn?
Ich hab ja hier noch so eine Danksagung auszurichten, zwischendurch, während wir jetzt alle D-Themen ausprobieren.
Ja.
Das war ich ja letztes Mal über Telekom gerandet. Ich bin ja immer noch nach wie vor Telekom Opfer. Aber mein Schmerz wurde ja gelindert. Da hat ja hier der... Wie heißt der denn eigentlich im Chat? Lino84 aka Arno. Hat mich ja dann angechattet und meinte... Morgen ist er entlassen? Nee, ich hab ihn gefragt. Ich kann das sagen, dass er mir da eine kundenorientierte Lösung beschafft hat. Und hat auch tatsächlich geklappt, hatte ich irgendwie innerhalb weniger Minuten Tethering an. Und bezahlt auch nichts extra. Das heißt...
Kein Telekom Opfer mehr.
Na, weniger Telekom Opfer. Also ich zahl ja nach wie vor 49 Euro im Monat oder so. Auf jeden Fall hab ich jetzt Tethering. Das heißt, wenn jetzt Alice oder sonst was wieder mal in den Arsch geht. Und das war nämlich am Samstag genau der Fall. Wache ich morgens auf, wollte mal wieder News-Brausen, Internet aus, Internet über Tethering, Bum, Zack, Return. In dem Fall fast nicht. Sondern Touch, Zack, Return. Aber ja, hat funktioniert und deswegen natürlich auch nochmal dickes Dankeschön an den Werten. Was zahlst du dafür? Arno. Naja, also wie gesagt, ich hab halt diesen Complete-M erste Generation, was auch immer wie das heißt, für 49 Euro im Monat mit 120 freien Minuten und 40 freier SMS. Und jetzt hab ich halt auch Tethering. Naja, also ich hab ja da angerufen und wollte ja wechseln in diesem Tarif, wo das Tethering drin ist, zum gleichen Preis. Meinten sie ja, ne, du hast dir gerade ein iPhone 4 subventionieren lassen, kannst du erst nächstes Jahr im Sommer.
Genau, geh weg.
Genau, und dann hat der Arno gesagt, ja gut, das geht ja gar nicht hier und hat mir irgendwie Tethering bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich dann den Vertrag offiziell wechseln lassen, wechseln kann, halt so gut geschrieben.
Einfach dazu geklickt. Günstlingswirtschaft.
Der hat sich auch schnell aus dem Chat hier verabschiedet.
Wenn wir alle ihn jetzt fragen, ich will auch.
Aber ich hab ihm das, also ich hab ihm im Chat gefragt, ob ich das so erwähnen kann. Er meinte, ja, mach mal.
Telekom ist halt doch ganz cool.
Also er meinte, das ist, genau, er meinte, das ist halt eine kundenorientierte Lösung und so, das ist ja schon...
Kann man schonmal machen.
Ich bin ja auch nicht so für Vettern, Wirtschaft und so Connections, aber letztendlich funktioniert die Welt da draußen ja so. Und jetzt haben die Mobile-Max...
Und jetzt auch hier drinnen.
Und jetzt haben die Mobile-Max-Führer an dieser Stelle auch die Gelegenheit, das nächste Mal, wenn sie Lino84 im Chat erwischen.
Dann schimpft die den Auswahl an.
Aber wahrscheinlich sind unsere Mobile-Max-Führer auch gar nicht so viele Telekom-Opfer, ne?
Mir hat da damals ja bei meinem DSL-Anschluss geholfen.
Ja, also Lino84 ist auf jeden Fall für kundenorientierte Lösungen sehr nett.
Ich bin ja bei O2O und ich zahl jetzt, jetzt hab ich meine erste Rechnung bekommen, bin jetzt auch bei 20 Euro weniger als vorher. Wurde mal Zeit, mein Vertrag war 10 Jahre alt, der war jetzt doch ein bisschen überholt.
Du meinst, es hat sich tatsächlich was getan?
Meine Theorie war ja, jetzt haben sie mich nicht mehr angerufen, um mich irgendwie mit neuen Verträgen voll zu stressen, was ein Hinweis dafür ist, dass sie nichts mehr haben, womit sie mich noch mehr abzocken können. Das heißt, ich hab sozusagen schon den schlechtesten Vertrag, den es gibt, also musste ich mal wechseln. Verstanden?
Naja, Gratulierer.
Ich zahl jetzt so 17 Euro im Monat, circa, und hab da meine 200 Megabyte, hab ich ja letztes Mal schon erzählt, und man könnte jetzt auch auf 300 wechseln und so weiter und so fort, hab ich aber mich noch nicht gekümmert, ich brauch eh selten UMTS-Daten, weil ist ja überall WLAN in der Stadt.
Ich bin ja schon froh, dass das überhaupt funktioniert hier mit O2. Ich sag ja mal O2.
Ich bin ja schon gespannt, ob dieses hier, was du vorhin gemeint hast, mit diesem Stromspann, ob das demnächst mal sowas bringt. Vielleicht bringt es ja wirklich was.
Das wird sich zeigen, ne? Das wird sich zeigen.
Wie lang geht jetzt unsere Sendung schon?
Ja, wir haben nur noch Themen, wir haben nur noch Themen, was ist denn da noch? Wir haben noch was.
Ich hab noch Themen für ein paar Stunden. Ich frage jetzt, ob wir das alles noch durchruckeln wollen.
Naja, die coolsten halt.
Die coolsten?
Du guckst ja da alleine mal aufs Dokument.
Entschuldigung, kann ich ja hier nicht sharen. Oder bist du bereit hier noch so ein Paid Evernote-Account?
Kannst du das nicht hier auf dieses Freepad von Erdgeister pasten?
Ja, so ESA-Pad oder sowas.
Ja, das wäre in der Tat...
Ja, oder so.
Oh man.
Wo wir hier gerade über Texteditoren sprechen.
Sub ESA Edit, heikt installiert, ping, bum, zack, return.
Bestimmt komm ich jetzt erstmal updaten werden.
Jetzt muss ich natürlich auf eine Art und Weise tippen, dass ihr das auch versteht, was ich hier mach.
Hey, du gibst da so Zeichen ein.
Ja, oder du sagst einfach, was du noch hast.
Ja, ich hab so einiges und überlege halt gerade, was jetzt hier so am besten. Ja, so iPad und Tablette und so. Also ich war neulich auf so einer Veranstaltung, da lief jemand mit so einem Galaxy Tab rum. Hätte ich eigentlich letztmal schon erzählen können, aber da war ich dann zu müde.
Wo muss ich denn hinconnecten überhaupt?
Ach so, ich hab, ich rede jetzt gerade.
Du bringst mich ganz raus.
Ich überlege jetzt gerade, wie das war. Ja, ich überlege jetzt gerade, wie dieses Galaxy Tab war. Das ist diese, ihr wisst schon, diese Android-Tablette. Und was fandest du davon? Was hielst du davon?
Also da fand ich es ganz furchtbar, aber ich glaube, da waren auch ein Haufen Erweiterungen eingeschaltet, die so normalerweise nicht eingeschaltet sind. Das war so ein typisches Vorführegerät, wo niemand mal ein Hardreset macht. Aber ich finde es ein bisschen teuer für das, was man kann.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was kostet es in Deutschland?
Ich glaube so 700 Euro oder sowas. Aber da hat man schon echt ein schickes iPad für.
Ja.
Also was ich halt nicht verstehe, bei all diesen ganzen anderen Tablets, die bisher auf den Markt kommen. Also alle, die ich gesehen habe, sind irgendwie 16 zu 9. Das, das, das, das, das begreife ich nicht.
Bis auf das iPad.
Bis auf das iPad, ja.
16 zu 9 ist ja auch, ist auch vorbei einfach.
Nee, eigentlich nicht, aber...
16 zu 9?
Ich rede nicht vom Laptop. Ich rede von so einem Tablet. So ein Teil, was man in der Hand so rumrotiert und wo du halt so zwischen Landscape und...
Ja, da ist halt 16 zu 9 nicht angesagt, sondern da sollte man was anderes haben.
Ja, aber alles, was auf dem Markt ist, außer dem iPad, ist in etwa so ein Breitformat Zeug. Ja, den Eindruck hab ich auch. Naja, auf jeden Fall dieses Galaxy Tab. Ich meine, das war so ein Android-Device. Also es hatte halt so diese User-Interface-Sex, die sind jetzt von Android. Manche mögen die. Ich mag sie nicht so sehr. Das hab ich ja schon ausreichend zu verstehen gegeben. Ich find das halt irgendwie ein bisschen durcheinander. Du hast halt da wieder ein Upscreen und dann hast du da noch so ein Upscreen. Und es gibt halt irgendwie alle möglichen Menüs und irgendwie alles, ich weiß nicht. Wie auch immer. Ich fand's leicht. Fühlte sich nach Plastik an. War aber jetzt nicht über Gebühr hässlich. Also es kommt jetzt auch nicht mit irgendeinem bekloppten Branding oder so. Sonst einfach nur so ein Teil. Es gab natürlich keine Ups dafür. Also es war halt sozusagen die Anwendung dafür ist halt Webbrowser und Clock und so. Also es kommt so ein bisschen hoch wie so ein X-Windows. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Also ich fand's ein bisschen ruckelig und unexciting. Ich weiß nicht, also es wäre mir einfach keine 700 Euro wert. Das ist irgendwie unspannend. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich nicht überhaupt darüber rede.
Das hat mich überhaupt gar nicht tankiert.
Also ich finde eigentlich das iPad auch schon relativ teuer. Deswegen habe ich auch noch keins. Und deswegen kann ich nicht verstehen, wie Geräte, die, wo ich schon glaube, dass die noch schlechter sind, noch mehr Geld kosten.
Tja, ist wohl gar nicht so einfach, so was so billig zu bauen.
Aber so ein Ding halt ohne Tastatur, wenn ich halt auch so Seiten klicke oder irgendwie so Surfer auf der Couch darf, ist das bestimmt total super. Nur dafür wäre es mir zu teuer. Und dann, wenn ich halt so ein Ding habe, dann würde ich ab und zu doch irgendwie auch mal wieder chatten. Und das geht dann wieder schon nicht so richtig bequem. Dann würde ich ja doch immer wieder auf meinem Rechner, auf meinen Laptop zurückgreifen. Und dann ist ja der Sinn schon wieder verloren von diesem iPad. Also ich bin halt immer noch nicht, ich bin ja sonst so auch Fanboy, aber bei dem bin ich noch nicht so richtig überzeugt. Und ich hatte auch mal schon eins probiert, so ein bisschen. Nicht so richtig lange, aber ja.
Ja, man braucht da so seine Killer-App.
Na, was ist aber die Killer-App?
Na, Games finde ich ganz compelling. Webbrausen finde ich ganz großartig auf dem iPad. Twitter finde ich ganz toll, hab ich aber auch alles schon mal erzählt. Und womit ich jetzt gerade viel rumspiele, ist TouchOSC. Das finde ich total mega extrem. Also Open Sound Control, dieser MIDI-Nachfolger. Und ich hab ja letztes oder vorletztes Mal schon von diesem Osculator berichtet, der so ein OSC-Hub ist. Und das kann man damit wunderbar perren. Und dann kannst du eben mit TouchOSC, mit dem Editor auf dem Mac, kannst du da deine Screens machen, fürs iPhone oder für ein iPad. Und mittlerweile läuft das übrigens auch unter Android. Also auch das kann man da machen. Was ich persönlich ein bisschen schade finde, nicht weil ich es jetzt Android nicht gönnen würde, dass es darunter läuft. Aber es ist halt wieder so eine Applikation auf dem Mac, wo man sich halt so denkt, so... Ja, so Cross-Plattform-Framework, keine ordentlichen Menüs, kein ordentliches Copy-and-Paste. Und irgendwie alles funktioniert irgendwie nicht so richtig. Und dann, weißt du, so komische Sachen. Du kannst nicht einfach so ein Objekt nehmen, Option gedrückt halten, drüber drängen und dann es kopiert und so. Also einfach, es fühlt sich nicht an wie so eine Macintosh-Hub. Aber man kann damit arbeiten, man kann so die Elemente da platzieren. Dann lätst du das, dann syncst du das mit dieser Applikation, diesem Touch-OSC und dann hast du da dein, auf dem Mac designtes Layout und dann hast du halt diese ganzen Standardregler. Drehregler, Knöpfe, Schalter, Schiebefäder in alle möglichen Richtungen und Breiten und Felder von Buttons. Und das kannst du dann auch die Farbe bestimmen, kannst die Labelnamen und Defaults geben, etc., pp. Und dann hast du das da drauf und dann kannst du die einfach benutzen auf diesem iPad. Dann ist dein iPad einfach ein generisches Open Sound-Control Device und kannst dann mit dem Osculator diese ganzen Events abfangen und in MIDI umsetzen oder kannst auch Keys an Programme schicken. All so ne Sachen. Also du kannst dir einfach ne generische Klaviatur machen, mit dem du irgendwas Fernbedienen kannst. Das ist echt irre. Du kannst auch die V-Modes damit fernsteuern, kannst da irgendwie die Dinger vibrieren lassen und die Lämpchen leuchten lassen, lässt sich irgendwie alles miteinander verknüpfen. Und das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine ganz tolle Geschichte mit dem iPad. Und das plan ich hier auch noch ein bisschen weiter einzusetzen. Ich plus hätte noch nicht so richtig dazu gekommen, das hier zu Ende zu führen. Aber was finde ich noch toll auf meinem iPad? So muss ich mal meinen iPad nennen.
Magst du auch so ein Ding oder nicht? Warum gibt es eigentlich nicht Find My iPad auch jetzt, Grasis?
Ja, gibt es auch.
Ich finde es ja super.
Ja, iPad kannst du damit auch finden.
Also was ich... Was für mich die beste Applikation ist tatsächlich wiederum Reader, so als schneller RSS-Reader. Read It Later, das ist so dieses Leseprogramm. Surfen mache ich darauf nicht so viel. Und dann so dieses ganze Casual Computing. Also wenn ich abends, was weiß ich was, wenn ich abends weggehe...
Aber hast du dich das Problem, dass du was machst und denkst, scheiße, jetzt würde ich ja gerne hier, und dann greifst du doch wieder zum Rechner. Das ist immer so...
Nee, ich nehme den einfach gar nicht mit. Also das ist... Also das lenkt immer sehr von der Situation ab. Also wenn ich jetzt coden will oder sowas, dann setze ich mich natürlich an meinen Rechner. Aber wenn ich abends essen gehe und dabei noch ein bisschen was lesen will oder sowas, dann nehme ich das iPad mit, dann nehme ich den Rechner gar nicht mit.
Hast du auch keine Freundin?
Doch, aber die ist ja nicht immer dabei, wenn ich was essen gehe.
Was ist in deiner Küche? Was ist in deiner Küche?
Katzenfutter.
Alles außer Tiernahrung.
Und da ist es einfach viel besser als so ein Rechner, weil so ein MacBook, das klappt es dann auf, dann musst du hier irgendwie den 3G-Stick ranstöpseln oder das iPhone mit Tethering und weißer Teufel, was um Netz zu haben. Und dann hast du einfach das iPad, das hast du da und dann kannst du online gehen und dann bist du gut.
Aber das ist ja auch alles, wissen wir dann alles schon.
Gut, stimmt.
Sony hingegen, also jetzt hätten wir ja noch so die Ransektion, ne Tim, bevor du jetzt das ganze abbaust.
Ja, Tim, wir machen mal aus deinem iPad.
Machen wir mal aus deinem iPad und dann sagen wir hier den Leuten da draußen, was Sache ist mit Sony und Gnustap und wie sie alle heißen.
Warte mal, sind wir denn durch hier mit dem iPad-Thema? Hier noch irgendwas? Irgendwas war doch hier noch.
Weiß ich jetzt hier, fang einfach an Huckel.
Also eine Sache vielleicht noch zu dem iPad, wo wir gerade noch beim iPad sind. Was mich auch so ein bisschen wundert ist, diese, also dieses iPad wird jetzt so groß beschworen als die Alternative zum Mac. Du brauchst gar keinen Mac, du willst dein iPad haben. Dann gehen die Leute den Laden, kaufen sich das, aber du kannst ja noch nicht mal die Software auf diesem iPad aktualisieren, ohne einen Mac zu haben.
Dann kannst du den nicht mal benutzen.
Oder einen PC.
Musst du den jetzt zum Aktivieren?
Ja, aktivieren kannst du das auch im Store.
Mittlerweile?
Das machen die schon für dich.
War jetzt nicht aktivieren so mit iPhone, oh nee, die haben doch vor ewigen Zeit das schon geändert, oder?
Ich glaub man muss sogar einen iPod aktivieren.
Du sagtest nichts, steckt das hier mit deinem Kabel mal an den Rechner?
Doch, doch, das macht's.
Ja, aber du kannst dir das da, also ich bin relativ sicher, dass du ein iPad beim Apple Store kaufen kannst und du latsch da raus und hast sozusagen ein funktionierendes Gerät. Aber was machst du, wenn jetzt ein Software-Update kommt und du hast nur ein iPad?
Gehst du in deinen Laden?
Ja, aber kannst du nicht alle zwei Tage in den Laden rennen, um festzustellen, dass du ein Software-Update hast? Ist ja nicht so, dass es hier irgendwas anzeigen würde, dass es eins gäbe. Weil das zeigt dir nur dein Mac an. Mit deinem Musikprogramm. Dein Musikprogramm zeigt dir an, dass dein Computer ein Software-Update hat. Das ist ja ungefähr so, als ob dein Mac seine Software-Updates bekommen würde, weil dein MP3-Player den beim Aldi geschoppt hast und in eine rote Lampe leuchtet.
Was ja lustig wäre. Wobei, wer kein Mac hat, den...
Software-Update-Gerät. Nur 1999.
Dongle, Update-Dongle.
Wobei, wer nur ein iPad hat und keinen Desktop-Rechner dazu, der ist mit einem Software-Update... Das heißt nicht, dass er keins braucht, aber der weiß es ja eh nicht. Der weiß es ja eh nicht, dass er eins verpassen könnte.
Aber es geht ja auch. Und es gibt jetzt ein iOS-Gerät, was das kann. Na, Apple TV. Das neue Apple TV hat jetzt sein Update bekommen und selbst gesagt, es gibt ein Update, hier ist das Update und installiert dieses Update ohne... Also diese Funktionalität ist in iOS drin. Aber sie ist nicht auf dem iPad, sie ist nicht auf dem iPhone. Aber dass diese Systeme können das. Wir können schwer davon ausgehen, dass dieses Apple TV technisch mit so einem iPad oder mit einem iPhone oder beidem extrem ähnlich ist. Also bis zu fast dasselbe.
Also ich sehe, mir ist das auch schon aufgefallen, hey, die können ja ein Over-See-Air-Update oder wie auch immer das jetzt heißt. Over-See-Air. Ich glaube, dass sie das extra fürs Apple TV gebaut haben, dass sie das vorher noch nicht konnten. Und es gibt natürlich schon ein paar Unterschiede zu den anderen Geräten, weil du hast eine deutlich schnellere Internetverbindung an so einem Apple TV dran, im Zweifelsfall. Und die Gefahr ist nicht halb so hoch, dass dir mittendrin der Strom abhanden kommt und ähnliche Späße. Naja, du kannst jetzt bei einem iPhone, da kannst du nicht zwangsläufig davon ausgehen, dass die Person jetzt die ganze Zeit im WLAN hängt und so was.
Muss ja auch nicht. Du kannst ja sagen, das gibt's nur im WLAN. So wie du auch nur deine YouTube-Videos in groß nur im WLAN anguckst, kannst du Video-Facetime nur im WLAN machen.
Ja, ich glaube, aber das wird einfach noch, das Apple TV ist die Testplattform dafür, ob das auch vernünftig geht. Und dann führen sie es irgendwann auch bei den anderen Geräten ein.
Ja, das kann ich nur schwer hoffen, aber tatsächlich verkaufen sie derzeit halt ein iPad, mit der Idee, dass das sozusagen dein einziger Computer sein könnte. Ihr Oma jetzt dein... Ich würde nicht sagen, dass sie das jetzt besonders betonen, aber es ist schon im Raum, dass das iPad versucht, ein eigenständiges Teil zu sein für Leute. Und die Botschaft, dass das aber eigentlich ein Accessory für deinen Computer ist, die sehe ich halt nirgendswo, aber es ist die Wahrheit.
Na, ich glaube, das ist...
Den müssten wir an den Preis noch dranschreiben. Kostet 500 Euro, Sternchen oder Macintosh Not Included.
Da kannst du ja auch ein Windows-PC nehmen. Holst du irgendwie so ein Netbook für 200 Euro dazu. Als Update, die weiß. Aber ich glaube, als das iPad ausgeliefert wurde, da konnte das noch nicht mal Multitasking, wie wir uns alle dunkel dran erinnern. Also eigentlich bis vor zwei Wochen oder wann kam?
Ja gut, aber Multitasking ist was vollkommen anderes, als du brauchst noch ein 1500 Euro Gerät, damit du dein 500 Euro Gerät aktualisieren kannst. Ja, aber was ist denn das für ein Scheißdreck?
Naja, aber du brauchst noch ein Zusatzgerät, um da ein größeres Maß Musik drauf zu kriegen. Ich glaube, das wird kommen. Außerdem, Apple bewirbt das im Augenblick gar nicht, als kauft ihr stattdessen keinen Mac. Das ist schon sehr deutlich, einen kaufst du zusätzlich zu deinem Mac. Kauft dir zwei Macs und ein iPad.
Aber in keiner Werbung siehst du ein Mac-Unternehmen, neben dem iPad.
Du hast aber auch bei der iPod-Werbung nie einen Mac gesehen, weil es geht da um den iPod. Da war auch jedem klar, dass du mit dem iPod alleine nicht weit kommst.
Na ja gut, aber auf dem iPod hast du halt auch nicht Programme und so weiter. Also... Das war schon so gedacht, dass du deine Musiklaborier da drauf hast. Und die ist halt auf deinem Computer. Also es ist schon noch ein bisschen was anderes. Anyway, es ist auf jeden Fall das, was ich als nächstes erwarte. Aber ich wundere mich, dass das nicht viele dem iPad vorwerfen. Und es ist auch immer noch das, was mich davon abhält, dass jemanden zu kaufen. Also hier diese klassische Oma, Eltern, brauchen einen Computer und wollen auch mal ins Internet-Geschichte. Ich würde sofort losgehen und ein iPad dahinschenken, wenn ich in der Lage wäre, das Teil irgendwie eigenständig einzurichten. Und dann weiß ich in dem Moment, wo ich es aus der Hand gebe, vielleicht mit so einem 3G-Plan, den man selber bezahlt oder so. Ja, aber das Ding aktualisiert sich selber, das Ding lebt selber und ich muss da nicht alle zwei Monate hinfahren mit meinem Laptop, um dieses Gerät neu zu beatmen, Sicherheit-Updates einzuspielen oder sonst irgendwas. Weil das können die ja dann gar nicht leisten. Man denkt nur an dieser PDF-Bug, der in iOS drin war, der richtig hardcore scheiße war, richtig hardcore gefährlich war. Der meines Wissens keine konkrete Malware zwar nach sich gezogen hat, aber mit dem du das halt Jail breaken konntest. Und wenn du das Jail breaken konntest, dann konntest du damit im Prinzip alles machen.
Das kannst du ja bis heute mit den älteren Geräten.
Ja, wenn sie halt nicht das Software-Update haben.
Nee, fürs erste Alkoholgipfel gehabt.
Ja genau, das hatten wir ja auch schon mal. Okay, das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Aber gut, ich finde es nicht gut. Ich prangere das an. Ich prangere das an.
Also jetzt würde ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt gar kein iPad verschenken, sondern dann würde ich jetzt noch bis zur nächsten Generation warten.
Ja, wie lange soll man noch warten?
Der eine Kamera drin hat.
Und Light Connector. Diese optische Connector, der gerumort wird. Lightpeak. Und das Retina-Display.
Du bist jetzt bei dem Next-Generation-iPad oder wo bist du?
Ja, weil Max gerade sagte, ich warte auch bis zur nächsten Generation.
Also ich hab ja eins, ich brauch ja nicht bis zur nächsten Generation zu warten.
Ich schon.
Ich warte auch.
Ich will Retina-Display, aber hatten wir auch schon alles. Wir wollten jetzt Gnustap.
Du wolltest Gnustap?
Ich wollte Gnustap von dir.
Was hab ich damit zu tun?
Vorhin warst du doch ganz enthusiastisch.
Worüber?
Dieses ganze Thema.
Was du immer alles so denkst, was ich enthusiastisch begleite. Also, was ist denn die Story? Sony, das ist halt so eine Tritmine. Sony ist doch diese Firma, die...
Erfinder des Walkmans.
Genau, die mit den Fernsehern. Und die auch mal mit der Playstation durchaus einen Hit hatten. Und jetzt weiß ich grad nicht mehr ganz genau, wofür haben sie dieses SDK angekündigt?
Für die Playstation Portable? Für irgendwelche Touch-Interfaces. Warte, ich guck nochmal nach.
Wie ist der Name von diesem SDK?
Apple Insider Gnus-Dap. So, Sony adopts den Drops Cocoa-like Gnus-Dap. Und zwar für... Ach komm, Internet gibt es mir.
Voll gut vorbereitet die Sendung heute, was?
Soll ich mal hier kurz zwischendurch was erzählen?
Ja.
Man kann jetzt, die Nerd Barbie ist jetzt verfügbar. Man kann sie jetzt kaufen. Irgendwann hat auch Mattel angekündigt, so eine Nerd Barbie, die so einen kleinen Laptop hat und ein Handy und jetzt offensichtlich hat sich seit dem Vorfilmmodell das Handymodell geändert. Und zwar vorher war es so ein richtiger Knochen und jetzt hat es ein iPhone.
Natürlich.
Ein rosaes iPhone.
Es gibt ja auch die Steve Jobs Action Figure, aber...
Steve Jobs und die Barbie.
Touch-based mobile devices. Sollte es schon sein.
Ja, aber was haben die denn für Touch-based mobile devices?
Na die verkaufen auch Android-Telefone und Windows-Mobile-Telefone.
Sony.
Die haben auch so ein, wie heißt...
Weil die haben ja nichts Eigenes.
Doch, doch, die haben doch so eine Art Radio-Wecker, auf den du eigene Software drauf spielen kannst.
Da reden wir nächste Sendung drüber, okay? Das klicken wir jetzt alle über unsere Affiliate Links.
Nee, aber dieses Gnus-Tab, ja? Also ich kann ja ein bisschen was erzählen. Weil 2006 hab ich irgendwie so ein Programm gekodet und dann meint der Auftraggeber, er hätte ja auch gerne, dass das Zeug unter Linux läuft. Ich hab's überlegt so mit Kumpel, weil wir haben zu zweit gemacht. Ja, könnte man theoretisch machen. Da gibt's ja irgendwie so GnuStab. Und der so, ja, alles klar, macht mal, kriegt's halt irgendwie noch mal extra cool. Haben wir uns irgendwie rangesetzt. Irgendwie mit diesem Linux, das war so schon ein Drama, war mal nicht so zu Hause, war schon mal alles nervig. Dann irgendwie dieses GnuStab an den Start kriegen. So und dann denkst du, alles klar, musst halt so ein paar Änderungen machen und dann läuft das Zeug unter GnuStab. Aber so einfach war das halt nicht. Dann hat Apple halt lauter Sachen, die die bei GnuStab irgendwie noch nicht so haben oder leicht anders sind. Und auch wenn's halt so in den tiefsten Ecken ist, wo sich dann was anders verhält, aber du musst dann... also das war irgendwie ein Drama.
Aber du hast trotzdem dein Innes-Object da?
Jaja, also GnuStab ist richtig. NS-String, weil die haben ja mal mit irgendwie Next-Stab, dann hieß es ja Open-Stab, wollten ja auch mit Sun irgendwie was zu machen und so weiter, mit dieser Yellowbox und was es da nicht alles gab. Jedenfalls gibt's das alles einmal in offen. Und das ist halt dieses GnuStab. Aber das ist schon ganz schön kompatibel bei den grundsätzlichen Sachen, aber bei allem, was ein bisschen neu ist, das haben die halt auch erst gar nicht. Also, die haben schon die normalen Buttons und die Strings. Das weiß ich, hab ich seitdem nicht verfolgt. Aber das war nicht so richtig schick. Aber es funktioniert, muss man schon sagen. Aber halt auch da hier mit dem Interface-Bild oder was die da hat, wie auch immer das jetzt bei denen da hieß, das war alles irgendwie ein Drama. Also das ist alles nicht so schön. Also wenn man auf dem Mac halt irgendwie mit Xcode arbeitet oder damals hieß es ja auch noch, wie ist das? Seit wann hieß das? Was hieß denn das vor Xcode? Keine Ahnung.
Gab es da nicht nur Codeviva vorher oder sowas? Von irgendwie so einer anderen Bude?
Codeviva meinst du?
Codeviva war ja für C-Programmierende. Das hatte ja mit diesem Cocoa-Zeugs nichts zu tun. Sie hatten auch keinen Interface-Bilder. Interface-Bilder gab es schon immer nur von Apple oder Next-Step vorher.
Vorgänger von Xcode, das ist natürlich jetzt mal wirklich eine spannende Sache.
Project-Bilder? Project-Bilder.
Achso, und dann war der Interface-Bilder dazu.
Interface-Bilder und Project-Bilder, deswegen hießen die auch früher nips, weil die hießen Next-Step-Interface-Bilder. Und jetzt haben sie es ja unbedingt nach Xzip, so Xcode-Interface-Bilder. Wobei da nichts mehr Interface-Bilder heißt. Jetzt ist er ganz weg, weil bei Xcode 4 ist er integriert irgendwie in ihr Single-Screen-Dings-Modus und so weiter. Aber ich glaube auch der größte Hässel, wenn ich mich jetzt genau erinnere, war gar nicht mal Gnushtabs, sondern der größte Hässel war, als diese Linux-Applikation dann wirklich irgendwann mal fertig war, die so zu bauen, dass du irgendwie eine Binary-Distribution hast, die auf allen Linuxen läuft, weil da gab es ja tausende und verschiedene Versionen und hast du nicht gesehen. Und das war das Schlimmste an allem. Aber das ist eigentlich eine ganz andere Ecke. Also das Gnushtab funktioniert so einigermaßen, aber so schön ist auch anders. Weil manchmal Mac kommt zumindest.
Ja und jetzt hat Sony gesagt, machen wir. Und dann haben sie aber gleich gesagt, machen wir erstmal einen Holt.
Was ist denn das bitte für, was ist denn da los?
Da ist was geleakt und dann musst du gleich wieder dementieren oder wie?
Ja vor allem, also erstens verstehe ich nicht, warum sie sich überhaupt für Gnushtab entscheiden.
Ja hat man jetzt in den letzten Jahren jedenfalls nicht so wahnsinnig viele News von gehört.
Naja vor allem, was würde denn das für sie bedeuten? Ich meine Gnushtab versucht ja im Prinzip immer Apple hinterher zu poamieren. Mit anderen Worten, sie sind sozusagen bei Default immer hinterher.
Aber das ist auch der einzige Default.
Ja, das ist also Sony würde sich quasi für eine Plattform entscheiden, die bei Default immer hinter Apple herläuft.
Ja wieso? Sie könnten doch auch einfach eigene Änderungen einbringen, die man dann sogar wieder auf Mac OS X wieder zurückportieren müsste.
Mit welcher Expertise? Also ich meine das ist...
Sie könnten daraus aus dieser bestehenden Plattform... Ich meine, es gab da mal so eine Firma, die hatte ein total schlechtes Betriebssystem und war total hinterher und ist dann auf die Idee gekommen, sich eine Hardware-Bude einzukaufen.
Ja, aber wenn sie sozusagen diesen Nutzen abgreifen wollen, dass alle Entwickler quasi mit dieser Plattform ohnehin schon arbeiten, dann müssen sie auch allem hinterher jetten, was Apple ihnen vorlegt. Zum Beispiel Garbage Collection. Das ist doch da bestimmt noch nicht drin. Bestimmt nicht.
Vielleicht geht es ihnen ja gar nicht so sehr darum, die ganzen Entwickler abzugreifen, sondern vielleicht geht es ihnen in erster Linie darum, erstmal ein System zu haben, was läuft, was ordentlich ist, was eine gewisse Stabilität hat und das dann zu erweitern. Genauso wie Android halt darum auf Linux basiert, weil sie einen stabilen Kern haben wollten und eine stabile Api halbwegs und darauf ihr Zeug aufflanschen wollten. Und Treiber und Konsorten.
Aber es wirkt halt schon trotzdem alles immer noch...
Ja und dann rudern sie wieder zurück. Also war das jetzt gar nicht so... Hat sich da nur jemand verplappert oder war das irgendwie gar nicht jemals beschlossen? Völlig unklar.
Ich könnte mir jetzt gut vorstellen, dass das zuerst haben sie sich gar nichts beigebracht, hat irgendjemand so eine kleine Entwicklungsabteilung angefangen, irgendwie so unter dem Radar vom Management und dann kommt plötzlich die Nachricht, dass Sony irgendwas entwickelt, was irgendwie an Apple erinnert und dann dreht da irgendein Sony-Manager am Rad und sägt sofort dieses Projekt ab, drei Tage später und hat es nicht verstanden, warum. Weil er sagt, was Apple macht und wir müssen unabhängig sein.
Die Sony-Jungs, die haben echt verloren jetzt.
Wäre jetzt so eine Möglichkeit?
Die sind alle so, ich verstehe das überhaupt gar nicht, warum diese ganzen Buden nicht in der Lage sind, sich eine ordentliche Software-Strategie zu geben. Auch da muss ich sagen, wie der Lob dem Microsoft, also die sind da zumindest in der Lage, überhaupt irgendwas an Start zu kriegen, was sie aus ihrem eigenen, also sie machen zumindest alles aus ihrem eigenen Saft heraus. Ich mag das nicht, meistens. Und sie rennen ja auch mit einer ganzen Menge Sachen gegen die Wand, aber sie sind zumindest in der Lage, eine Software-Strategie zu definieren und auch irgendwie durchzuhalten, koste was es wolle. Aber wenn du dir jetzt diesen Mobilmarkt anschaust, um den ja gerade dieses Schlachtentbrand ist, gut, Google hat Androids. Naja, gut, ich mein, auch denen gestehe ich zu, dass sie da eine Plattform-Strategie haben. Ob die gut ist, ist jetzt noch eine andere Geschichte, aber sie haben zumindest eine. Guck dir Blackberry, was machen die? Jetzt haben die irgendwie ihr klassisches OS, dann haben sie sich QNX gekauft, interessanter Move, gutes OS, dann brauchen sie aber jetzt noch einen GUI, wollen jetzt auch Tablets machen, was holen sie sich ins Boot? Adobe. Das heißt, ihre potenziell wichtigste Zukunft, diese Mobilplattform auch auf diesen Tablet-Faktor hinzuentwickeln, strategische Entscheidungen zu fällen, da klammern die sich an Adobe. Das heißt, sie sind sozusagen, sie stehen und fallen mit Adobe. Wenn Adobe das irgendwie verkackt mit ihrem R, stehen sie irgendwie blöde da. Also ich glaube nicht, ich halte das einfach nicht für eine gute Strategie. Man muss als Plattform-Anbieter in der Lage sein, sowas auch selber in Hand zu haben und selber entwickeln zu können. Das ist bei Google immerhin der Fall. Sony kommt jetzt mit diesem Gnu-Step-Kram hoch, was ich irgendwie für, weiß ich nicht, ein ungelegtes Ei halte. Und so stellt sich das ja jetzt auch irgendwie dar.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das jemals eine wirklich große offizielle Strategie von denen war.
Naja, ich sag nur, die haben halt irgendwie alle keinen Plan. Und Nokia hat zwar im Prinzip was, kann sich aber irgendwie nicht festlegen oder ist nicht in der Lage, das Festgelegte zu kommunizieren. Weil eigentlich läuft alles auf ihr, ja, jetzt heißt es auf einmal MeeGo, hab ich schon wieder vergessen, wie es vorher hieß. Das ist alles eine Konfusion mit QT, aber trotzdem bringen sie halt immer noch Symbian-Telefone raus.
Hab ich mir so eingelassen. Das ist aber eigentlich ja total, was ich das gehört hab.
Das könnte euch so passen, dass ich das QT nenne.
Ich glaube, du interpretierst da Strategien rein, wo keine sind. Ich glaube, das ist Nokia und Sony und so. Das sind Riesenkonzerne, wo Rivalitäten innerhalb des Konzerns existieren.
Doch, bei Nokia nennt man das schon Strategie. Also ich hab mich auch mit einem Developer unterhalten, der bei Nokia arbeitet, den ich schon länger kenne. Und seine Faszination für das Nokia-Telefon, was er dabei hatte, konnte ich nicht teilen, weil das war halt auch die klassische Developer-View. Er hat so ein Slide-out-Keyboard-Teil da irgendwie ausgepackt. Und hier guck mal, mein Terminal ist doch toll.
Ich hab mal beim Mittagessen ein paar Nokia-Entwickler kennengelernt. So zufällig, das war es an seinem Tisch wie die. Und dann haben wir danach noch Telefonnummern ausgetauscht. Und die holen alle ihre Nokia-Telefonen raus. Ich hol mein iPhone raus. Und wirklich alle so, oh, ich hätte so gern so ein iPhone. Das war aber wirklich so, das war echt lustig. Ja, aber ich glaube, dann behaupten sie, dass es eine Strategie wäre, weil es das Beste ist, was sie haben. Ich glaube, das ist ein riesen Konzern und den muss der erst mal unter Kontrolle bringen. Und ich glaube, das ist das Wesentliche, was Steve Jobs da auf die Reihe kriegt. Dafür werden ihn genug Leute hassen und wahrscheinlich auch zurecht, aber er hält diesen Laden zusammen und schafft sowas wie eine Strategie. Und bei Sony hast du da, guck mal, in einer Ecke, dass der Firma irgendwelche Fernseher produziert werden, in der nächsten wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich weiß der Sony-Chef nicht, was die alles produzieren. Ist einfach viel zu groß der Laden.
Das ist Yamaha. Also wie man ja, ich hab ja irgendwann mal gelernt, dass es Yamaha heißt. Yamaha? Und nicht Yamaha. Das ist ja Yamaha. Yamaha ist ein ganz anderer Konzern, weil die machen ja irgendwie so von Klavier bis Außenbordmotoren, Motorräder, Unterhaltungselektronik, Mischpulte.
Diese Sendung wird live zusammengemischt mit Yamaha Technologie.
Yamaha. Yamaha.
So viele Affiliate-Things können wir gar nicht wissen, wie das läuft.
Dann sollten wir aber unseren Podcast auch Mobile-Max nennen.
Nein, Mac-Hackers oder irgendetwas anderes. Aber egal, ich glaube, Yamaha ist irgendwie echt besser organisiert. Ich glaube, die haben irgendwie einen besseren Plan, obwohl die noch eine preisere Produktpalette haben als Sony. Sony ist bestimmt so ein Monster-Mega-Corporation.
Yamaha ist viele Konzerte auf einmal.
Also, ich hab mal auf Wikipedia die Geschichte von diesem Yamaha-Typ.
Es kommt doch bestimmt gleich wieder Nils im Chat und kritisiert uns hier für unsere japanischen Allüren. Los, Nils, komm.
Hä, haben wir japanische Allüren?
Ich nicht.
Wie man das richtig ausspricht und so weiter.
Der hat aber nur Schwerter gebaut.
Das wird total Sushi.
Da gibt es auch dieses schöne Lied von Humpe Humpe, das sind noch so neue deutsche Wellezeiten. Kennt ihr das noch? So Inga Humpe, die so mit Zweirohmwohnung jetzt immer noch so Die beiden Humpeschwestern? Die beiden Humpeschwestern, genau.
Damals, wo man noch schwarze Terminates hatte.
Und das Lied heißt... Also mal das ruhig mal raus. Das ist bestimmt auf YouTube. Das Lied besteht aus japanischen Firmennamen. Und so geht das ganze Lied über nur aus japanischen Filmenamen. Das ist ganz großartig. Ich glaube, Yamaha...
Die japanischen Firmennamen sind eigentlich immer Familiennamen.
Das heißt Yamaha... Was ist das hier?
Das sind einfach nur ganz normale Familiennamen. Obwohl Suzuki heißt wie Falke oder sowas. Oder was war das? Irgendwas Ähnliches.
Endlich reden wir über Themen, von denen wir richtig Ahnung haben.
Ja, wir sind ja auch schon wieder bei unserem Limit angekommen. Dann sinkt immer das Niveau, bis wir es merken. Das ist ja auch das berühmte neue Wort, Niveau-Limbo.
Genau, wir benutzen jetzt Jugendsprache, um besonders logisch rüber zu kommen.
Logisch. Wir benutzen es, sondern wir machen das, wir setzen uns gleich um.
Hire Buza ist der Falke, wurde hier gerade gesagt.
Und was war dann Suzuki? War da auch irgendwie sowas?
Such doch Google Translate mal.
Wo sind wir denn in den Chat hier, Jungs? Ihr müsst auch mal was tun, das nennt man Interaktiv-Chat hier.
Ach, echt Interaktiv-Chat jetzt?
Wir können auch eigentlich Schluss machen, ich hab hier noch so ein paar Sachen, aber wir sind irgendwie... Was denn, wo du es zuckerst, ist ja nicht hinaus.
Ich weiß, ich seh's ja nicht. Was hast du denn noch?
Ach, das sind so Füller irgendwie.
Füller.
Naja, so Sachen, die mir immer wieder auffallen, dass sie toll sind.
Ach so, ich wollte ja eigentlich nur über Blogsoftware ran, ne? Ich hab mir ja dieses Blog da auf Tumblr geklickt, ne? Und ich dachte mir, ok, diesmal mach ich's nicht selber. Und diesmal nämlich jetzt hoste ich auch nicht selber in WordPress oder irgendwas, sondern ich geh jetzt entweder zu Posteros oder Tumblr. Superio ist eigentlich von vornherein ausgeschieden, weil die einfach zu schlecht performen und sowieso viel zu oft offline sind leider. Auch wenn ich deren Interface ganz schick finde. Und dann hab ich mir Posteros angeguckt und das fand ich irgendwie zu überladen und zu komisch. Und dann hab ich mich für Tumblr entschieden. Und Tumblr war so auf dem ersten Klick ganz gut, aber ist halt auch viel zu limitiert und hat irgendwie so ganz bescheidene Limitierung. Also wenn du irgendwie einen Fotopost machst, ja, und du klickst dann auf das Foto, dann kriegst du ein Ajax-Overlay und es wird groß. Wenn du aber in einem Textpost ein Foto embeddest, dann geht das nicht und so ein Krempel halt alles, ne? Das ist ja alles furchtbar. 2001 und bloggen ist immer noch ein Krampf.
Das ist schlimm, oder?
Ja, also auch dieses WordPress mit diesen unendlichen Plug-In-Arien, wo dann das eine Plug-In ja das andere zerschießt und dann baust du da irgendwie eine Silbentrennungs-Plug-In ein, was dir dann aber irgendwie das Pretty- oder Tidy-HTML-Plug-In zerschießt und dann, ach nee, das macht aber keinen Spaß.
Ich muss jetzt mal wieder ein paar Plug-Ins bauen für WordPress und das ist die totale Hölle. Das ist wirklich so unerträglich. Das sind so monolithische Funktionen, die Arrays von Argumenten entgegengenommen kriegen, wo dann drei verschiedene Schreibweisen irgendwie zu einer verbunden werden und wo dann Dinge, die du normalerweise als Array erwartest, plötzlich als Komma separiert ist, irgendwas übergeben werden müssen und so.
Das muss man als einen PHP-Storm oder wie hieß das?
PHP-Storm ist super. Wenn man PHP macht, ist PHP-Storm super.
Also ich hab ja schon angefangen. Ich hab jetzt schon so einen Blog-Repo angelegt lokal. Ich hab's noch nicht auf GitHub gepusht.
Oh, na dann.
Aber ich bin drauf und dran. Also ich hab jetzt da den ganzen Schrott ja, also nicht Schrott, den ganzen Inhalt draufgeschoben. Das ging auch irgendwie, aber ich hab echt viel zu viel Zeit damit verbracht, nur diesen Tumblr zu resten, dass der Content so aussieht, wie ich haben will. Ich hab jetzt echt keine hohen Ansprüche gehabt, aber ich will halt in einem Textpost auch ein Video embedden oder in einem Textpost auch ein Foto embedden können mit irgendwie Lightbox und Großzoom und es wehrt sich einfach. Und dann machst du in einem Foto... Ja, dann machst du halt in einem Foto-Post mehrere Fotos und dann macht der dir so eine bekloppte Slideshow da draus, die du aber auch gar nicht haben willst. Und dann geht auch nicht diese Lightbox auf. Und dann sagst du schon da nicht mal. Und dann kriegen sie es ja nicht mal gebacken, dir die simpelsten Statistiken anzuzeigen.
Ja, okay, mach einen Blog. Und ich sag dir, was für Podcast-Features da rein müssen. Und wir sind Stars.
Ja, werden wir zu Tode geflattert. Das Risiko nehm ich hinten auf. Ich würd die Blog-Software nämlich auch Geld kosten lassen, hab ich mir überlegt, sowieso.
Genau, wir verkaufen das dann.
Zehn Euro. Die Lizenz. Dann habt ihr da draußen dann irgendwie Leute, die sich drum kümmern und...
Genau, das ist dann die erste Blog-Software in Ruby, die auch was taugt sozusagen. Da brauchst du aber auch noch so eine moderne, hippe Datenbank dahinter.
Weiß nicht, mir gefällt MongoDB einfach besser. Ich könnte jetzt irgendwie erzählen, was ich an MongoDB toll finde. Aber CouchDB hat auch coole Features. Also ich bin da nicht so ganz emotional, aber irgendwie hat mir MongoDB bis auf den Namen bisher mehr zugesagt. Und es tut einfach das, was ich in dem Fall brauche. Und das würde CouchDB wahrscheinlich ähnlich gut hinbekommen. Also das einzige, was mir so spontan als Argument einfällt, ist halt, dass du bei MongoDB dynamische Finder hast und nicht die vorher definieren musst, die Views. Das ist ein Punkt. Und du hast Native Drivers und musst nicht immer über das HTTPJS-Interface. Und noch ein Feature fällt mir da gerade ein. Ihre Geo-Implementation ist besser als die bei CouchDB.
Die ist bei Couch wirklich scheiße.
Da sind sie bei MongoDB auch ein bisschen hinterher.
Und wie viele Stunden haben wir jetzt schon? Haben wir die vier schon wieder voll gemacht?
Drei von Millionen von Sternen.
Was sind denn noch mal vier Stunden in Minuten? Ja, ja, wir sind knapp dran. Wir machen einfach noch ein bisschen Musik hinterher, dann haben wir die vier Stunden.
Was gibt's denn noch hier auf dem Teller?
Ich nehm alles, geschmeißt mir ein Thema zu.
Alles außer Tiernahrung.
Also ich hab ja noch zwei Mac-Tools, jetzt wo du so drauf bestehst, dann kann man das irgendwie auch noch machen. Also es gibt eine Alternative zur Little Snitch, die ich jetzt noch nicht so richtig bis zu Ende getestet hab, aber soweit wie ich sie getestet habe.
Wie heißt sie denn?
Die heißt Hands Off.
Und macht die auch bidirektional oder macht die auch nur outgoing?
Na die...
Erklär doch erstmal was Little Snitch ist für unsere Anfänger-Hörer.
Ich glaube es macht outgoing im Wesentlichen und nicht incoming. Und ist halt so eine Personal Firewall, um zu verhindern, dass bestimmte Programme zu gesprächig sind. Und es ist wirklich extrem ähnlich zu Little Snitch auch im User-Interface. Also es ist schon wirklich so ein direkter Abklatsch für aber billiger. Abklatsch macht aber einen ordentlichen Eindruck und ist so vom User-Interface vielleicht noch so ein Zacken besser. Sieht nicht schlecht aus auf dem Screen. Ja, es ist so mit diesen Defaults, ist ja immer so diese Entscheidung, wie machst du das jetzt? Und jetzt ist immer so, wenn ein Programm das erste Mal bei Hands-Off so auftaucht, dann kannst du dafür generell erstmal ein Default geben. Kannst du mir sagen, so ja generell erstmal Network Usage erlauben. Ah ja, und im Gegensatz zu Little Snitch macht es auch die Sperre.
Es macht auch Incoming.
Es macht auch Incoming?
Ja, hier gibt es so eine Feature-Liste, wo es gegen Little Snitch kommt.
Und es macht auch Fall frei. Jetzt weiß ich auch wieder, warum ich das überhaupt erwähnt habe, weil es nämlich sozusagen die Programme in der Sandbox startet. Also es benutzt sozusagen die Sandbox-Features von OS X und kann halt auch so File Writing verhindern. Das heißt, du kannst halt auch Programme starten und den irgendwie Zugriff auf irgendwas verhindern.
Ja, voll win.
Ja, sieht schon extrem nach Little Snitch aus, ne?
Ja, ja, es ist wirklich extrem inspiriert, aber es tut mehr Dinge und...
Ist von den gleichen Leuten vielleicht?
Nee, ich kann es, also ich kann es, ich hab es auch noch nicht gekauft. Ich hab es von daher auch nur so ein bisschen. Man kann es aber länger testen als Little Snitch, weil es alle vier Stunden stoppt es für fünf Minuten. Also es ist noch relativ fair, um das sozusagen zu testen.
Ja, Little Snitch muss man wieder einschalten, einfach nach vier Stunden oder irgendwie so was.
Ja, ist irgendwie anders. Auf jeden Fall, ich glaub, der schaltet sich auch wieder automatisch ein. Angucken ist interessant. Mich würden Ergebnisse interessieren. Ich hab noch nicht so richtig viel damit gearbeitet. Ich hab's halt eine Weile mal angehabt und es hat mich gestört und es gefiel mir vom User Interface her. Und es hatte halt einfach interessante Features. Ich hatte jetzt keine Programme, die nicht das Dateischreiben untersagen wollte. Und von daher, aber da ist eben diese Sandbox Features von 10.5 benutzt, ist es in seiner Implementierung eben auch sehr interessant. Auch. 10.5 hab ich gesagt. 10 Sandboxen kam mit 10.5 oder 10.6?
Die da fischen im Boden.
Nach vier Stunden kann ich jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Alle Tja auf den Sack.
Und wo wir jetzt auch noch bei geilen Tools sind, muss man mal so einen Klassiker nennen. Nach dem Motto Tools, die mir immer wieder Freude machen, wenn mir einfällt, dass sie da sind und in dem Moment ein interessantes Problem lösen.
Ping.
Weißt du jetzt Ping, dieses Social-Network?
Social-Network.
Das löst keine Probleme, die ich schon vorher hatte. Und zwar, manchmal kommen ja so merkwürdige Tools, die einem suspekt sind. Am besten noch mit so einem suspekten Installer. Weißt du so ein...
Wo du erstmal Rootpasswort eingeben musst.
Irgendwie so komische Sachen. Und du traust dem Scheiß nicht, aber du willst es trotzdem unbedingt installieren.
Verbotene Sache.
Ja, aber so mit Skripten. Und du willst einfach wissen, was macht das eigentlich wirklich auf meiner Platte. Und da ist dieses Tool FS Eventer cool. Hatten wir das schon mal. Aber es hat sich auch eine Menge getan bei FS Eventer. Das kann man auf jeden Fall sich nochmal angucken. Und es gibt ja auch mal noch Leute, die das noch nicht gehört haben. FS Eventer nutzt halt diese... Also hat diesen merkwürdigen Namen, weil es eben auf diesen File System Events, die es glaube ich seit 10... Gibt oder so? Oder 10.3? Das ist schon eine Weile. Das heißt, es ist in der Lage, alle Zugriffe auf das Datalsystem zu protokollieren. Und macht das dann in so einem riesigen Graph. Und du kannst halt sagen, irgendwie starte, recorde jetzt und dann startest du deinen Installer. Solltest dann aber möglichst wenig andere Programme haben, weil natürlich jegliche Aktivität aufzeichnet. Das heißt, wenn du irgendein hyperaktives Tool gerade laufen hast, was auch noch in der Festplatte rummalt, dann ist blöd. Aber wenn du es eben isolieren kannst, am besten den Finder auch noch beenden, nur diesen Installer starten und FS Event damit laufen lassen, dann hast du halt ein relativ cooles Protokoll, wo halt überall irgendwelche Dateien angelegt werden.
Das ist ja auch die Command Line Variante, Open Snoop. Heißt das glaub ich, ne? Open Snoop. Nur kurz die Tab Completion im Terminal testen. Und damit kannst du auch dann auf Prozess-IDs dich draufhängen, also in einem Activity-Monitor, die die Pit rausgefunden hast von deinem Tool, was du beobachten willst. Dann kannst du auch mit Open Snoop genau dich auf die Pit hängen und siehst dann auch im Terminal halt welche Files aufgehend sind.
Das ist natürlich noch schicker. Dann hast du auch gleich so einen schönen Text-Log.
Genau, man kann es halt auch ab viel F drinnen machen im Terminal und so. Also Open Snoop, das habe ich mal auf, wie heißt das? Stack Overflow, dieses Portal da gefunden. Da gab es so einen Thread dazu mit den coolsten Terminal-Tools und manchmal klicke ich auch auf sowas rauf und tata. Open Snoop war schön. Nee, das ist ein OS X Tool, ist dabei. Hast du schon auf Platte?
Echt? Gross?
Hier, ich paste mal den Link in den Chat von diesem Super User Thread. Guck an, mit die Trace und so. Und da ist auch dieses Open Snoop-Exam.
Ich empel liefer halt einen Command Line Utility aus, was mit Open anfängt.
Ja, und du kannst auch, genau, was halt auch cool ist, du kannst ein bestimmtes File angeben und er guckt drauf und zeigt dir an, welche Programme auf dieses File zugreifen. Zum Beispiel, hier in diesem Beispiel ist es ETC PassWD oder sowas. Also es ist halt an sich ein echt cooles Tool, weil manchmal will man eben genau wissen, welcher Prozess macht denn jetzt welche Files auf oder welcher Prozess, oder was macht denn der Prozess überhaupt für scheiß? Genau. Ja, diese Command Line Tools gibt es ja sowieso irgendwie echt so viel.
Da sollten wir immer mal wieder was aufgreifen. Ein anderes Tool, was ich schon mal erwähnt habe, was jetzt so mit dem Fallsystemlevel so nichts zu tun hat, was lange Zeit keine Aktualisierung erfahren hat, was aber auch ganz schön ist, ist Telefon.app. Hab ich das schon mal erwähnt überhaupt?
Nee.
Telefon.app. Nee, stimmt, das hatte ich hier, glaube ich, noch gar nicht erwähnt. Telefon.app ist so eine ganz kleine, super, mega, sleek, simple Macintosh App, die einfach ein SIP-Client ist. Also, die einfach Telefonie macht und zwar genau das. Ohne irgendein bekackiges, ich bin ein Telefon-User-Interface, das den ganzen Spaß wieder zerstört. Das macht einfach nur Menü, ein kleines Fenster, wo du eine Telefonnummer eingibst, zack, retourn und dann telefoniert das Teil. Und das ist jetzt nach langer Zeit mal aktualisiert worden und hat jetzt auch so Call-Forwarding und so eine Geschichten gemacht. Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht getestet, aber generell der Zip-Transport funktioniert wunderbar.
Gib mal einen Link, ich will mal eine Telefon-App bei Google eingestellt haben.
Ich habe genau Telefon und Leerzeichen-App gegeben und ich komme auf diese Google-Code-Seite da gleich her. Da, Telefon. Yeah, man, we're English.
codegoogle.com, Telefon. Genau. Und das ist einfach super schick und ist auch ganz klar, wie du dann die SIP-Adressen in Adressbuch mit einbaust und das ist irgendwie open source und macht growl und irgendwie ist irgendwie cool. Also finde ich, ist auf jeden Fall der Erwähnung wert.
N'avant? N'avant?
N'avant.
Jo, und den Rest, den lassen wir uns irgendwie für später. Wir müssen jetzt hier mal aufhören.
Das ist Schluss.
Ja.
Yamaha.
Muss jetzt noch so lange durchhalten, bis der... Bis Dennis von Toilette......vom Klo wieder da ist.
Bis Dennis wieder vom Klo zurück ist, und da halten wir sich noch mit leisen......Clips.
Mit immer wieder demselben...
Nein, wir machen einfach Schluss. Dennis, willst du noch irgendwas sagen, Dennis? Nö.
Dennis hat nichts zu sagen.
Und insofern würde ich sagen, beenden wir hier diese Session. Und wünschen euch noch viel Spaß. Es war wieder mal eine Sendung, die viel Spaß gemacht hat und die viel zu lang war. Also ist es halt.
Ja, da gibt es ja auch mehr Flätereien dann.
Ja, aber nicht ganz so lame wie gestern.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das mehr bringt oder weniger bringt, ist ja auch eigentlich völlig egal. Der Spaß steht doch im Mittelpunkt.
Hast nur ein Thema, ich mach noch eins.
Schluss. Schluss. Ich ruf die Gewerkschaft an.
Die Podcast-Gewerkschaft.
Okay, wir sagen Winke-Winke und Tschüss.
Dann machen wir Podcast-Gewerkschaft.